[Music]
thank you
it's 11 o'clock this is Sky News live
from Westminster over the next six hours
we'll be assessing what's been dubbed
the growth budget with our political
editor Beth Rigby and our economics and
data editor Ed Conway or Jeremy Hunt
will say the country needs to get back
to work as he outlines his blueprint for
growth
case that goal cheaper child care and
with a plan to provide 30 hours a week
free for one and two-year-olds in
England
on energy and end the prepayment penalty
for the poorest and average bills will
stay at 2 500 pounds for three more
months
the chancellor says he wants stability
over tax cuts but how will that go down
here in Burnley the city with the
highest inflation in the country the
corporation tax rise looks set to stay
Jeremy Hunt could face a back bench
Revolt if he doesn't prioritize business
but no wind of a pay deal as hundreds of
thousands of teachers Junior doctors
tube workers and civil servants all go
on strike
well stay with us throughout the day for
Jamie Hunt's statement and full analysis
of what this budget will mean for you
good morning from Westminster and thank
you for joining us for our special
coverage of the spring budget the
chancellor has made it clear that he is
not going to Splash the cash today that
he wants this budget to be about growth
stability in getting people back to work
well there'll be a lot to look out for
over the next few hours I am very
pleased to say that we're going to have
this guy's political editor Beth Rigby
and Sky's economics and data editor Ed
Conway alongside me to decipher exactly
what the measures all mean for you so
it's going to be
good now Jeremy Hunt at left number 11
Downing Street a short time ago and when
he stands up in the Commons in just
under 90 minutes time it will be against
a backdrop of punishing public sector
strikes some of which we've seen today a
stagnating economy and a cost of living
crisis fueled by high inflation now
there's a lot we don't know but there
are also quite a few things that we do
know so the energy price guarantee which
keeps average yearly household bills at
2 500 pounds that will now continue
until June
the chancellor has also promised 30
hours of free childcare a week to
working parents with one and
two-year-olds in England and he'll
invest 80 million pounds over five years
in 12 investment zones across the UK
and a drive to try and reverse the early
retirement Trend the lifetime pension
allowance and annual cap on
contributions will be increased to allow
people to save a bit more without being
taxed an extra 5 billion pounds will be
spent on defense over the next two years
and with strike action across multiple
sectors there's also pressure to
increase public sector pay
well this is the Chancellor's
penultimate budgets before a general
election so we can begin today with the
voters and try and find out what they
want to hear
I've had to change my hours at work
because of child care costs so I can't
afford to work full-time anymore it's
not feasible for our family so I've had
to write my mum in to do child care but
she's retired it feels a bit unfair but
I have no option I can't afford to work
otherwise local businesses are Furious
really that we've got this skill
shortages so to be investing more in
apprenticeships but to also be investing
in adult education budget I think what
our members would love to hear from the
budget today measures that are going to
be announced that are going to put money
in the pockets of not just public
servants but workers everywhere I think
we'd also like to see some measures in
there that are going to help with the
cost of living whether that be energy
bills child care and things like that
we'd like to see a fully funded pay rise
for teachers back dated to September to
be in line with inflation we'd like to
see the shortage of teachers address I
know that there are simply not enough
teachers at the moment so valuing
education is going to be a good start to
that and fully funded pay rise will help
as always with budgets things leak out
some things are briefed out so we know a
few things already Child Care bills
energy bills public sector pay all being
mentioned there by some of the voters
well let's bring in Beth and Ed shall we
they're going to be staying with us well
into the afternoon just to try and find
out a bit about what you're looking for
um Beth what what have you got your eye
on
well I think if we sort of roll back to
where we are where we were a few months
ago you had the the mini Mega budget
from Liz truss with all those unfunded
tax cuts and all the chaos in the
markets that ensued you then had the
correction uh Autumn statement eight
weeks later when a new prime minister
and a new well the chance of Jeremy Hunt
then reversed that budget and tried to
just get things back on track this
budget now I think is a stick to the
plan stability budget but also one in
which Jeremy Hunt feeling that he at
least reversed the chaos now has to put
forward a plan for growth and I think
that the big elements of this budget
there will be two there will be
short-term help on cost of living
whether it will be enough is the big
question and then there's a longer term
plan here about getting economically
inactive people back into work through a
mix of carrots and sticks in terms of
incentives we talked a bit about the
childcare but also maybe being tougher
on benefit claimants and then there's
going to be a longer term plan about
business investment and trying to get
the economy growing
all of this really is Paving the way if
you like to what the conservatives hope
will be a narrow path back to victory in
a general election next year in which
the pre-election budget of next year
will be the one where you get the big
tax giveaways now how that sits with the
public in terms of do they think that
they're getting enough now also how it
sits with conservative back benches some
of which want tax cuts some of which
want spending cuts one former cabinet
minister saying to me I want a sensible
tax policy rather than brown Knight
tinkering is how this person put it to
me so how it lands there but I think in
a sort of political terms what Jeremy
Hunt and Richie soon at will be hoping
to do is not make the polling any worse
so so entered this fine line between not
making it worse and Paving the way to
get tax cuts to hopefully narrow the
polls give the public more of what they
want want in a run-up to having a stab
at trying to win the next general
election because they are still 20 plus
points behind in the poll so at the
moment it's looking nearly impossible
yeah that Landing zone so so narrow that
they think they've got they think they
can find it you're right it's so narrow
so I want to come back to you in a
minute but Ed is it quite interesting to
hear Beth they're talking about growth
um yeah give us a bit of a sense about
the economic picture in the backdrop you
know the interesting thing as well is
that you know the last time we were six
months or so ago when we were here for
for the mini budget you know chaos
reigned in financial markets back then
it was it was the UK at the center of it
actually right now markets are looking
pretty tense at the moment but actually
it's not so much the UK it's what
happened in the US with Silicon Valley
bank right now Credit Suisse the big uh
Swiss bank looking in in shaky territory
as well so that's that's an interesting
backdrop okay because the UK you know
has lots of banks in there in the ftse
100s it's a big part of the economy here
and that's a part of the economy the
chancellor wants to be focusing on but
just yeah big pictures should I go
through some of the numbers because it's
partly I mean as we with all these
budgets is partly about what we get in
terms of the kind of the measures and
we'll have lots on that but it's partly
also about what's happening with the
state of the economy and I can show you
just kind of how things are looking and
how things indeed were looking not all
that long ago when it came to economic
growth remember of course last time
around the growth numbers were pretty
weak we were talking about kind of
growth being well relatively kind of in
negative territory this year it wouldn't
necessarily have been in positive
territory uh according to the various
numbers this this actually shows you I
think we'll bring it up on the screen in
a second but this actually shows you
kind of where it grows was forecast last
time around so you're talking about a
big four look at that bit the line there
for 2023 down by 1.4 that's the
recession that everyone's been talking
about and that was last time the
question is do those bars go up so do
things improve this time around and the
obr the office budget responsibility
they're going to put a forecast right
now this is what independent forecasters
are forecasting so you're talking a
little those red bars this is not the
obr forecast for today this is what
independent forecasters are talking
about and the key thing is here look at
the difference between that minus 1.4
percent that was forecast for this year
and the minus 4.6 it's still possibly a
recession but it's nonetheless less bad
should we say than it looked last time
around look that differential there but
here's the key thing go out into the
future and look that red bar there these
are independent forecasts I should say
so we're going to get the official obr
numbers later on but it gives you a
sense of where we may be heading weak
weaker than was previously forecast off
in the future that's relevant because it
determines how much money is coming into
the exchecker the higher these bars are
generally speaking the more tax revenue
you get because the better the economy
is doing the more people are earning the
more money comes in and as a result your
deficit doesn't look so bad and you see
that if you look at borrowing and the
reason we focus on these numbers is
public sector net borrowing there'll be
a lot of talk about it over the course
of the day the reason we focus on this
is It's a sense of just how much leeway
the chancellor has to spend against his
rules he has these fiscal rules and the
higher those bars are the less he's got
and it just shows you I know the more
boring there is it just shows you that
those economic growth numbers really
factor in here okay so let's just factor
in the fact that you've got stronger
growth in the short run and weaker
growth off in the future and look at
what those bars do if you just factor
that into the economic model look at
this the bars go down okay so you have
less borrowing more money coming in less
boring in the short run but
interestingly more borrowing in the long
run so potentially less money to be
spent there so that's stronger growth
now factor in the fact that you've got
lower debt interest remember interest
rates last time we were talking about
the midi budget a moment ago last time
everyone thought they were going to go
up to potentially kind of six percent
now maybe four percent maybe four and a
half percent as a result the government
doesn't have to spend as much on debt
interest those bars go down again now
look what happens when you factor in
energy cost particularly at these two
red bars here so energy costs
they're a bit lower as well and that
means the government doesn't have to
spend quite so much on the energy price
guarantee I think we'll come back to
that because I've got another chart I
don't want to over overdo the charts
right now but um we've got another chart
just showing you what matters there
because the chancellor has already
announced something uh on that um but
put it all together and you're talking
about potentially 30 to 40 billion
pounds less borrowing this year than was
previously expected that matters because
that's some of the leeway that the
chancellor potentially has to spend on
but again look over to this side that
red bar there the bar that we might well
be seeing uh today from the obr is
higher so you've got more borrowing off
in the future less boring now
potentially suggesting that the
chancellor has room for a short-term
giveaway but not necessarily much going
into the future I'm going to leave it
there for the time being because we've
got so many other issues we're going to
cover things like you know corporation
tax Public Services spending and all of
that and of course Energy prices as well
but you know over the course of the day
we'll have many more charts and this
just to pick up on this the 30 to 40
billion lower this is why the chance is
now under huge pressure from his own
back benches to actually cut some taxes
now because what happened in January was
the forecast for or the the the the the
money into the extrajacker was more than
expected uh there was a 30 billion pound
uh windfall for the chancellor and that
raised pressure on him from the back
benches to say well come on give us some
tax cuts so they look at that and they
say we want tax cuts now the chancellor
wants to wait to give the tax cuts in
the big pre-election budget splurge and
that is attention on the back benches
and I'd be very interested to see how
the back benches react uh to this
package today yeah we've seen a couple
of Simon Clark taxes having a chilling
effect on the whole economy of pretty
Patel conservative party is nothing if
it does not stand for low taxes they're
already rumbling aren't they you know
the overall tax burden is incredibly
High by recent historical standards I
don't see anything necessarily even this
stuff that's been kind of leaked so far
today that's going to really change that
so I think that those back benches who
have concerns about high taxes have a
lot of ammunition there is quite a lot
so corporation tax going up to 25 Pence
there's a lot of pressure from the
conservative party for the chancellor to
keep it at 19 Pence a lot of pressure
but that costs 18 billion pounds and
that is a big chunk of money for the
exchequer to give on a tax cut when also
you're facing into an election and the
tax cuts you want to Target are tax cuts
that voters rather than business
political isn't it that that is the
corporation tax rate and that's where
it's heading and actually by kind of
historical standards to look back to the
1970s you know it doesn't look it was a
lot higher infamously above 50 so it is
a lot lower now but like that scale of
the scale of that going up in one big
leap you know that that would be the
single big biggest jump that we'd had
upwards in that tax and a lot of
businesses saying you know you need
something to compensate from that so the
thing I'd you know definitely be
watching out for is you know probably
they're going to keep that but what do
they have in exchange for it do they
have more incentives when it comes to
investment and that's really key so it's
a super deduction does that come back do
we get because the super deduction was
this uh system where basically people
would get kind of more of a tax
allowance if they're going to invest
does that stay in it's supposed to
expire at the very same time as that
goes up and that according to many
businesses is disastrous to have those
two things at the same time so that's
really going to be an interesting one to
watch on the super deduction so this was
a tax whereby you got
um you got tax relief so the more money
you invested the more tax relief you got
so I think it was for every one pound 30
you in if you've got tax relief of one
pound 30 for every pound you invested it
was a Rishi sunak policy back in uh
March 2021 it ran for two years it cost
25 billion pounds it was a massive of
expenditure and what I've heard the
chatra I've heard is that Jeremy Hunt
thinks it's too expensive just to
repurpose again but as Ed was saying the
big Focus will be about Capital
allowances and incentives so tax relief
for businesses providing they invest and
that's where I think several billion
pounds of money will go to try and get
businesses to invest for growth because
you know you were talking about and you
were talking about better than expected
forecasts in terms of the economy now
just to remind ourselves Richie soon
acts five pledges to the public is half
inflation get the economy growing by the
end of the year and uh cut long-term
debt uh over the next five years and so
within that he has to try and get the
economy growing and that's where the
focus is going to be yeah really
interesting to talk to you both we'll
have well Ed's promises more charts
lots more to talk about as well
definitely want to talk about the child
care policy a bit later as well but as
Beth was saying lots of pressure on the
chancellor the man of course who pledged
to cut Corporation tanks if he was to
become leader over the conservative
party is he going to be the man who puts
it up to 25 pence in the meantime let's
go to Sam shall we who is in Burnley
with some voters
yes thank you Sophie a very good morning
to you we are live here all day in
Burnley in Lancashire so I'm 20 miles
north of uh Manchester is where people
are facing some of the toughest
financial decisions of their lifetime in
order to just juggle their household
budgets through the very worst of the
cost of living crisis we're spending the
whole day here at the church on the
street Ministries it's really a drop-in
center where people can come in and get
some hot food they can have a hot shower
they can get some mental health support
even a haircut and the need is so great
here that they're actually having to
relocate to a bigger premises a few
streets away at the end of the month so
why come here to Burnley in Lancashire
to test the mood of the nation well this
town could well be one of the most
affected by the decisions that are made
by the chancellor today once he gets on
his feet and reveals the contents of
that red box according to the Center for
sister these Think Tank Burnley has got
the highest rate of inflation in Great
Britain that is up to 11.8 percent that
was measured in January now that is some
two and a half percent higher than what
you see in Cambridge that's at the other
end of the scale now that crucially is
coupled with one of the slowest rates of
wage growth with the latest data showing
that there is actually negative real
wage growth so that's once you've
stripped inflation out of minus 6.6 here
so prices going up real wages going down
you can see what happens and the
relative child poverty rate as well I
think this is a very Stark measure that
stands at 31 here more than one in three
children in in poverty that compares to
18.7 for the UK as a whole that's
according to House of Commons Library
data well we're joined now here by
Pastor Mick Fleming that he moved away
from a previous Life Of Crime he got
himself ordained and here on the streets
of Burnley founded Church on the street
where we're spending the day here to try
and make a difference to his hometown we
also have James Foy who also turned his
life around partly uh through meeting
Mick wasn't it and set up Curry on the
street which has now provided over 40
000 hot meals to people here in need a
very good morning to both of you and
thank you very much for having us uh
pasta make you are a bornly Burnley man
aren't you born and bred you've been
doing this for some 10 years now what is
the last year been like it's been really
difficult so it's been far more
difficult than when we're in the corvid
days because there was an openness for
people to donate and to help and a
camaraderie but the economy is so
deflated that people just don't have
the ability to give in the same way so
Charities are really really struggling
so it's been really really difficult so
the need is rising for the resource is
falling you know so so it's been it's
been an horrendous really 12 month and
the levels of poverty that we see that
James will tell you about you know you
know children on the street hungry the
parents really really really struggling
uh coming to get the help and the
support and then
our resource is all limited you know we
do the best that we can but the
questions are should Charities be
picking this up we are what should they
and for me I like to see a budget that
supports organizations like James's and
organizations like ours you know and I
think helps around uh you look at them
figures you talked about child poverty
there
31 percent
and a national average more than one in
three children you know you know where's
the Justice in that and then you look at
the terrorist properties around this
area this is the inflation rate it's
which is why we are inflation so they're
not
adequately insulated because of lack of
government support through down the
years so it costs you more to heat your
house
I know you see about 1200 people a week
coming in here one of the attractions of
course we could smell it here it's the
fresh food drink at homemade food being
cooked in the kitchen there but James
you're also helping out with this need
aren't you so so you you were on Hard
Times yourself you saw what it was all
about and you decided to try and help
other people and you take Curry to
people around the area don't you just
tell us what you're seeing
the poverty-wise I've seen it growing
and growing and growing over the last
few months especially
um and what we try and do now is is give
them a career give them a hot meal
and give them a bag of shopping with the
essentials in but what I worry about
will chase the children as well we're
trying to educate the children with the
purines
to come out help these people that are
vulnerable you know if they're not so
vulnerable they can help
um we try and get them to help and then
go into the schools and all that we want
to learn them while we're young to
respect these people and stuff you know
the vulnerable get a bad time and and
you said they're coming out of dark cold
houses and standing in queues for an
hour or two to get some food for their
parents
Thursday when it was snow on Thursday
night and we had about 70 people there
which had been there quite a long time
stood absolutely freezing but we managed
to get a little donation so we could get
some sleeping bags for the guys that
were sleeping rough and we have to pick
them out you know we have to pick these
guys out
um I'm so worried about him because
light mixers we haven't got the funding
we haven't got that funding to help
everybody
so this is why they're coming down
queuing all getting into a couple hours
before in the freezing cold with babies
in the prams you know and there were one
woman there with a baby in her arms are
you probably a month old
you know and it's it's all breaking it
really is operating when you hear about
leveling up it doesn't feel like that to
you here in Burnley no no
it's it's um it's a shock to me to be
honest
it's it's got worse and worse
you know
um
when I first started in Berlin I started
through Mick really I went another
meeting with him and I said can I do out
to help and he he showed me where to go
and where to set up and that were like
four years ago you know from then I were
doing about 12 Currys a week
now we're doing 300 curries
all
done by volunteers
we can't afford to pay anybody we can't
afford it we need people but we need
like a manager we can't I'm not going to
get the manager and I'm not going to get
a proper driver I've had to stop driving
because I'm going blind
but I can't afford to pay a driver and I
can't get funded
and it's little things like that that
stop you stop you doing your best you
know so if you're ready to hear one
thing from the chancellor today that you
would think that is just what we need
would it be about the children what what
would it be about it will be about the
children but it's not just the one thing
I can't I can't leave it at that but
it'll be about the organizations getting
what they need you know we do need money
we do
don't do it for money but we need the
money coming in to carry on well um it's
eye-opening coming to talk to you and
the work that you do here in Burnley
we're going to be watching at the budget
here what the chancellor has to offer
for the people of Burnley here and we'll
be bringing new analysis and indeed the
thoughts of some of the people here who
are coming in to see to get what they
need from the church on the streets
Ministry do get in touch with us because
we want to hear your thoughts as well on
the budget uh what do you want to see
from the chancellor are you expecting
Jeremy Hunt's announcements to help you
deal with the cost of living at crisis
do get in touch you can call us now on
0208-167-2200 to be part of a special
phone-in program that's to have your say
of course that's what it's all about we
want to hear from you and you can ask
our experts any questions you might have
you can watch the budget you'll say
that's at 7 p.m this evening right here
on Sky News back to you safety
thanks very much Samwell there'll be
lots more from Burnley as we try and
work out exactly how the Chancellor's
measures impact people across the
country we've got a bit of a flavor of
it already haven't we Beth I want to
talk to you about the child care and I
should say announcement it was more of a
leak right one of the rabbits escaping
up on the hat I think it might have been
a rabbit that escaped due to the good
work of the uh great people at the
guardian actually quite unusual
um but it's one of those things where
it's probably the age I am but my
WhatsApp groups are absolutely lighting
up over this um policy it is quite a big
deal for some people it is a massive
deal and I was once that soldier with
with toddlers And and came for two lots
of child care and it is extremely
expensive when you're in
um that spot in your life and um yes so
uh a bit a big bit of a rabbit here is
this um free child care announcement
we're expecting for one and two years
old now as you will well know the
government already has a policy of up to
30 hours of free child care a week for
three and four-year-olds before they go
go to primary school and now they're
looking at extending that now when I was
in that Focus Group in Wickham last week
you heard Charlotte we had her at the
top of the program for working parents
child care and the cost of it is a very
immediate and pressuring issue for cost
of living we think that the Chance is
going to expand provision to one and
two-year-olds that policy was actually
costed at about six billion pounds it
looks like the money the treasury going
to put in today is about 4 billion
pounds which raises obvious questions to
me I think I know so so part of the part
of the explanation behind that again you
know after Wednesday numbers is is it's
called a dynamic scoring and so it
should cost six billion pounds but then
they expect the economy to do a bit
better to the tune of bringing in an
extra two billion pounds so in net terms
it does end up at 4 billion and is that
because your base encouraging people
back to work who might not be able to
work exactly because of the cost of
child it's called this it's got these
twin kind of goals hasn't it what are we
facing at the moment a lot of people
economic inactivity has gone up
enormously again sorry I've got another
chart about that so if we bring it up we
can we can show you economic and
activity has gone up really sharply uh
around the country and part of what
we're seeing here look at that line
there particularly particularly the bit
on the far right hand side where it's
going up so since the pandemic that's a
lot of people just not going back into
the workplace whether it's people who
have children who are working from home
or indeed not able to work from home or
whether it's pensioners so so part of
part of this is coming back to that yeah
and actually there's
million vacancies in the job market at
the moment because of partly brexit and
you know migration that's a big issue
and so the government want to try and
get economically inactive people back
into work so at one end of the scale
there's child care support at the other
end of the scale and I think this could
potentially be quite a controversial
policy we're expecting the government to
lift the lifetime allowance on Pension
funds now at the moment it's capped at 1
million so once your pension fund Hits 1
million quid you can't keep putting
money into it we think they're going to
lift the cap maybe to up to 1.8 million
I don't need to tell you with those
figures that This only affects a small
percentage of people in society what why
are they doing it well they're looking
at trying to bring professionals in
their 50s particularly in medicine
they're trying to incentivize them to
get back into work because they I've
maxed out my pension I'm now being taxed
more on my income do I need to work when
also I've got this massive pot of money
to enjoy an early retirement but I I
think that the risk politically of that
is say that's a two billion pound policy
that's a two billion pound policy very
much directed at a very narrow group of
people who are very very wealthy already
so I'm interested to see how that looks
on the scorecard but what you see in it
Sophie is you know help for parents
trying to incentivize ugly and then with
Universal Credit as well more support
for child care payments for those on
Universal Credit the other thing they're
going to do is is reduce the ratios now
this is the rules around how many carers
do you need to look after how many
toddlers in a in a child care setting
and it used to be one one in you know
one adult for four three-year-olds and
they might loosen that ratio to say one
adult in five and the reason that
matters is of course if they're looking
after more children then it drives down
the cost that also raises questions
about you know Child Care standards but
this is a whole package about getting
people back into work another critical
problem of this set as you will know is
that it NHS waiting lists are causing a
problem with economic inactivity because
hundreds of thousands of people are in
HS waiting lists and can't go back to
work until they're better and so this
all feeds into also trying to cut
waiting lists in the NHS but this is a
big job for malstride the work and
pension Secretary of State and we don't
have long left but Ed how much of a
problem is economic inactivity for the
economy it's I mean this is one of the
big issues in the UK most other
countries around the world okay when you
look at the chart we just showed you you
don't see quite such a big increase in
economic inactivity people have been
coming back and it's you know there's
all sorts of reasons behind why it is
you know people choosing not to work in
in some cases but also people having
been having long-term sickness so there
is there's a long Shadow from covid-19
both for things like long cover but also
for other uh issues that weren't
necessarily treated as a result of the
the lockdowns and the shutdowns that we
had so so that that you know solving
that as far as the treasury is concerned
as far as uh Rishi zunak is concerned is
one of the big answers towards kind of
getting us back towards some sort of
health and economic health as well as as
the kind of general public and so that's
a big deal yeah I remember when I need
to be the chancellor on Sunday that was
the thing he wanted to talk about when I
said what what's the what should we
expect from the budget this was it lots
more an assets from uh Beth and Ed
coming up
now now the budget decisions has been
made this afternoon are all been taken
on a day of major strikes as hundreds of
thousands of workers walk out in action
which impacts the country's schools
hospitals underground trains and Soil
Service as well what's good as Porter
joins us now from outside the department
for leveling up in Westminster where
workers are on strike Alice are we
expecting anything about this issue in
the budget
well I think the civil servants who are
behind me are very keen to see what
we'll hear from the budget they're one
of a hundred government organizations
which are going on strike today we heard
from representatives from the PCS Union
who are warning that strike action may
continue until the end of the year
unless their demands are met by the
government now have just come from a
picket line in East London where
teachers are going on strike now they're
wanting a pay Rise Above in line with
inflation now Jillian Keegan has put
forward a three percent pay rise and
they're saying that is not enough I
think the real difficulty is how
fractured it has become across the
United Kingdom when we see strike action
with teachers has been paused in Wales
because they've got a new offer made and
it's been called off in Scotland so
there's pressure there on Jillian Keegan
to solve the issue there and today is
also the third day of Junior doctor
strikes they make up around 40 of the
medical Workforce to have them going on
strike for three consecutive days today
is the last day is of course course
having an enormous impact on the NHS
there's good news at least is that
strike action by ambulance workers and
nurses has paused for the moment while
talks are ongoing but to have 40 percent
of your Workforce impacted in the way is
of course highly significant and then
here in London it's very much at a
standstill because we've got members of
the rnt and as left Union who are
striking on the London Underground
they're having an enormous impact and
many of these groups are all wanting a
pay rise in lie with inflation they're
struggling with the cost of living but
in terms of where this puts Jeremy Hunt
is going to be really interesting
because he's under pressure to bring
inflation down and he said he doesn't
want to entrench high levels of
inflation but many people across the
public sector are struggling with the
High Cost of Living at the moment and
will certainly be very much hoping from
Jeremy Hunt's budget there will be
something in it for them to make their
standard of living better
thanks very much indeed lots of strikes
today many of them of course are
completely unresolved expecting more in
schools and on our transport networks
too we'll be talking a bit about how the
budget is likely to impact people's
finances whether that is pension plans
whether it's Child Care let's bring in
our household Finance expert Greg Marsh
shall we and Greg this is really what I
think most of our viewers really want to
know about how is the budget going to
affect them
exactly well we know the chancellor is
talking about the impact on the UK
economy but what we care about is the
impact on UK households we woke this
morning to some good news for
householders which is that the energy
price guarantee is indeed going to be
Frozen at the current level of 2 500
pounds for another three months Energy
prices as a sword over the last few
months as we all know we were expecting
until that was confirmed that energy
price guarantee would rise it now will
not rise and indeed most analysts are
now predicting that by the middle of
this year July onwards Energy prices
will fall still further so Energy prices
good news for households
more uncertainty about income tax now
while we're not expecting to see any
rise in the headline rates of income tax
we do know that that average rate of tax
the effective rate of tax that we all
pay has increased over the last few
years and in Nest the government today
unless the chancellor unfreezes income
tax thresholds this is effectively a
sort of stealth tax if income tax
thresholds stay constant even though
earnings or increases we're all paying
effectively a bit more taxed so Working
Families people on uh incomes especially
higher incomes will be watching to see
very closely about income tax thresholds
now those are lower incomes and
dependent on government support have
other things to worry about and in
particular they'll be looking to see
whether the rate of Universal Credit
increases in line with inflation whether
disability living allowance or personal
Independence payments increases in line
with inflation and whether we see the
winter fuel payment continue so again
very big difference depending on your
income level and your household
composition
during the course of today we are going
to be talking to a number of
householders around the UK to understand
what the budget means for them and we're
going to be looking in detail at those
households that let's have a look at
Leanne so Leanne is a self-employed mum
she has a four-year-old daughter her
daughter too old to benefit from the
additional child care support that's
been rumored over the last day or two
that might we might see at lunchtime
Linda Linda is a retired occupational
therapist while Linda's husband does
work Linda is dependent on pension and
disability support so she'll be looking
to see whether those numbers increase in
today's announcement
and Mike an I.T consultant Mike owns
well but as a householder he like all of
us has faced those higher energy prices
higher costs of food and fuel and
everything else squeezing his wallet so
what does this mean today for a working
person like Mike and other households
over the course of today we'll be doing
live analysis on these particular
household finances and how the budget
affects them and we'll also be going
live to them to get their reaction
so let's go back to Sophie and hopefully
we'll hear more for some of these people
over the course of the day
so much uh Greg well he'll be of course
there guiding us through the consumer
reaction and trying to find out exactly
how it impacts families across the
country now at which you see next the
Prime Minister has left
number 10 Downing Street this is all
part of the budget choreography there he
is he is making his way out to the House
of Commons we'll have provinces
questions of course kicking off as usual
at about 12 and then after that is when
the chancellor will be unveiling his
budget that will be live at 12 30. it's
always a bit of an unusual pmqs the one
just before the budget it's kind of like
the rare occasion when the pmqs is
almost like the startup before the main
course
but there is but she said like setting
off in his car leaving number 10 Downing
Street
so Ed we've been talking about childcare
but there's some other kind of consumer
facing policies I guess that are going
to impact people even if they don't have
kids I mean energy is still a huge issue
isn't it it's been pretty cold recently
as well it's enormous in a way I mean
one of the lessons we've had for the
last few months is that there are two
things that really matter and no one
really thinks about them all that much
until they kind of kick in one is
interest rates and you know remember
what's happened over the last kind of
six months with interest rates of roller
coaster that and there's more news I can
tell you about in a second on that and
the second is energy because it feeds
into everything it feeds in obviously to
our bills and on that front uh we do let
me quickly show you what we what we now
know because it has been it's
pre-announced again like I can't think
of many leakier budgets than this they
seem to be getting leakier and leakier
over the over the years but this is kind
of how the energy price guarantee works
the blue bars there are just showing you
what the off gem price Gap is it's
basically the rate at which an average
household might be expected uh to see
their energy bills and what happened in
the last kind of six month period is
that because of really high wholesale
prices they those bills were going to be
way into this kind of Stratosphere
heading towards kind of four thousand
pounds for the average household but
instead Along Came the energy price
guarantee and basically kind of capped
the rate I should say the rate because
it doesn't cap the absolute amount that
you end up having to pay as as you will
have probably experienced by now but it
does cap the rate at that 2500 pound
level and that difference there you see
those bars the bit above the white line
that's basically what the government has
had to pay that's why this has been
moderately expensive but those bars were
seen as being far higher before so they
haven't had to pay quite so much which
is partly why they have a bit more money
to spend it was going to be going up to
three thousand pounds so look at that
cap and that would have meant that when
those bills increased in April everyone
would have seen an increase the average
household but instead yes as we've just
learned instead the Cap's going to stay
there at 2 500 pounds the big question
now though is what happens in the future
do they keep the cap there now this was
really relevant a few months ago when it
looked like later on this year those
bills were going to be really high so
the cat would have applied but actually
look at those red bars these are just
forecasts okay for the next few months
based on Energy prices in the wholesale
Market actually those have gone down and
down and now these are the latest
forecasts as of March actually the
market price is potentially going to be
below where that cap is and that's why
so far we've only got that extended
through to the end of the end of that
quarter so it's basically July but if
things kind of carry on as the Market's
suggesting at the moment that implies
you don't necessarily have those really
high costs the other thing I'm going to
come back to my desk the other thing is
that um I mentioned interest rates
really interesting safely because
looking right now at What markets are
pricing in for interest rates remember
last time people were you know pricing
and potentially six percent interest
rates after that shot from the mini
budgets
because of the scare about what's
happening with banks right now not
because of the UK but obviously Silicon
Valley Bank that bank that collapsed it
did have a UK branch and there were
concerns about banks in general at the
moment and the economy
look at interest rates right now a lot
of people think that maybe a UK rates
might Peak only at about 4.25 that's
quite a big change only on Friday they
thought they were going to get up to
about 4.75 percent
in the space of a few days it's down to
4.25 maybe not even that and that's a
really big deal because you know for all
of those who have have mortgages and
indeed anyone who has savings you'll
have seen that kind of reflected more in
mortgages it must be said than on
savings higher interest rates so when
we're talking about cost of living
crisis ironically something that Jeremy
Hunter has nothing to do with which is a
financial crisis on the other side of
the world or not maybe Finance crisis
going too far but a bank crisis in
certain banks on the other side of the
world feeding into what's going on in
the market that could have as big an
impact if not more on household spending
and on how much we have after after all
these costs stand something like the
energy price guarantee and that could
have a huge impact on not only you know
the budget or the chancellor but the
whole Premiership of Rishi Scenic I
guess yeah of course and I mean look
what you have to always keep front and
center in your mind is what is Rishi
sunax bid to to remain in number 10
after the next general election it's to
get the economy growing and get people
feeling like they are better off now
under a conservative government and I
have to say when I went and did that
focus group it's Wickham it's actually
near where I grew up so I know the area
really well it's been a conservative
seat since 1950s I mean it really is the
true blue shy as if you like of the of
blue wall of the conservatives you like
and what's beginning to happen is
kirstma is now trying to take bricks out
of the blue wall
and and the challenge for the
conservatives is to to get voters that
have stuck with them for years and years
and years to keep with them and we did a
sort of straw poll in this room where I
said put your hand up uh if you think
the government or the country needs a
change and everyone put their hand up
and they were they were floating voters
but there were voters in there that had
told us that they'd voted conservative
in the last general election and I I
can't stress enough how much pressure
the government is on in the run-up to
the next general election to to make
people feel that they're better off and
to make people feel that the country is
working like basic services are working
but of course there are external factors
on economy that Rishi sunak can't
control I mean it's a bit like Ed when
Kirsten said that he wanted to make the
UK that was it the biggest performer or
the best performer
in the G7 so where you can't control
what the other six do so why make a time
like that but you know it's
incredibility as well probably that you
picked that up in your focus group as
well you know the government's
credibility after last what happened
last year regardless of how well this
goes and the growth that's been really
badly damaged and the question is
whether rich is United can repair that
or whether the the damage is done
particularly for a party that's always
trying to position itself as a party of
economic credibility and responsibility
thank you both uh very much indeed let's
get back to Burnley uh shall we we've
been talking a lot with Beth there about
how it really matters at what voters and
some of these key seats think of the
budget let's go to Sam Washington
yes thank you very much Sophie welcome
back to Burnley in Lancashire we're here
at the church on the streets Ministries
drop-in center where we people can get
hot food a hot shower or even a haircut
if they need it now there's decisions
that are being taken more than 200 miles
away down in Westminster are gonna have
a material impact aren't they on the
day-to-day life for families and
business owners who are living here well
we saw their profiles up in the screen
by break there I'm joined Now by Linda
Marshall she's a retired occupational
therapist and Mike Holden who's an I.T
consultant a very good morning to you
thank you very much for joining us so
you're both at Burnley foe can't you and
let's let's talk to you Linda first of
all the cost of living crisis has been a
real thing hasn't it in your life cost
of food you say it's doubled and it's
Energy bill so what what are you looking
for from the chancellor today
and well Energy bill is a quick winners
as many people at the minute so we're
hoping that that's going to be so capped
um even if it is
expensive but I'd like to think what
will happen if it does go up even more
um and also interest rates the mortgage
rates have gone up as well which hours
has gone all since we um you know the
contract ends but for many people that's
causing you know they're paying double
the amount of what they're paying at the
minute it's not too bad for us at the
minute because we don't have a big
mortgage but for most people
but you're retired your husband works
full-time and your son who's 38 had to
move back in with you because his costs
were too expensive yeah so he lived in
digsby Manchester for seven years good
job whereas as a technical engineer and
was paying a thousand pound a month for
rent for his apartment all the money he
had coming in even though it was going a
very good way so he's had to come back
so he's come back home to help her
science as well because he you know well
let me bring in Mike I know we've all
got to know each other aren't we this
morning and might you if you don't mind
me describing you like this
um you're with the better off end of
people in Bernie and you still say that
you're also feeling the pinch you're an
I.T consultant steady job yes I've been
in a steady job for many years uh I'm on
a good salary and I've got a good
pension lined up but um our day-to-day
costs have doubled in the last 12 months
fuel costs as everybody knows they've
gone up 50 in the last 12 months and
you're on the road a lot uh yes and the
fuel fuel and heating and electricity
costs are all going through the roof and
and you saw the value of your pension
because you're coming close to the time
when you'll be drawing it down you're a
victim of what happened with the mini
budget from Liz Charles yes Liz truss's
intervention cost me
am I allowed to say about 60 000 pounds
in Lost pension
so what are you looking for today
my concern is is not for myself uh I'm
comfortable enough if uh fuel bills stay
as they are I can survive if they go up
I can take the the hit a little bit I'm
concerned for people then people here
are on minimum wage and can't afford to
heat homes and they can't afford to feed
the kids and I'm hoping to help help
with those people rather than for myself
and I will
ride over the bumps and I've got a
retirement coming up in a few years I
mean a few years in me yet but um
I I'm more concerned for the people of
birming who are around us here do you
feel burnley's been forgotten about very
much so
um
over the number of years
um manufacturing is in Decline here or
it's picking back up a little bit now
but it's been in Decline for years and
this Corridor I've only Blackburn and
Blackpool of suffering the highest
inflation in the country
and the lowest wage Rises and it
concerns me I know this is supposed to
be helped for child care coming up which
is going to be very welcome if you
promise not not for myself because again
I have a stepdaughter but we have family
to help with that
um but um
people in in the town of Birmingham
really have had it very hard for a very
long time
all right well Linda and Mike are going
to be staying with us throughout the
program we're going to be watching the
budget together and joined by a few more
people and we'll be talking about what
we heard or perhaps even what we didn't
hear after the chancellor has delivered
his speech of course the needs for
people of Burnley as you can see here
this drop-in center people who need food
people who need a hot shower people who
need mental health support that's an
acute need here so of course we will be
keeping a close eye on that and we'll be
bringing you all of our thoughts
throughout the afternoon back to you
Sophie
thank you very much indeed Sam and now
we do have a little bit of news to bring
you ahead of the budget head of our pmqs
panel that we're going to be with you
and build up of course to the private
usual promises questions but we have had
a bit of a readout from cabinet today it
was an earlier cabinet than usual uh 8
30 a.m this morning so bright and early
and I can just bring you what the
chancellor said he set out the improved
economic picture which he said was
following his Autumn statement saying
that paved the way for his growth budget
so clearly being dubbed a growth budget
today
he also referenced plans for
deregulation plans to invest billions in
carbon capture and storage and nuclear
energy and a boost to leveling up
through those 12 investment zones across
the UK he also outlined a significant
package in his words that says rather
than mine to help people get into work
ranging from support for the over 50s so
we're talking there about the help for
pensions and pensions contributions that
Beth was talking about a bit earlier
those on benefits parents we have heard
a bit of course about the child care
proposals and also those with long-term
health conditions so that was the budget
readout in cabinet this morning
we'll just discuss all this we are now
joined by Theresa Villas who is the
conservative MP for chipping Barnet she
was a former Shadow Financial secretary
to the treasury and the former Northern
Ireland secretary II James Murray the
labor MP for Ealing North and the
party's Financial secretary to the
treasury and we're also joined by Layla
Moran the liberal Democrat MP for Oxford
West and Abingdon and the libderm
spokesperson for foreign affairs and
International Development great to have
you all here Teresa let's get to you
first we heard there a bit about the
Chancellor's growth plan all about
trying to tackle economic inactivity
what are you expecting from the budget
um well I think there's it seems like
there's going to be a little bit of good
news showing that the difficult
decisions taken in the Autumn statement
have have paid off
but growing the economy is clearly one
of the the prime minister's five
priorities we have to do it it's the key
to everything else to funding our public
services and I particularly welcome the
suggestion that there's going to be some
extra help with child care costs and
also
the problem with pensions has been
effectively driving doctors to retire
early so if the chancellor is addressing
that today that is also welcome because
it helps people get the GP appointments
they want when they want them at the
same time that's benefiting the very
wealthiest isn't it some people might
say look at this time of economic
hardship is that the right thing to do
there has to be a balance here and even
even with sort of more positive economic
signs there are still constraints on
what the chancellor can do but genuinely
I think this this pensions taxation
problem is serious it is part of the
reason why the NHS is Under The Strain
it is and so I think it is important
that we do fix it okay that's what T
James Murray now
um childcare that's something that
Labor's been talking about an awful lot
you must think this is good news
well as he said my colleague Bridget
Phillips has been talking a lot about
child care because it's absolutely
essential to help parents and families
across the country is also essential for
economic growth to make sure that
parents have that support to go back to
work when they want to but you know
let's see the detail we're still uh
feeding on on rumors and and press leaks
at the moment let's see the detail of
what the government is proposing and
also let's see you know how is it going
to be paid for when is this going to be
delivered let's think about the whole
system as well because this is not just
about putting money in it's also about
looking at the whole system to make sure
the capacity is there to make sure
staffing issues are addressed and so on
so you know we think Child Care is
absolutely essential to the future of
the country and the economy and my
colleague Bridget Fullerton is going to
keep pushing on that I guess
and that's the fact that some people
were saying that the three hours for
three and four-year-olds hasn't been
properly funded so it leaves child care
providers out of pocket effectively well
we know that thousands of child care
providers have been closing in recent
years we know there are issues with
staff shortages and so on so you know
it's one thing putting in money but
there's a lot of detail around that
about how things are going to be
delivered and actually you know what my
colleague Bridget is doing is looking
International examples to work out what
is the best way to change the system to
reform the system to make it fit for the
future uh laying around what are you
going to be looking out for
um well I'm pleased with the child care
announcement that was the 2019 liberal
Democrat Manifesto promise they've
basically copied the The Bare Bones of
it so that's good but the devil is going
to be in the detail and one of the
things I'm looking at really closely is
the ratios because it's all very well
saying that you're going to invest in it
but also if you increase the ratios that
drives down safety and also quality so
we're worried about to explain that's
basically the number of people in
nurseries or in other providers who how
many children they're allowed to how
many children they're allowed to look
after and I've had child care providers
in my constituency have me round and
talk me through how that's not just
unworkable but potentially unsafe the
other thing that I want to really focus
on is again the devil in the detail of
the energy price cap announcement now
the government are desperately trying to
claim that people are going to be
so-called better off they're actually
not when people look at how much they're
going to have to pay in for their energy
it's actually going to go up so the
liberal Democrats have been calling on
not a cap at 2500 but a cap at 2000
which more or less marries what we have
now because that 400 pound payment that
we've been seeing over the winter is not
about to be repeated ultimately what I
care about is those ordinary
constituents of mine who are struggling
to make ends meet who are literally
putting things back in the supermarkets
because they can't afford the energy to
heat them up in the oven are they the
ones who are going to be better off or
worse off at the end of this budget at
the moment I've seen very little for
them
the energy price uh cap is about how
it's going to be paid for uh because
what we've been calling for um is for a
strengthened windfall tax to pay for
that now the government according to
leaks may be moving a bit on the front
of uh extending the the price cap but we
need to know how it's going to be paid
for as well and you know we've been
talking about windfall tax since January
last year
there are still keeping holes in it you
know there's still this investment
allowance for oil and gas giants it
still doesn't start when we so it should
be starting it still isn't at the same
rate for instance as they have in Norway
so there are obvious ways in which it
could be strengthened and that could
raise billions of pounds which could
then help fund the sexual support for
families I just want to talk a little
bit about Taps because I think you'll
agree your concerns of colleagues many
of them getting increasingly Twitchy
about the fact that we're expected to
have the highest levels of tax since the
1960s we've seen Simon Clark say that's
having a chilling effect in the whole
economy pretty Patel so the conservative
party is nothing if it does not stand
for low taxes do taxes need to come down
yeah we we all yes they need to come
down but we have to do that in a
sustainable way and I'm sure what the
chancellor will be saying today is even
if headline rates attacks are not coming
down here's plan for growth and his plan
for the economy will ultimately deliver
those tax cuts in the longer term
although not the short-term particularly
Corporation attacks going up to 25p yeah
of course I'm not happy about it but we
the economy has suffered severe shocks
as a result of the covert outbreak and
the war on Ukraine and therefore we have
to consolidate the public finances but I
think it there may well be something in
the budget to encourage business
investment that I think is one of the
most important potential tax cuts
because it helps us deal with our
productivity problem I love the message
of unity
conveniently forget the the Liz trust
quasi-quarting era where we lost 50
billion possible pounds that we could
have been spending right now people are
still paying for it on their mortgages
right now
returned to normal
um we're giving up promises questions
about four minutes time it's always a
bit of a weird pmqs always think ahead
of the budget you know what exactly can
the PM say are you kind of everyone's
waiting for the main event how do you
think kirst armor is going to be dealing
with that what line of question would
you expect him to go on
um well I don't I don't have a sheet
that tells me what questions he's going
to go on um you know so obviously is the
timing of it is unusual because it's
straight before Kia then responds to uh
what the chancellor says in terms of the
budget but there are plenty of other
issues you know going around uh in in
politics these days uh you know whether
it's um whether it's migration you know
whether it's questions about hs2 and all
the stuff around that you know there's a
lot of other issues which could be
focused on but I haven't gone inside
track to tell you what he's going to go
on how about the lip dance what do you
think they should be focusing on um well
we've got we've got three and I'm sure
my colleagues will be raising a lot of
constituency issues if I had one today
actually the one I had raises on Long
covered so the chancellor is talking a
lot about productivity there are two
million people in this country who
according to the ons survey are
estimated to be be living with long
covered a million of those for more than
a year and actually five percent of
those are in Social care and across the
NHS so I want to hear from them they've
talked about long-term conditions but
specifically on Long covered what are
they going to do to support those
workers many of whom if supported
correctly could go back into the
workforce there's a petition going into
Downing Street on this today that I hope
to be supporting later and that's
probably what I would go on how about
you what do you go for
I might I think if I were a leader of
the opposition I'd be talking about the
economy that's you know people people do
want to know what the situation is in
terms of cost of living Etc but I I
think what is pretty much a certain that
is the prime minister's answers some of
them will focus on Labor's failure to
support legislation to seek to stop the
boats it's interesting isn't it because
it does feel like the small boats is one
of those genuine dividing line issues at
the minute do you think that's a fair
comparison I think I think everyone
agrees there is an issue with small
boats and actually everyone agrees
across the country people want something
to be done about it what we disagree
with and is the government's approach to
it which is driven by gimmicks and
headlines rather than an actual plan to
stop the small boats coming over in the
first place to clear the backlog to get
those International agreements in place
if that's what a proper plan looks like
but actually what the government is
doing is all driven by headlining
gimmick we've just got uh we're just
looking right now at the live shop from
the House of Commons it is just under a
minute now until we're expecting that
all to kick off so we'll keep an eye on
that and we will pause just as soon as
the guys in question get to their feet
now let's talk to you at Leila Moran
what's your position on the small boats
um so I've been able to agree that there
is a problem and but fundamentally what
we have here is a a problem of partly
the government's own making they have
not negotiated those International
agreements we used to send back many
more people they don't do that anymore
and the consequence of it on a local
level is that there is a Detention
Center in kidlington that had closed in
2018 after a 30-year-long campaign that
to the tune of 400 million pounds that
that one and one in gospel are going to
be opened and that's 400 beds so it's
barely touching the sides of the problem
the main thing that I would rather that
400 million were invested in was is that
backroom staff at the home office so
that they can process these applications
quickly and the thing that just I find
just boggles the mind is now they're
saying they'll send these Asylum Seekers
who are already here a form that they
can fill in to determine whether or not
they're allowed to stay imagine if they
did that before they got on the small
boats in the first place that would be
called a safe and legal route and yet
they're determined not to set up those
routes immediately I don't understand
what the delay is with the setup of
those routes
oh do you think the uh the prime
minister is finding his reception with
the conservative about that just at the
minute it felt like that was a bumpy
period at the beginning of the year
apologies I am going to go to Jess
Phillips now I'm going to go live to the
House of Commons and we're going to take
officiency
[Applause]
Summit we signed a new
attack now
over the weekend we facilitated a sale
of Silicon Valley Bank at no cost to the
taxpayer
and we have launched a submarine
partnership with Australia in the US
launched our integrated review and
boosted our defense budget Mr Speaker
this morning I had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today Jess Phillips thank you Mr Speaker
I've worked for years with women brought
here illegally as sex slaves raped by 30
men a day last week the Prime Minister
tweeted that these victims would be
denied access to support from our modern
slavery system a tweet that traffickers
will hold up to these women and say see
no one will help you before the Prime
Minister paris's prepared answer about
increases in the number of people
accessing our modern slavery system lets
me educate him and everyone else in this
house that the biggest increase in the
last 10 years has been from the huge
increase in British adults and children
trafficked for sex and crime within
Britain not a number they should be
proud of how exactly will I help the
next woman I meet brought here illegally
from being repeatedly raped if she as he
tweeted is denied access from our
mother's life
Mrs Mr Speaker just to correct The
Honorable lady it is actually now a
minority of people in our modern slavery
referral system that are from the UK
that was not the intention of the
legislation when it was introduced we
have a proud record of supporting
victims of modern slavery
and thousands of victims are supported
every year here in the UK and that will
not change as we grip illegal
immigration
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker on Monday the Home Secretary
said that in recent decades there has
been the immigration to this country has
been too high and all the benches
opposite held their disapproval they
want higher immigration
[Applause]
agree that what we need to do is rather
than importing treat foreign labor we
need to invest in the skills of our own
young people and encourage visitors
yeah well Mr Speaker my little friend is
right that we do need to encourage
long-term investment in the domestic
Workforce we'll hear more from this in
the chancellor later this afternoon that
the department for work and pensions is
directing support at sectors with labor
shortages like construction and social
care and our new skills boot camps are
part of a dramatic rebooting of our
skill system to support workers to get
the skills that they need so now comes
to lead in the opposition kill Starbuck
thanks
thank you Mr Speaker Last Summer the
Prime Minister claimed he wanted to
protect free speech and put a stop to no
platforming so how concerned was he by
last week's campaign by Tory MPS to
cancel a broadcaster
foreign
Mr Speaker as I said as I said at the
time the issues between Gary lineker and
the BBC were for them to resolve and I'm
very glad I'm very I'm very glad that
they did and we're looking forward to
watching match the day again on our
screensaver Mr Mr Speaker the site of
them howling with rage over a tweet
signing greeting letters in their dozens
desperately trying to cancel a football
highlight show that should have been
laughable instead it led to a farcical
weekend with the national broadcast
being accused of dancing to the
government's tune by its own employees
rather than blame everyone else why
doesn't it take some responsibility
stand up to his snowflake MPS Waging War
on Free Speech
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker just the usual
usual political opportunism
[Music]
the labor party because
I don't I don't know if he noticed I
don't know if he knows this but actually
first the shadow attorney general and
then the shadow Home Secretary actually
criticized the language that had been
used in the tree
[Applause]
a political bandwagon and changed his
mind First Armor so Mr Speaker
I'm not being funny I think I'm a
constituents something to get to the
budget the more that you showed the more
you progressed question so please my
constituents interested if yours aren't
gizama Mr Speaker they want more of a
prime minister who doesn't understand
you can disagree with what somebody says
but still defend their right to say it
doesn't have that we're in a real
problem does he accept that people's
concerns about the BBC have been made
worse because the government chose to
put a Tory donor with no broadcasting
experience in charge of the BBC
[Applause]
[Music]
speaker as as he well knows BBC chairman
was appointed before I became prime
minister
[Applause]
he was appointed
he was he was appointed
at the same applies to this side this
budget matters the people of this
country they won't hear it don't keep
questions going long in the Navy prime
minister
Mr Speaker
very rigorous in this independent and
long-established process
the expert panel members as well as the
cross as well as the cross party dcms
select committee now that is
process that process is
this process is being independently
reviewed by the office for commissioner
of public appointments and we should
allow that review to conclude
Starbucks the problem is the chair of
the BBC isn't just any old Tory donor
it's so close to the Prime Minister
order this
I want you to be
to be no ordinary Tori donor he's so
close to the Prime Minister he's been
described as his mentor he helped
arrange an 800 000 pound credit line for
the former prime minister a minor detail
he forgot to tell the select committee
which scrutinized his appointment does
the Prime Minister think that his
friend's position is still tenable
well Mr Speaker as I've just said
the office for in the independent office
for commissioner of public appointment
is reviewing what was a rigorous
independent process to appoint the
chairman instead of pre-judging and
preempting that review we should let it
conclude and wait for the outcome that
is the right way to do things and that's
what the government will do
Mr Speaker when people with links to the
Tory party somehow find themselves in
senior positions at the BBC it's
important that their impartiality is
seen to be Beyond reproach so has the
promise to received assurances but no
one with links to the Tory party was
lobbied by Tory MPS or involved in the
decision that saw match of the day
effectively canceled
Mr Speaker these as I said these These
are matters these are matters for the
BBC to resolve and it's right it's right
that the BBC as an important institution
takes its obligations to impartiality
seriously right I I care about the
integrity and partiality of Institutions
the BBC but also the Civil Service Mr
Speaker and it's right that those
processes carry on properly but what I
would say to him what I would say to him
on this matter there is an independent
review it's right that that process
concludes and he would I would hope
respect that process
[Applause]
he comes here today with his Minnie
Mouse platitudes pretending the actions
of his party have nothing to do with him
but the whole country saw how he kept
quiet and hid behind the playground
bullies while they try to drive someone
out Simply for disagreeing with them an
impartial public broadcaster free of
government interference is a crucial
pillar in our country but isn't that put
at risk by the council culture addicts
on his benches the BBC leadership that
caves into their demands and a prime
minister too weak to do anything about
them
Mr Speaker we're not going to take any
lectures on Council culture from the
party officer
he's avoided it in six questions the
actual the substance of the issue that
this underlied this tweet and that's
what has he done in this past week the
only thing he and his party have done is
voted against our bill to stop the boats
Mr Speaker siding with people Smugglers
over the British people that's the
what's happened instead what have we
done is conclude a new migration deal
with France Mr Speaker we've managed to
sign a new defense partnership with our
allies the US and Australia we've
protected British startups and we have
boosted defense spending and that Mr
Speaker is what delivering for Britain
looks like
can I just say to you the biggest day in
the house and you want to carry on
cheering I'll tell you what my kids no
I'll be
because there is plenty of rumors I've
mentioned in the two room for all sides
so let me say Angela Richardson's once
again on with the questions Angela
thank you Mr Speaker for decades the
Surrey Research Park in Guildford has
been home to our pioneering space sector
with Surrey satellite technology limited
and now Surrey Space Center spacecraft
project which recently received 300 000
pounds to train and recruit dedicated
space engineers and create facilities to
trial space related technology will my
right honorable friend join with me in
welcoming this investment and when his
diary allows will he come and visit
Guildford to celebrate successful local
Innovation and job creation
well I am I can reassure my honorable
friend that we are continuing to invest
in the UK's thriving space sector
including in her constituency a new six
and a half million pound scheme to
support high impact uh projects space
South Central as she knows is already
the leading Regional space cluster in
the UK there's more investment coming
and I look forward to either visiting
myself or the minister of State for
science Innovation and Technology to
make sure that her companies get the
recognition they deserve SMP leader
Stephen Flynn
Mr Speaker on Monday as households in
Scotland were Awakening to freezing
temperatures they were met with the news
that the electricity grid had been
upgraded in order to meet the Power
demands of the prime minister's new
swimming pool so may I ask him was it
whilst he was taking a leisurely dip
that he decided to leave households
Downing in their energy bills
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker thanks to the actions of this
government what we have provided is over
one thousand three
to help families with their energy bills
over the last year now I wouldn't want
to preempt what the chancellor is going
to say later but this is a government
that is committed to continuing to help
people with the cost of living and
that's what you'll hear later on Stephen
Flynn you've got to wonder what planet
he's on Mr Speaker because for
households in Scotland the energy prices
haven't been frozen at two and a half
Grand and did the average bill in
Scotland has been closer to 3 500 pounds
and you're tripling in just under two
years but worse than that the chancellor
is about to get to his feet and
announced that the 400 pound energy
rebate is about to be Scott for everyone
not just in Scotland but right across
these aisles so is it not the case the
notorious aren't freezing energy bills
they're looking to freeze households
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker actually the
government is delivering for people
across the United Kingdom energy bills
have been our priority which is why over
a thousand pounds of support which is
benefiting households in every part of
our country but he talks about delivery
it's now clear that we know because of
the SMP that the trains don't run on
time the
[Applause]
pillar the police are at breaking point
the police are at breaking point and the
NHS in Scotland experience the longest
ever waiting list Mr Speaker that isn't
that isn't even my assessment that's
what we learned in the smp's leadership
debate last week
Aaron Bell so thank you Mr Speaker
independent retailers of the lifeblood
of our high streets and critical to the
Regeneration of our town centers so we
should cherish and celebrate the
entrepreneurs who set them up and run
them with that in mind with the Prime
Minister join me in congratulating the
winners of my recent competition to find
newcastle's best left independent shops
and Market stores namely Tony Price
quality butchers majuli's cheeky
cheesecakes and the overall winner and
that's my Greek Bakery who only opened
in January 2021 and are already
expanding to a second site
[Applause]
well I agree with my honorable friend
about the incredible benefit that small
businesses and independent retailers
bring to our high streets and our
economy I congratulate the team at an
asthma Greek Bakery for winning the
competition and I know that they will
feel reassured by their government's
investment in his constituency through
the towns deal that they have and of
course funding from the future High
streets fund Stephen Curry thank you
very much Mr Speaker just to head off
after the community off the Windsor
framework and hopefully we will see the
executive restored uh shortly however
that executive is facing a spiral of of
budget cuts which will stop it from
transforming Public Services on invest a
safe basis and investing in a Prosperity
agenda so will the Prime Minister and a
data Chancellor work with the Northern
Ireland parties on a financial package
in order to transform Northern Ireland
accepting data for strict conditions and
a real focus on key areas such as health
education skills and infrastructure
well can I Thank The Honorable gentleman
and his his colleagues and his party for
the engagement they had in the run-up to
the Windsor framework it was helpful and
I appreciated his constructive
involvement and my right honorable
friend the Northern Ireland secretary
has been woken closely and will work
closely with all Northern Irish parties
leading discussions on a wide range of
issues including the public finances
because I believe what the original
gentleman believes is the people of
Northern Ireland need and deserve
effective accountable devolved
government up and running as quickly as
possible and I hope that those talks can
be constructive in leaving their aim
well Blackman
speaker in 2016 the current mayor of
London promised zero strikes on London
Underground so today is the 135th day of
strikes since then
will my right adult friend join with me
in condemning both strikes that have
brought misery to the traveling public
in London and also condemned the mayor
of London for his failure to address
this
yeah Mr Speaker my uh mindful friend is
absolutely right about the misery being
inflicted on londoners by the
incompetent running of tfl it's worth
bearing in mind not only to the party
opposite vote against our minimum
service levels which will provide
respite for the hard-working British
public that that the mayor of London
since the pandemic has received six
billion pounds of additional funding for
transport services so for us to be in
the situation that we are find ourselves
in today is simply unacceptable
thank you Mr Speaker an investigation
reported in the guardian and the BBC
revealed that in the last year on more
than 450 instances sewage was leaking
into cancer Wards maternity units and a
e departments without urgent action the
legacy of this conservative government
on the NHS will be an image of a nurse
cleaning up sewage around a patient in a
crumbling hospital will the Prime
Minister commit to that pledge of
building 40 hospitals by 2030 including
in West Hertfordshire and will he
establish a fund to repair those
hospitals that are in a dire state of
disrepair
Mr Speaker we are investing record sums
in NHS Capital to upgrade dozens of
hospitals across the country but in
particular to build 40 new hospitals and
we are committed in particular to a new
hospital scheme at West Hertfordshire
Hospital NHS trust as part of that
program and the program is working
closely with the Trust on their plans in
lines with the approach that we have
taken nationally I'll put John speaker
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that agritech is a vital part of the UK
economy and in particular the excellent
work of the crop and environment
Research Center at Harper Adams
University in Shropshire I know he has a
busy schedule but could he dispatch the
Secretary of State to come and look at
that research center and in particular
this the women leading science and maths
at Harper Adams and indeed leading the
world
well Mr Speaker I agree with my
honorable friend in particular Harper
Adams is a fantastic example of the type
of innovation and skills provision that
we need in our agritech sector and
that's why I'm pleased post brexit that
we can introduce the gene editing Bill
Mr Speaker which will help Drive
productivity and efficiency in our
agricultural sector even further but
the government promised the 40 new
hospitals three years ago and the prime
minister's just expressed his intention
to proceed again two years ago in St
Mary's Paddington Hospital serving my
constituency award ceiling fell in
during floods the Eye Hospital was
closed by a fire and the birth center of
Eternity Wars are threatened by
structural problems this week trust
managers said the infrastructure is
having an increasing impact on staff and
patients we just can't afford to
continue to waste money on failing
buildings but the hospital is waiting
for the commitment from the government
for the funding under the new hospitals
program will today be the day that the
Prime Minister commits to that
specifically yeah
it's because I said in my previous
answer the government is committed to
the new hospitals program we've
committed record sums to NHS Capital not
just for that program but for smaller
scale upgrades across the country and
those conversations with her trust and
others are happening in the same way
across the country and I look forward to
those conversations continuing
[Music]
yeah Mr Speaker governments at all level
national and local should always strive
to deliver value for money
particularly in a cost of living crisis
therefore does the Prime Minister share
my astonishment that my local Labor led
Westminster Council voted last week to
raise council tax by two percent
housing tenants Council tenants went by
seven percent and increase allowances
for its senior councilors by up to a
staggering 40.
[Applause]
[Music]
please answer
Mr Speaker it is disappointing to see
that I think it's been just under a year
that the now labor run Westminster
Council has put its own councilor's pay
ahead of everything else I can't quite
believe the figures that we have from
honorable friend a staggering an
eye-watering 45 pay increase when people
across our country and indeed the water
suffering cost of living pressures it's
clear Mr Speaker that it's only
conservative run councils that deliver
for their residence
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker every
child in the UK is entitled to free NHS
dental treatment but with 80 percent of
practices not accepting children as new
patients is the prime minister proud of
his record on our children's dental
health
Mr Speaker we're investing three billion
pounds in NHS Gentry and because of the
reforms to the contract there will be
about 10 more activity this year above
contractor levels there are 500 more
dentists in the NHS today but also are
they almost say 45 increase in the
amount of dental care being provided to
Children Eric Thomas
five years ago 40 million pounds of
public funds were set aside for brain
tumor research but recent government
figures suggest that a little less
quarter of that money has been deployed
to researchers the mechanism to
distribute research funding effectively
is broken as a result the brain tumor
Community has not seen the breakthroughs
in treatment and Survivor rates that
many of us believe they should have does
my primary does my friend the Prime
Minister agree with me that a unique
complex disease needs a unique response
and in what is brain tumor awareness
month will he make brain cancer a
critical research priority across all
cancers
or can I uh can I thank honorable Fenn
for his thoughtful and Powerful question
he's absolutely right about the
importance of medical research being
expedited so we can deliver better care
for the people who are affected I'll
make sure that he gets a meeting with
the relevant minister so we can ensure
that that funding gets out to the people
who need it and we can bring relief to
them as quickly as we can Joanna yeah
thank you thank you Mr Speaker with the
encouragement of the British government
female prosecutors and female judges in
Afghanistan stood up for the rule of law
and for a more inclusive and equal
Nation those Left Behind are in Mortal
danger last year I met with senior
officials at the foreign office who were
open to making a specific case for at
least some of these women to be
relocated to the United Kingdom but
nothing has happened since then this
dire situation requires a prime
ministerial intervention so I'm not
asking to meet the prime minister's
officials or his ministers I'm asking
him directly will he meet with me to see
what we can do for these women yeah
prime minister I'm very happy to meet
with the honorable lady and she will
know that we take our obligations to
those who helped and served in
Afghanistan extremely seriously both
through the Arab scheme and the acrs
scheme we have already brought 20 000
refugees from Afghanistan to the UK we
work with the unhcr and others on those
legal routes but I'd be happy to meet
with her to ensure that we're targeting
our compassion our generosity on the
people who most need it and not those
who are coming here illegally Carolina
speaker at the height of the pandemic
Center assessed grades allowed our young
people to move forward with their lives
Lara my very brave young constituent is
now battling cancer and will not sit the
GCSE exams she has worked so hard for
and could be left with only a
certificate of recognition
in exceptional circumstances such as
these why can't the same principle apply
would my right honorable friend the
Prime Minister look compassionately at
this situation
prime minister start by sending my best
wishes to Lara and thanking my honorable
friend for raising her case uh in in
Parliament of course it's incredibly
upsetting and challenging for children
and young people to be diagnosed with a
serious illness and especially so close
to their exams now there are allowances
that are made and in the first instance
students will speak to their school or
their college to make those reasonable
adjustments but I'll be happy to make
sure that we work with my horrible
friend to find a resolution in Lara's
case
Mr Speaker I welcome the PM's numeracy
but did he know that some 7.1 million
adults in England are functionally
illiterate is often diagnosed late in
life like with TVs J blades if at all so
would he thank the entirely voluntary
read easy who are turning this around at
just 250 pounds cost per new reader and
commit to a national strategy for
eradicating this problem that's costing
our economy 25 billion a year in Lost
competitiveness
well Mr Speaker I agree with honorable
Lady Liberty and numeracy are critical
for adults to be able to participate
both in society and the economy are
happy to appraise read easy for the work
that they do look forward to learning
more about them but the best way to
solve this problem is to ensure that our
young children get the the reading
skills and training and education that
they need and I'm so pleased that
because of the reforms introduced by
this preview or previous conservative
governments particularly with phonics we
have now marched up the international
league table and have some some of the
best results for reading that we've seen
in a very long time Richard Fuller thank
you Mr Speaker more than a quarter of
the economic output of this country is
in sectors overseen by some of our major
Regulators such as off-ward and off-chem
but historically there's been very
little in the way of oversight to say
whether doing a good job or a bad job
whether achieving International best
practice or not so can the Prime
Minister look to see what he can do to
address his historical oversight and
enable Regulators to play their part in
ensuring economic growth
Mr Speaker as always my honorable friend
makes a a very thoughtful point and he's
absolutely right about the importance of
our Regulators in driving growth
competitive investment in our economy I
know the chance we'll have something to
say on this later on but he should rest
assured that we will keep at it to make
sure that there is accountability and
oversight of our Regulators we all want
to see more growth in our economy and
they need to play their part in
delivering it red Stringer
Mr Speaker 20 years after defeat in the
second world war the first Japanese
bullet train traveled the 300 miles from
Tokyo to Osaka at 200 miles an hour
isn't it a measure of the government's
incompetent yes lack of commitment to
the regions uh lack of commitment to
infrastructure that it is now expected
that 24 years after a conservative
transport secretary announced that hs2
would happen that Birmingham Manchester
and London will not be linked by that
time
Mr Mr Mr Speaker we're actually
delivering the biggest rail investment
this is it the the biggest
Israel investment the biggest rail
investment since the Victorian era I'll
just gently point out to The Honorable
gentleman compared to when labor were
lost in office the investment the
investment going into the north is 30
percent higher every single year under
this conservative government we are
delivering for communities across the
north with more trains more buses more
stations and more roads because the
conservative government doesn't just
talk about it it gets on and delivers it
it's another deal
I hope very much that later today we'll
hear news of help for motorists and
small businesses but for most us four
businesses in Bromley and the rest of
outer London they're going to be hard
hit later this year by the mayor of
London stealth tax in a form of an ultra
low emissions
money and jobs isn't it time to revisit
the Local Government Act and revise it
so that such charges can only be imposed
on London boroughs with the consent of
the boroughs themselves well Mr Mr
Speaker my honorable friend makes an
excellent point and is right that the
the mayor of London should listen to the
voices of commuters of families and of
small businesses as he inflicts his
damaging tax on them this government
will always be on the side of those
people and this budget will deliver for
them too a complete prime minister's
questions
well that concludes prime minister's
questions as we await the chancellor
who is making his way
to deliver his budgets Kirsten were
there steering away from economic issues
at Prime Minister's questions so focus
on the BBC and its relationship with the
government after the Gary lineker Rao
but now we await
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt
available to them from the vote office
in members lobby at the end of the
chancellor statement and of course
online
it might also be helpful for some people
who are following our proceedings to
know that British sign language
interpretation of the statement which
will continue until the end of the
speech of the spokesman for the Scottish
national party is available to watch on
parliamentlive.tv advert uh live
subtitling will also be available for
the Chancellor's speech and the
remainder of today's debate I hardly
need remind honorable members but I will
do for good measure that they may not
make interventions during the chancellor
statement nor indeed during the replies
of the leader of the opposition
or even of the spokesman for the
Scottish national party
Chancellor Alex Jacker
[Applause]
Madam Deputy speaker in the face of
enormous challenges I report today on a
British economy which is proving the
doubters wrong
in the Autumn we took difficult
decisions to deliver stability and sound
money
since mid-october 10-year guilt rates
have fallen debt servicing costs are
down mortgage rates are lower and
inflation has peaked
tree fund
says our approach means the UK economy
is on the right track
but we remain Vigilant and will not
hesitate to take whatever steps are
necessary for economic stability
office for Budget responsibility
forecasts that because of changing
International factors and the measures I
take the UK will not now enter a
technical recession this year
[Applause]
foreign
we will meet the prime minister's
priorities to halve inflation reduce
debt and get the economy growing We are
following the plan and the plan is
working
[Applause]
but that's not all we've done
in the face of a cost of living crisis
we have demonstrated our values by
protecting struggling families with a
two and a half thousand pound energy
price guarantee one-off support and the
upbrating of benefits with inflation
taken together these measures are worth
94 billion pounds over this year and
next one of the largest support packages
in Europe that average is Madame Deputy
speaker over 3 300 pounds of cost of
living help for every household in the
country
today we deliver the next part of our
plan a budget for growth not just the
growth that comes when you emerge from a
downturn but long-term sustainable
Healthy Growth that pays for our NHS and
schools finds jobs for young people and
provides a safety net for older people
all whilst making our country one of the
most prosperous in the world Prosperity
with a purpose and that is why growth is
one of the prime minister's five
priorities for our country I deliver
that today by removing obstacles that
stop businesses investing
by tackling labor shortages that stop
them recruiting by breaking down
barriers that stop people working and by
harnessing British Ingenuity to make us
a science and technology superpower
I start with the forecasts produced by
Richard Hughes and his team at the
independent office for Budget
responsibility who I thank for their
diligent work
they have looked in detail at the prime
minister's economic priorities
the first of those is to halve inflation
inflation destroys the value of
hard-earned pay deters investment and
ferments Industrial strife
this government remains steadfast in its
support for the independent monetary
policy committee at the bank of England
as it takes action to return inflation
to the two percent Target
despite continuing Global instability
the obr report today that inflation in
the UK will fall from 10.7 percent in
the final quarter of last year to 2.9
percent by the end of 2023 that is more
than halving inflation
all right
High inflation is the high inflation
Madam Deputy speaker is the root cause
of the strikes we've seen in recent
months we will continue to work hard to
settle those disputes but only in a way
that does not fuel inflation
part of the fall in inflation predicted
by the obr happens because of additional
measures I take today
firstly I recognize that even though
wholesale Energy prices have been
falling there is still enormous pressure
on family finances some people remain in
real distress and we should always stand
ready to help when we can so after
listening to representations from Martin
Lewis and other experts I today confirm
that the energy price guarantee will
remain at two and a half thousand pounds
for the next three months
this means the two and a half thousand
pound cap for the typical household will
remain in place when Energy prices
remain high ahead of an expected fall in
prices from July this measure will save
the average family a further 160 pounds
on top of the energy support measures
already announced
the second measure concerns over 4
million households on prepayment meters
they're often the poorest households but
they currently pay more than comparable
customers on Direct debit offgem has
already agreed with suppliers a
temporary suspension to forced
installations of prepayment meters but
today I go further and confirm we will
bring their charges in line with
comparable direct debit charges
under a conservative government the
energy premium paid by our poorest
customers our poorest households is
coming to an end
[Music]
listened to representations from The
Honorable members for East Devon North
Cornwall comb Valley and Central Suffolk
and North Ipswich about the risk to
community facilities especially swimming
pools caused by high costs when times
are tough
such facilities matter even more
I am providing a a 63
today I am providing a 63 million pound
fund what's up
we want to hear what the chancellor of
the exchequer is actually seeing enough
chance
today I am providing a 63 million pound
fund to keep our public Leisure centers
and pools afloat
I have also heard from my right
honorable friend the Charities Minister
and his secretary of state about the
brilliant work third sector
organizations are doing to help people
struggling in tough times they can often
Reach people in need that Central or
local government cannot so I will give
his Department 100 million pounds to
support thousands of local charities and
community community organizations do
their fantastic work
I also note the personal courage of one
of my predecessors my right honorable
friend from bromsgrove in talking about
the tragedy of suicide and the
importance of preventing it we already
invest a lot in this area but I will
assign an extra 10 million pounds over
the next two years nearly a million
pounds for every year that he's been in
Parliament to help the voluntary sector
play an even bigger role in stopping
families experiencing that intolerable
party
my penultimate cost of living measure
concerns one of our other most treasured
Community institutions the Great British
pub
in December I extended the alcohol Duty
freeze until the 1st of August after
which duties will go up in line with
inflation in the usual way but today I
will do something that was not possible
when we were in the EU and significantly
increased the generosity of draft relief
so that from the 1st of August the duty
on Craft products in pubs will be up to
11 Pence lower than the duty in
supermarkets
it's a differential a conservative
government will maintain as part of a
new brexit pubs guarantee
Madam Deputy speaker
[Music]
Madam Deputy speaker British ale is warm
but the duty on a pint is Frozen
[Applause]
a windsor framework negotiated by my
right honorable friend the Prime
Minister that change will now apply to
every Pub in Northern Ireland
[Applause]
and finally Madam Deputy speaker I have
heard I've heard the representations
from The Honorable member for
Stoke-on-Trent North my right honorable
friend for Witham and my right humble
friend from South thanet and the Sun
newspaper about the impact on motorists
of the planned 11 Pence rise in fuel
Duty I noticed the party opposite called
for a freeze on this Duty somehow they
forgot to tell the British people they
voted against every single Fury
12 years
because because
inflation remains High I have decided
now is not the right time to operate
fuel Duty with inflation or increase the
duty so here's what I'm going to do for
a further 12 months I'm going to
maintain the five key cuts and I'm going
to freeze fuel duty to that saves the
average driver a hundred pounds next
year and around 200 pounds since the 5p
cut was introduced
[Music]
[Applause]
uh energy price guarantee fuel Duty and
Duty on a pint all Frozen in today's
budget that doesn't just help families
it helps the economy too because their
combined impact reduces CPI inflation by
nearly three quarters of a percent this
year lowering inflation when it is
particularly High
I now turn to the prime minister's
second priority which is to reduce debt
here too our plan is on track underlying
debt is forecast to be 92.4 percent of
GDP next year they're 97.3 percent 94.6
percent 94.8 percent before falling to
94.6 in 2728 we are meeting the debt
priority and with a buffer of six and a
half billion pounds it means we are
meeting our fiscal rule to have debt
falling as a percentage of GDP by the
fifth year of the forecast
as a proportion of GDP
our debt remains lower than the USA
Canada France Italy and Japan and
because of the decisions I take today
and the improved outlet for public
finances underlying debt in five years
time is now forecast to be nearly three
percentage points of GDP lower than it
was in the Autumn that means more money
for our public services and a lower
burden for future Generations deeply
held conservative values which we put
into practice today
at the Autumn statement I also announced
that public sector net borrowing must be
below three percent of GDP over the same
period the obr confirmed today that
we're meeting that rule with a buffer of
39.2 billion in fact our deficit Falls
in every single year of the forecast
we're borrowing falling from 5.1 percent
of GDP and 2324 to 3.2 percent to 2.8
percent to 2.2 percent and 1.7 percent
in 27 28 even better in the final two
years of the forecast our current budget
is in Surplus meaning we only borrow for
investment and not for day-to-day
spending
day-to-day departmental spending will
grow one percent a year on average in
real terms after 24 25 until the end of
the forecast period Capital plans are
maintained at the same level set at the
Autumn statement we will upgrade tobacco
Duty and we will freeze the gross gaming
due to yield bans we're also maintaining
the starting rate for savings and Isis
subscription limits and will bring
forward a range of measures to tackle
promoters of tax avoidance schemes
Madam Deputy speaker taken together
today's measures lead to a slightly
lower overall tax burden for the rest of
the parliament compared to the obr's
Autumn forecast other parties run out of
money but a conservative government is
reducing borrowing and improving our
public
[Applause]
by doing so we are on track to halve
inflation get debt falling and grow our
economy which I turn to next
growth Madam Deputy speaker is the prime
minister's third priority and the focus
of today's budget
[Music]
13 years ago we inherited an economy
that had crashed
but since
hey Mike
they might want to listen to this they
might want to listen to this
because since 2010 we've grown more than
major countries like France Italy or
Japan about the same as Europe's largest
economy Germany we've halved
unemployment we've cut inequality we've
reduced the number of workless
households by one million
[Applause]
for the first time ever because of rises
in tax thresholds made by successive
conservative chancellors people in our
country can earn one thousand pounds a
month without paying a penny of tax or
National Insurance
the party opposite opposed those tax
reductions but they have helped lift two
million people out of absolute poverty
after housing costs including 400 000
pensioners and 500 000 children that
average is 80 pensioners and a hundred
children lifted out of poverty for every
single day we've been in office
yeah yeah
and today today we Face the future with
extraordinary potential
the World Bank said that of all big
European countries we are the best place
to do business
the chief Executives say that apart from
America and China we are the best
country to invest in
we became the second country in the
world to have a stock of foreign direct
investment worth two trillion dollars
and London has just picked New York and
53 other Global cities to be the best
place in the world for female
entrepreneurs
declinists are wrong about our country
for another reason
which is our strength in new industries
that will shape this Century over the
last 13 years under conservative
leadership we have become the world's
third trillion dollar Tech economy after
the U.S and China we've built the
largest Life Sciences sector in Europe
producing a coveted vaccine that saved
Six Million Lives and a treatment that
saved a million more our film and TV
industry has become Europe's largest
with our creative Industries growing at
twice the rate of the economy our
Advanced manufacturing Industries
produce around half the world's large
civil aircraft wings and thanks to a
clean energy Miracle we have become a
world leader in offshore wind
other parties talk about a green energy
Revolution
so I gently remind them that nearly 90
percent of our solar power was installed
in the last 13 years showing
the sun is shining
[Applause]
now
let's turn to what the obr say about our
growth prospects
in November they expected that the UK
economy would enter a session in 2022
and contract by 1.4 percent in 23. that
left many families feeling concerned
about the future but today the OVR
forecast we will not enter a recession
at all this year with a contraction of
just 0.2 percent and after this year the
UK economy will grow in every single
year of the forecast period by 1.8 in 24
2.5 percent 2.1 percent and 1.9 in 27.
they also expect
the unemployment rate to rise by less
than one percentage point to 4.4 percent
with 170 000 fewer people out of work
compared to their Autumn forecast
Madam Deputy speaker that return to
growth has direct consequences for our
role on the global stage
I am proud that we are giving the brave
people of Ukraine more Military Support
than anyone else in Europe
on Monday we were we were able to go
even further with my right honorable
friend announcing a 5 billion package of
funding for the ministry of Defense an
additional 2 billion pounds next year
and three billion pounds the year after
today following representative
representations from our persuasive
defense secretary I confirm that we will
add a total of 11 billion pounds to our
defense budget over the next five years
and it will be nearly two and a quarter
percent of GDP by 2025. we were the
first European we were the first large
European country to commit to two
percent of GDP for defense and we will
now raise that to two and a half percent
as soon as fiscal and economic
circumstances allow
and following representations from the
equally persuasive Minister for Veterans
Affairs I am today also increasing
support for our brave ex-servicemen and
women
we will provide a package worth over 30
million pounds to increase the capacity
of the office for Veterans Affairs
support veterans with injuries returning
from their service and increase the
availability of Veteran housing
but to be Europe's biggest defender of
democracy we must build Europe's most
dynamic economy
that means tackling our long-standing
productivity issues including two in
particular which I addressed today lower
business investment and higher economic
inactivity than other countries
too often companies struggle to recruit
and even when they do output per
employee is lower
so today I set out the four pillars of
our industrial strategy to address these
issues
colleagues will know from my Bloomberg
speech they all conveniently start with
the letter e Enterprise employment
education and everywhere
I start Madame Deputy speaker with
everywhere
our measures
well they may not want to level up
growth across the United Kingdom
this government this government was
elected on a mandate to level up
[Music]
four billion pounds in over 200 projects
across the country through the first two
rounds of the leveling up fund a third
round will follow
since we started focusing on leveling up
70 of the growth in salary jobs has come
from outside London and the southeast
and today we take further steps
Canary Wharf and the Liverpool docks
were two outstanding regeneration
projects that happened under a previous
conservative government
I pay tributes to Lord Hazeltine for
making them happen because they
transformed the lives of thousands of
people they showed what's possible when
entrepreneurs government and local
communities come together
so today I announced that we will
deliver 12 new investment zones 12
potential Canary wharfs in England in
England we've identified the following
areas as having the potential to host
one West Midlands greater Manchester the
Northeast South Yorkshire West Yorkshire
East Midlands T side and once again
Liverpool there will also be at least
one in each of Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland
to be to be chosen each area must
identify a location where they can offer
a bold and imaginative partnership
between local governments and the
University or Research Institute in a
way that catalyzes new innovation
clusters if the application is
successful they'll have access to 80
million pounds of support for a range of
interventions including skills
infrastructure tax reliefs and business
rates retention
working together with our formidable
leveling up secretary
I also want to give some further support
to leveling up areas under the E of
everywhere
first I will invest over 200 million
pounds in high quality local
regeneration projects across England
including the Regeneration of Tipton
town center and the Mazda new Mills
Redevelopment scheme I'm also announcing
I'm also announcing a further 161
million pounds for regeneration projects
in Merrell combined authorities and the
greater London Authority and I will make
over 400 million pounds available for
new leveling up Partnerships in areas
that include redcar and Cleveland
Blackburn Oldham Rochdale Mansfield
South tyneside and Basset law
yeah having listened to the case for
better local transport infrastructure
from many honorable members I can
announce a second round of the city
region sustainable transport settlements
allocating 8.8 billion pounds over the
next five-year funding period
and following a wet then cold winter I
have also received particularly strong
representations from my honorable
friends from North Devon Southwest Devon
and Newton Abbott as well as councilor
Peter Martin from my own constituency
about
[Applause]
the spending the spending review
allocated 500 million pounds every year
to the potholes fund but today I have
decided to increase that fund by a
further 200 million pounds next year to
help local communities tackle this
problem
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland this
budget delivers not
Zone but an additional 320 million
pounds for the Scottish government 180
million pounds for the Welsh government
and 130 million pounds for the Northern
Ireland executive as a result of
barnet's consequentials on top of which
on top of which in Scotland I can
announce up to 8.6 million pounds of
targeted funding for the Edinburgh
festivals as well as one and a half
million pounds funding to repair the
cloddock bridge
I will provide 20 million pounds of
funding for the Welsh government to
restore the hollyhead Breakwater
and in Northern Ireland I'm allocating
up to 3 million pounds to extend the
tackling
militarism program and up to 40 million
pounds to extend further and higher
education participation
truly succeed we need to unleash the
Civic entrepreneurship that's only
possible when elected local leaders are
able to fund and deliver solutions to
their own challenges that means giving
them responsibility for Local Economic
growth and the benefits from the upside
when it happens so this government will
consult on transferring responsibilities
for Local Economic Development from
local Enterprise Partnerships to local
authorities from April 24. I will also
boost mayor's Financial autonomy by
agreeing multi-year single settlements
for the West Midlands and greater
combined Manchester Authority in the
next spending review something I intend
to roll out for all mayoral areas over
time I've also agreed a new long-term
commitment so that they can retain 100
of their business rates something I also
hope to expand to other areas investment
zones regeneration projects leveling up
Partnerships Local transportation
structure and business rates retention
more control for local communities over
their economic Destiny so we will level
up wealth and opportunity everywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
today's priority
today's priority is the prime minister's
promise to grow the economy
we've talked about making that growth
happen everywhere so I now move on to my
second e-enterprise we need to be
we need to be well this has never been
something of interest to the labor party
[Applause]
for conservatives we won't rest until we
are Europe's most dynamic enterprise
economy
and under a conservative government
that is exactly what's been happening
since 2010 we have one million more
businesses in the UK a bigger increase
than Germany France or Italy but I want
another million and another million
after that so today I bring forward
Enterprise measures in these three areas
to lower business taxes reduce energy
costs and support our growth industries
so let's start with business taxation
conservatives know the importance of a
competitive tax regime we already have
lower levels of business taxation than
France Germany Italy or Japan
but I want us to have the most
pro-business pro-enterprise tax regime
anywhere
even after the corporation tax rise this
April we will have the lowest headline
rate in the G7 lower than any period
under the last Labor government only
10 percent of companies will pay the
full 25 rate but even at 19 our
corporation tax did not incentivize
investment as effectively as countries
with higher headline rates the result is
less capital investment and lower
productivity than countries like France
and Germany we've already taken measures
to address this for larger business
we've had the super deduction introduced
by my right honorable friend the Prime
Minister which ends this month for
smaller businesses we've increased the
annual investment allowance to one
million pounds meaning 99 of all
businesses can can deduct the full value
of all their investment from that Year's
taxable profits
if the super deduction was allowed to
end without a replacement we would have
fallen down the international league
tables on tax competitiveness and
damaged growth
as a conservative I could not allow that
to happen
so today I can announce we will
introduce a new policy of full capital
expensing for the next three years with
an intention to make it permanent as
soon as we can responsibly do so that
means that every single pound a company
invests in it equipment plant or
Machinery can be deducted in full and
immediately from taxable profits
it is a corporation tax cut worth an
average of nine billion pounds a year
for every year that it's in place and
its impact on the economy will be huge
the obr says it will increase in
business investment by three percent for
every year it's in place this decision
makes us the only major European country
with full expensing and gives us the
joint most generous Capital allowance
regime of any advanced economy
Madam Deputy speaker I understand the
party opposite is reviewing business
taxes let me save them the bother they
put them up we cut them
[Applause]
I also I also want to make our taxes I
also want to make our taxes more
competitive in our life science and
creative industry sectors in the Autumn
I said I'd return with a more robust r d
tax credit scheme for smaller research
intensive companies
so today I'm introducing an enhanced
credit which means that if a qualifying
small or medium-sized business spends 40
or more of their total expenditure on R
D they'll be able to claim a credit
worth 27 pounds for every hundred pounds
they spend
that means an eligible cancer drug
company spending two million pounds on
research and development will receive
over five hundred thousand pounds to
help them develop breakthrough
treatments it's a 1.8 billion pound
package of support helping 20 000
cutting-edge companies who day by day
are turning Britain into a science
superpower
okay
and this government's audio visual tax
reliefs have helped make our film and TV
industry the biggest in Europe only last
month Pinewood announced an expansion
which will bring another 8 000 jobs to
the UK to give even more momentum to
this critical sector I'll introduce an
expenditure credit with a rate of 34 for
film high-end television and video games
and 39 for the animation and children's
TV sectors I'll maintain the qualifying
threshold of high-end television at a
million pounds and because our theater's
orchestras and museums do such a
brilliant job at attracting tourists to
London and the UK I'll extend for
another two years their current 45 and
50 reliefs
Madame Deputy speaker an enterprise
economy needs low taxes but it also
needs cheap and reliable energy
we have already announced billions of
support to help businesses reduce their
energy bills through the energy bills
release scheme and the energy bills
discount scheme
we've appointed Dame Allison Rose chief
executive at NatWest to co-chair our
national Energy Efficiency task force
and help deliver our national ambition
to reduce energy use by 15 and to
support her efforts I'll extend the
climate change agreement scheme for two
years to allow eligible businesses 600
million pounds of tax relief on Energy
Efficiency measures
but the long-term solution is not
subsidy but security
that means investing in domestic sources
of energy that fall outside Putin or any
autocrats control
we are world leaders in renewable energy
so today I want to develop another plank
of our green economy carbon capture
usage and Storage
I'm allocating up to 20 billion pounds
of support
for the early development of ccus
starting with projects from our East
Coast to merseyside to North Wales
Paving the way for cc us everywhere
across the UK as we approach 2050. that
will support up to 50 000 jobs attracts
private sector investment and help
capture 20 to 30 million tons of CO2 per
year by 2030.
we have increased the proportion of
electricity generated from Renewables
from under 10 when we came into office
to nearly 40 percent
but because the wind doesn't always blow
and the sun doesn't always shine even
under the conservatives speaker we will
need we will need another other critical
source of cheap and reliable energy and
that is nuclear
now there have been
markets for this than the honorable
member for innisman
Copeland's Hartlepool and workington
they rightly say that increasing nuclear
capacity is vital to meet our Net Zero
obligations so to encourage private
sector investment into our nuclear
program I today confirm that subjects to
consultation nuclear power will be
classed as environmentally sustainable
[Applause]
that will give it access to the same
investment incentives as renewable
energy
and alongside that will come more public
investment
in the Autumn statement I announced the
first state finance investment in
nuclear for a generation a 700 million
pound investment in size well C today I
can announce two further commitments to
deliver our nuclear Ambitions firstly
following representations from our
energetic energy security secretary I am
announcing the launch of Great British
nuclear which will bring down costs and
provide opportunities across the nuclear
supply chain to help provide one quarter
of our electricity by 2050 and secondly
I am it's so good to hear labor in favor
of nuclear energy
[Applause]
they never did any
secondly I'm launching the first
competition for small modular reactors
it will be completed by the end of this
year and if demonstrated as viable we
will co-fund this exciting new
technology
finally under the E of Enterprise Deputy
speaker I come to our Innovation economy
a central area of national competitive
Advantage for the United Kingdom
over the weekend I worked night and day
with the Prime Minister and the governor
of Bank of England to protect the
deposits of thousands of our most
cutting-edge companies we successfully
secured the sale of the UK arm of
Silicon Valley Bank to HSBC so the
future of those companies is now safe in
the hands of Europe's biggest and one of
its most credit worthy Banks
but those events show that we need to
build a larger more diverse financing
system where the benefits of investment
in high growth firms are available to
more investors so I will return in the
Autumn statement with a plan to deliver
that it will include measures to unlock
productive investment from defined
contribution Pension funds and other
sources make the London Stock Exchange a
more attractive place to list and
complete our response to the challenges
created by the U.S inflation reduction
Act
however when it comes to our Innovation
Industries there are two areas I want to
make progress on today
Nigel Lawson made the city of London one
of the world's top Financial Centers by
competitive deregulation with our brexit
autonomy we can do the same for our high
growth sectors so today I want to reform
the regulations around medicines and
medical Technologies
we are lucky with the mhra to have one
of the most respected drugs Regulators
in in the world indeed the very first
anywhere to license a covid vaccine
from 2024 they will move to a different
model
which will allow rapid often near
automatic sign-off for medicines and
Technologies already approved by trusted
Regulators in other parts of the world
such as the United States Europe and
Japan
at the same time they will set up a
Swift new approval process for the most
cutting-edge medicines and devices to
ensure the UK becomes a global Center
for their development and with an extra
10 million pounds of funding over the
next two years they will put in place
the quickest simplest regulatory
approval in the world for companies
seeking rapid Market access we are proud
of the life science sector which receive
more inward investment than any in
Europe last year today's change will
make the UK an even more exciting place
to invest using our brexit freedoms and
speeding up access for NHS patients to
the very newest drugs
today with our talented science
Innovation and Technology secretary I
also take measures to strengthen our
position in artificial intelligence
where the UK hosts one-third of All
European country companies
I'm accepting all nine of the digital
technology recommendations made by Sir
Patrick Valance in the review I asked
him to do in the Autumn statement
that means I can report to the house
that we will launch an AI sandbox to
trial new faster approaches to help
innovators get cutting-edge products to
Market we'll work at PACE with the
intellectual property office to provide
Clarity on IP rules so that generative
AI companies can access the material
they need
and we'll ask the Patrick successor Dame
Angela McLean to report before the
summer on options around the growth Duty
for regulators
because AI needs Computing horsepower I
today commit around 900 million pounds
of funding to implement the
recommendations of the independent
future of compute review for an exascale
computer
the power needed by ai's complex
algorithms can also be provided by
Quantum computing so today we'll publish
a Quantum strategy which will set out
our vision to be a world-leading Quantum
enabled economy by 2033 with a research
and Innovation program totaling two and
a half billion pounds
[Applause]
I also want to encourage the best AI
research to happen in the UK so we'll
award a prize of one million pounds
every year for the next 10 years to the
person or team that does the most
groundbreaking British AI research the
world's first stored program computer
was built at the University of
Manchester in 1948 and was known as the
Manchester baby 75 years on the baby has
grown up so I will call this new
National AI award the Manchester prize
in its honor
[Applause]
Deputy speaker
who won the UK to be
safe for everybody we want the UK to be
the best place in Europe for companies
to locate invest and grow so today's
Enterprise measures strengthen our
technology and life science sectors
invest in energy security and for three
years but I hope permanently cut
corporation tax by nine billion pounds a
year to give us the best incentive
investment incentives of any advanced
economy
an enterprise economy
can only grow if it can hire the people
it needs which brings me to my third
pillar after everywhere and Enterprise
I said it was a growth budget Madame
Deputy speaker and we are talking about
the E of employment
I'm going to talk about a difficult
topic for the party opposite now because
brexit was a decision by the British
people to change our economic model
in that that in that historic vote our
country decided to move from a model
based on unlimited low-skill migration
to one based on high wages and high
skills
today we show how we will deliver that
with a major set of reforms the obr say
it is the biggest positive supply-side
intervention they have ever recognized
in their forecast
we have around 1 million vacancies in
the economy but excluding students there
are over 7 million adults of working age
who are not in work that's a potential
pool of seven people for every vacancy
conservatives believe work is a virtue
we agree with the road haulage King
Eddie Stobart who said the only place
success comes before work is the
dictionary
so so today I bring forward reforms to
remove the barriers that stop people who
want to from working and I start with
over 2 million people who are inactive
due to a disability or long-term
sickness
thanks to the reforms courageously
introduced by the right honorable member
for chingford and Woodford green the
number of disabled people in work has
risen by 2 million since 2013.
but even after that we could fill half
the vacancies in the economy with people
who say they would like to work despite
being inactive due to sickness or
disability with zoom teams and new
working models that make it easier to
work from home this is possible now more
than ever
so for that reason the ever diligent
work and pension secretary today takes
the next step in his groundbreaking work
on tackling economic active inactivity
I thank him for that and today we
publish a white paper on disability
benefits reform it is the biggest change
to our welfare system in a decade his
plans will abolish the work capability
assessment in Great Britain and separate
benefit entitlement from an individual's
ability to work
as a result disabled benefit claimants
will always be able to seek work without
fear of losing financial support
today I'm going further by announcing
that in England and Wales after
listening to representations for this
from the center for social justice and
others we will fund a new program called
Universal support
this is a new voluntary employment
scheme for disabled people where the
government will spend up to four
thousand pounds a person to help them
find appropriate jobs and put in place
the support they need it will fund 50
000 places every single year we also
want to help those who are forced to
leave work because of a health condition
such as a back pain or a mental health
issue
we should give them support before they
end up leaving their job so working with
our health secretary I'm announcing a
400 million pound plan to increase the
availability of mental health and
musculoskeletal resources and expand the
individual placement and support scheme
and because Occupational Health provided
by employers has a key role to play I'll
also bring forward two new consultations
on how to improve its availability and
double the funding for the small company
subsidy pilot
there's another group that deserves
particular attention which is children
in care
they too should be given all possible
help to make a normal working life
possible when they reach adulthood
often they depend on Foster families who
do a brilliant job so today I'm nearly
doubling the qualifying care relief
threshold to 18 140 pounds which will
give a tax cut to a qualifying carer
worth an average of 450 pounds a year
I'll also increase the funding we
provide to the staying close program by
50 percent to help more care leavers
into employment and I'll support young
people with special educational needs
and disabilities with a 3 million pilot
expansion of the department for
Education supported internship program
to help those people transition from
education into the workplace
Madame Deputy speaker no civilized
society can ignore the contribution that
can be made by those with challenging
family circumstances a long-term illness
or a disability so today we remove the
barriers we can with reforms that
strengthen our society as well as
strengthening our economy
the next set of employment reforms
affects those on universal credit
without a health condition who are
looking for work or on low earnings
there are more than two million job
seekers in this group more than enough
to fill every vacancy in the economy
Independence is always better than
dependents which is why a conservative
government believes
[Applause]
with some exceptions Madam Deputy
speaker
Independence is always better than
dependence which is why a conservative
government believes those who can work
should so sanctions will be applied more
rigorously to those who fail to meet
strict work search requirements or
choose not to take up a reasonable job
offer and for those working low hours we
will increase the administrative
earnings threshold from the equivalent
of 15 hours to 18 hours at National
living wage for an individual claimant
meaning that anyone working below this
level will receive more work coach
support alongside a more intensive
conditionality regime
the next group of workers I want to
support are those aged over 50
my younger officials have turned these
people older workers although as a 56
year old myself I prefer the term
experienced
fully three and a half million people of
pre-retirement age over 50 are not part
of the labor force an increase of 320
000 pounds since 320 000 since before
the pandemic we now have the 23rd
highest inactivity rate for over 55s in
the oecd if we match the rate of Sweden
we would add more than a million people
to our National Labor Force Madam Deputy
speaker I say this not to flatter you
but older people are the most skilled
and experienced people we have
[Applause]
no no
country can Thrive no country can Thrive
if it turns its back on such a wealth of
talent and ability but for too many
turning 50 is a moment of anxiety about
the cliff edge of retirement rather than
a moment of anticipation about another
two decades of fulfillment
I know this Madam Deputy speaker myself
after I turned 50 I was relegated to the
back benches and planned for a quiet
life but instead I decided to set an
example by embarking on a new career in
finance
so today I take three steps to make it
easier for those who wish to
[Applause]
it's going well thank you and today I
take three steps to make it easier for
those who wish to to work longer first
we will increase the number of people
who get the best possible Financial
Health and career guidance ahead of
retirement by enhancing the dwp's
excellent midlife mot strategy they will
also increase by fivefold the number of
50 plus Universal credits who receive
midlife mots from 8 000 to 40 000 a year
second with my right hand right on rent
the education secretary who has a deep
personal commitment to this area will
introduce a new kind of apprenticeship
targeted at the over 50s who want to
return to work they will be called
returnerships
and operate alongside skills boot camps
and sector-based work academies they'll
bring together our existing skills
programs to make them more appealing for
older workers focusing on flexibility
and previous experience to reduce
training length
finally I have listened to the concerns
of many senior NHS clinicians who say
unpredictable pension tax charges are
making them leave the NHS just when they
are needed the most
the NHS is our biggest employer and we
will shortly publish a long-term
Workforce plan that I promised in the
Autumn statement
of that I don't want any doctor to
retire early because of the way pension
taxes work
it's an issue I've discussed not just
with the current health secretary but a
former Health secretary who kindly took
a break from whatsapping his colleagues
to consider it
realized the issue goes wider than
doctors no one should be pushed out of
the workforce for tax reasons so today I
will increase the pensions annual
tax-free allowance from by 50 percent
from forty thousand to sixty thousand
some have also asked me to increase the
lifetime allowance from its one million
pound limit
but I've decided not to do that instead
I will go further and abolish the
lifetime allowance
[Music]
tax reform
that will stop over 80 percent of NHS
doctors from receiving a tax charge
incentivize our most experienced and
productive workers to stay in work for
longer and simplify our tax system
taking thousands of people out of the
complexity
audiences because the touch of the
executive is either unpopular or popular
we still have to keep the noise down
because we still have to hear what he
has to say he has more to say
thank you madam Deputy speaker this is a
comprehensive plan to remove the
barriers to work facing those on
benefits those with health conditions
and older workers that is the E of the
employment pillar of today's growth
budget which brings me to the final
pillar of our growth plan after
employment Enterprise and everywhere I
turn to the E of Education
over more than a decade
this conservative government has driven
improvement in our education system
we've risen by nearly 10 places in the
international league tables for English
and maths since 2015 alone
in the Autumn statement I built on this
program with an extra 2.3 billion pounds
annual Investments to our schools
we're reviewing our approach to skills
with Sir Michael Barber we set out our
plans to transform lifelong learning
with a new lifelong loan entitlement and
my right honorable friend the Prime
Minister announced plans to make maths
compulsory till 18. but today I want to
address an issue in our education system
that is bad for children and damaging
for the economy it's an issue that
starts even before a child enters the
gates of a school today I want to reform
our child care system
we have one of the most expensive
systems in the world almost half
of non-working mothers
say they would prefer to work if they
could arrange suitable child care for
many women a career break becomes a
career end
our female participation participation
rate is higher than average for oecd
economies but we Trail top performers
like Denmark and the Netherlands if we
match Dutch levels of participation
there will be more than one million
additional women working
and we can do that
so today I announce a series of reforms
that start that Journey
I begin with the supply of child care
we've seen a significant decline in
child minders over recent years down
nine percent in England in just one year
but child minders are a vital way to
deliver affordable and flexible care and
we need more of them
so I've listened to representations from
my honorable friend from Stroud
and decided to address this by piloting
incentive payments of 600 pounds for
child minders who sign up to the
profession rising to 1200 pounds for
those who join through an agency
I've also heard many concerns about cost
pressures facing the sector
we know this is making it hard to hire
staff and raising prices for parents
with around two-thirds of child care
providers increasing fees last year
alone
so we'll increase the funding paid to
nurseries providing free child care
under the hours offer by 204 million
pounds from this September rising to 288
million pounds next year that's an
average of a 30 percent increase in the
two-year-old rate this year just as the
sector has requested I will also offer
providers more flexibility in how they
operate in line with other parts of the
UK so alongside that additional funding
we will change minimum staff to child
ratios from one to four to one to five
for two-year-olds in in England as
happens in Scotland although the new
ratios will remain optional with no
obligation on either child minders or
parents to adopt them
I want to help the 700 000 parents on
universal credits who until the reforms
I announced today have limited
requirements to look for work many
remain out of work because they cannot
afford The Upfront payment necessary to
access subsidized child care
so for any parents who are moving into
work or want to increase their hours we
will pay the child care costs up front
and we will increase the maximum they
can claim to 951 pounds for one child
and 1 630 pounds for two children an
increase of almost 50 percent
I turn now to parents of school-aged
children who often face barriers to
working because of the limited
availability of wrap-around care
one-third of primary schools do not
offer Child Care at both ends of the
school day even though for many people a
job requires it to be available before
and after school
to address this we'll fund schools and
local authorities to increase the supply
of wraparound care so all school age
parents can drop their children off
between 8 AM and 6 p.m and our ambition
is that all schools will start to offer
a full wrap-around offer either on their
own or in partnership with other schools
by September 2026.
[Music]
Madame deputy
increased the availability of child care
reduce costs and increase the number of
parents able to use it taken together
with earlier conservative reforms they
amount to the most significant
improvements to child care provision in
a decade but if we really want to remove
the barriers to work we need to go
further for parents who have a child
under three
for them Child Care remains just too
expensive
in 2010 there was barely any free child
care for under fives
a conservative-led government changed
that with free child care for three and
four-year-olds in England it was a
landmark reform
but not a complete one I don't want any
parent with a child under five to be
prevented from working if they want to
because it's damaging to our economy and
unfair mainly to women
so today I announce that ineligible
households where all adults are working
at least 16 hours we will introduce 30
hours of free child care not just for
three and four-year-olds but for every
single child over the age of nine months
the 30-hour offer will now start from
the moment maternity or paternity leave
ends it's a package worth on average six
and a half thousand pounds every year
for a family with a two-year-old child
using 35 hours of child care every week
and reduces their child care costs by
nearly 60 percent
hey
because it is such a large reform we
will introduce it in stages to ensure
there is enough Supply in the market
working parents of two-year-olds will be
able to access 15 hours of free care
from April 2024 helping around half a
million parents
from September 24
will be extended to all children from
nine months up meaning a total of nearly
1 million parents will be eligible
and from September 25 every single
working parent of under fives will have
access to 30 hours free child care per
week
Mr Perkins
stop it
[Applause]
Madam Deputy speaker today we complete a
landmark conservative reform we help the
economy transform the lives of thousands
of women and build a child care system
comparable to the best a major early
years reform for our education system
the E of Education alongside the three
other pillars of our growth plan
Enterprise employment and everywhere
so Madam Deputy speaker in November we
delivered stability today it's growth we
tackle the two biggest barriers that
stop businesses growing investment
incentives and labor Supply the best
investment incentives in Europe the
biggest ever employment package for
disabled people more help for older
people barriers removed for families
feeling the pinch fuel Duty Frozen beer
Duty cut energy bills capped and for
parents 30 hours of free child care for
all under fives today we build for the
future with inflation down debt falling
and growth up the declinists are wrong
and the optimists are right
to the plan
the plan is working and I commend this
statement to the house
[Music]
I thank the chancellor of the exchequer
for his budget statement and I hope the
house will
settle down please
understanding order number 51 the first
motion entitled absolutely the bad
behaviors are on this side of the house
I think a little bit of decorum please
while we go through the necessary parts
of the procedure understanding order
number 51 the first motion entitled
provisional collection of taxes must be
decided without debate well the
chancellor of the exchequer please move
formally
um
thank you Chancellor I'm just putting
your emotions the question is that
pursuant to section 5 of the provisional
collection of taxes act 1968 provisional
statutory effect shall be given to the
following motions a stamp Duty land tax
transaction funded with the assistance
of a subsidy motion number 39 B Fuel
duties accepted machines motion number
44 C rates of tobacco products Duty
motion number 46 D late payment interest
value added tax portion number 57 e
Charities value added tax
Etc motion number 65 as many as are of
that opinion say I
of the contrary no I think the eyes have
it the eyes have it let us now consider
the motion entitled income tax charge
for it's on this motion that the debate
will take place today and on the
succeeding days the questions on this
motion
and on the remaining motions will be put
at the end of the budget debate on
Tuesday the 21st of March so I call the
chancellor the exchequer to move the
motion formally move forward
the question is that income tax is
charged for the tax year
2023-24 and it is declared that it's
expedient in the public interest that
this resolution should have statutory
effect under the provisions
or just as they vote and move some of
those motions we await the response for
the shadow Chancellor to the budget but
just to take you through some of the key
announcements for what the chancellor
did let's say just a few moments ago one
of the headlines was that the economy is
now expected to just about afford void
recession this year which means that
Jeremy Hunt claims of the five Pleasures
uh he is on track let's listen to kirst
armor not quite as bad now as they were
in October last year after Kamikaze
budget and the more that he pretends
everything is fine the more he shows
just how out of touch they are
after 13 years of his government our
economy needed major surgery but like
Millions across our country this budget
leaves us stuck in the waiting room with
only a sticking plaster to hand a
country set on a path of managed decline
falling behind our competitors the sick
man of Europe once again
this was a day for ambition for bringing
us together with purpose and intent for
unlocking the pride that is in every
Community matching their belief in the
possibilities of the future but Madam
Deputy speaker after today we know the
Tory cupboard is as bare as the salad
Isle in our supermarket
[Applause]
the lettuces may be out but the turnips
are in
I hopelessly divided party caught
between a rock of Decline and a hard
place of their own economic recklessness
dressing up stagnation of stability as
their expiry date looms ever closer
and the figures published today spell it
out a year of stagnation growth
non-existent according to the IMF the
worst performing country in the G7 this
year a prediction today confirmed by the
obr and growth downgraded in years to
come this is a failure you can measure
not just in the figures but in the empty
pockets of working people right across
the country
13 years without wage growth 13 years no
better off 13 years stuck in a doom Loop
of lower growth higher taxes and broken
public proper services
[Applause]
Deputy Madam speaker our opr makes clear
today things don't look any better in
the long run a broken labor market
holding back our prospects seven million
on the NHS waiting lists ill health and
disability on the rise and the
consequences as we've just heard defer
to the Future the classic short-term
sticking plaster cycle decisions
cynically duck today paying for working
people tomorrow
it doesn't have to be like this Britain
has enormous potential on science
innovation technology we should be
leading not lagging we need an
industrial strategy that removes
barriers to investment
of the announcements today are nowhere
near the mark the lowest investment in
the G7 that's their record
all our competitors know this they're
gearing up for Almighty race for the
opportunities of tomorrow and we've got
to be on the start line not back in the
changing room tying our laces
now he mentioned the war in Ukraine and
of course on this side of the house we
stand with Ukraine and we stand with the
government's response to Putin's
brutality we'll look carefully at the
details of the military spending
announced and we will support them
but what we cannot accept is the use of
the war as a blanket excuse for failure
found in other countries wages in this
country are lower now in real terms than
they were 13 years ago
the average French family is a 10th
richer the average German family a fifth
richer countries which face the same
pandemic countries which face the same
War
and the war didn't ban onshore wind the
war didn't scrap our home insulation
scream see the war didn't run down our
gas storage facilities they did
decisions which hurt working people
battling the cost of living crisis right
now
it's been the same story for the whole
13 years always the sticking plaster
never The Cure and today's budget does
nothing to change that
again we see a failure to grip the
long-term challenges no order
not the leader of the opposition is
delivering this before
shouldn't be listening no we will now
listen to the leader of the opposition
so
today's budget changes nothing again we
see a failure to grip the long-term
challenges no determination to create
growth which unlocks the potential of
the many working people being made to
pay for Tory choices and Tory mistakes
[Music]
Madam Deputy speaker these are the
organizing principles of conservative
economics judge them by their choices
the running down of our Public Services
paid for by working people the disaster
of the Tory mortgage premium paid for by
working people the opportunities still
missed for a proper windfall tax paid
for by working people
that's what makes the Chancellor's boast
about lower inflation so ridiculous the
idea that it's a tax cut British people
can see through that they see their tax
burden at its highest level for 70 years
and they know it's not the government
that's lowering inflation it's working
people earning less enjoying less it's
their sacrifice that is helping to bring
inflation down and they deserve better
than another Cheap Trick from the
government of gimmicks making them pay
whilst trying to claim the credit
even with the price guarantee the
average Energy bill has doubled in 18
months because of their recklessness the
average mortgage payment is up 2 000
pounds a year a a massive hit to living
standards however they cook the books
and yet still no real ambition on
Industrial strategy no real ambition on
the clean energy that will give us
cheaper bills no real ambition on house
building the same old Tory choices
sticking plaster politics no growth for
the many working people paid
and let's turn to his policies on the
cost of living Madam Deputy speaker I
say his policies because there's a
history to this a pattern over the
course of the whole cost of living
crisis time and again it's labor who
bring the government not just to its
senses but to our position
who first pushed for the energy price
guarantee labor who first called for a
proper windfall tax labor who first
stood by people on prepayment meters
labor and who first said we should
freeze the price guarantee this April
labor and and we can go on because it's
also labor the first committee to
extending the fuel dirty cup
a policy that in January he dismissed as
part of a dossier that he published
so for one poor soul in their research
team at least this really is a back to
work budget
and
[Applause]
for the chancellor as he promotes this
policy in coming days
use your own car and For Heaven's Sake
make sure you know how to use a debit
card
and I look forward to the Prime Minister
promoting the swimming pools policy
unlike the car he won't have to borrow
one of those
but Madam Deputy speaker the cost of
living crisis is not over and once again
they've left money on the table when it
comes to oil and gas companies money
that could have been better spent on
working people
politics is about whose side you're on
there are loopholes that urgently need
closing even the former CEO of shell
admitted that they should be paying more
of the long-term plan just isn't there
the same old Tory choices the same three
principles sticking plaster politics no
growth for the many working people pay
and you see those principles at play in
our broken labor market
much of what the chancellor said today
focused on that as well it might
the figures announced in this budget
show how damaging the current situation
is to growth a long-term drag on our
ability to create more wealth our
inactivity levels are particularly
shocking up half a million since the
pandemic the worst jobs recovery since
the G7 people unable to work because of
ill health more than ever before
now we will look at what the chancellors
announced today because on these benches
we've long called for reform of the work
capability assessment for a welfare
system that supports people with
disabilities and long-term health
conditions to thrive at work the
Universal Credit system must help people
into employment and child care is a huge
barrier to that we've made the case for
reform
but on child care of course more money
on the system is obviously a good thing
[Applause]
they obviously didn't listen to when he
said he's actually going to do it
and we've seen the tours expand
so-called three hours before
and as parents up and down the country
know it's no use having more free hours
if you can't access things and it pushes
the cost for parents outside the offer
that's what we've seen before
and on pensions he made a big spending
commitment which will benefit those with
the broadest shoulders
where many people are struggling to save
into their pension we needed a fix for
doctors but the announcement today is a
huge giveaway to some of the very
wealthiest
the only permanent tax cut in the budget
is for the richest one percent how can
that possibly be a priority for this
government
[Music]
the truth is our labor market is the
cast iron example of an economy with
weak foundations our crisis in
participation simply hasn't happened
elsewhere not to this extent it's a
feature of Tory Britain and Global
excuses won't wash we need a wider
reform agenda
instead of making working people pay we
need to make work pay move on from
growth that's based on insecure low-paid
jobs to growth which comes from good
work from strong employment rights that
can deliver higher productivity growth
from the many for the many but makes
people better off in all parts of our
country
I welcome this announcement on
Devolution deals the principle that we
should push power out of Westminster is
fully supported on this side of the
house in fact we want him to go further
communities Beyond Birmingham deserve
the right powers and the same powers to
drive growth as well
[Music]
former Health secretary
published all
the signed copy of this book
he knows that growth needs an NHS fit
for the future
and no country can be fit for work when
there are seven million people on
Hospital waiting
so I was waiting for him to match
Labor's ambition absolutely waiting for
him to match our plan to train more
doctors and nurses to tackle the
capacity crisis a policy he publicly
praised just 15 days before he became
Chancellor and yet it never came a
madame Deputy speaker if there was ever
a symbol of the poverty of ambition that
is it
because the reality is the country
getting sicker is a country getting
poorer and a country getting poorer is a
country getting sicker health and wealth
must go together Britain can't afford to
be the sick man of Europe Britain can't
afford the Tories
[Applause]
there is another way on these benches we
understand institutions must be
respected constraints accepted the
fiscal rules should be fat sound and
followed rigorously that every pound is
precious and must not be wasted
but they want to shout about their
record let them shout wages lower taxes
higher borrowing higher debt higher
their chaos has a cost
[Applause]
certainty is vital for the growth we
need essential for businesses and
investors in our country as we've
spelled out compared with a blanket cut
to corporation tax investment allowances
are the right approach but the pressure
many businesses will ask today is how
long before the wind blows again and we
all go through this again
and that's what they don't understand
about business investment they're
endless fighting on tax is bad for
growth in and of itself
Madam Deputy has been real stability
means that taxes don't go up and down
like yo-yos
warranty tax credit regime doesn't get
overhauled twice in six months
order okay that's enough I now can't
hear the right honorable gentleman at
all exactly and it's nothing to do with
being old not quiet
Dorma
thank you let me give an example of that
instability it's a bit of a subject at
the moment but when he was culture
secretary the chancellor apparently took
some lessons on the rules of football
so let me provide a refresher the amount
of times his government has broken their
fiscal rules 11. that's one football
team the amount of times they've changed
corporation tax policy 22 that's two
teams you've got a game
but if he wants the postmax analysis
he'll have to consult the experts back
on his screens and ours this weekend I
know the whole house will want to
applaud that
but Madam Deputy speaker a budget is not
just about the choices made but the
choice is ignored Britain needs more
than certainty for growth that's the
least we should expect we need change
stability and success
anyone listening to this and worried
about NHS waiting list any about crime
it's about crime going unpunished you
don't want to hit they don't want to
hear they don't want to hear about the
waiting list
they don't want to hear about the crime
going unpunished house building rates
falling don't want to hear about that
either I suppose do you yeah
they will have heard very little that
makes them feel hopeful about our future
they could have used sensible taxation
policies or non-doms or oil and gas
companies have made the money work for
working people tackled the vested
interests that gum up our planning
system and shown real ambition or the
investment we need to turn us into a
green growth superpower
and that was the test today can we move
beyond the usual sticking plaster
Solutions set a new direction for growth
that serves the interests of working
people
but I'm afraid the verdict on this
budget is clear they won't offer change
because they can't and so our force is
managed to
clean going backwards the sick man of
Europe once again
that's the Britain they've created and
they should look it in the eye
because today's figures on growth put
their failures up in lights
after 13 years of tourists sticking
plaster politics 13 years of no growth
for the many 13 years of being asked to
pay
working people are entitled to ask am I
any better off than I was before and
after 30 years
the resounding answer is no and they
know it
[Applause]
[Music]
now we'll just have things like that
just settle down a bit now please and
the people are leaving let's do so
quickly and quietly
just out of consideration for everyone
else who is still taking part in the
debates
before I come to come on and get a move
on
before I come to the chairman of the
treasury select committee Harriet
Baldwin
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
I'm wonderful to have you back
after that torrent of socialist
declinism from the opposition
who wants to start by saying how lucky
we are to have a lucky Chancellor
[Applause]
been lucky this winter because
the weather has been a lot warmer than
when he stood here in November and as a
result
price of energy has come down but he has
also made some of his own luck Madame
Deputy speaker because thanks to the
steps that he took the financial markets
have stabilized and he has had to pay
less in interest than he was expecting
to about 4 billion pounds
it is actually quite hard to believe
that this is the first actual official
budget that we've had in this chamber
since October 2021.
are a lot of things have changed since
the last time we had a budget
our world leading NHS vaccination
railout rollout has ended the severe
contagion of the pandemic but Putin's
evil and illegal invasion of Ukraine has
sparked the worst inflation for 40 years
the challenges those events have placed
on the public finances have been
extraordinary and the spending can't all
be borrowed and passed on to the next
generation and that's why I welcome the
news today from the chancellor that he's
forecasting three percent lower debt in
years to come yeah our committee the
treasury committee welcomes the fact
that the budget is accompanied by
forecast from the office for Budget
responsibility
we think uh that it's important that
that stands alongside a budget it's a
key part of the independent framework
for chancellors and we will be taking
evidence from them next week on the
underlying assumptions behind their
forecasts
because what has changed most
perniciously since the last budget in
October 2021 is inflation
it was only just beginning to rear its
ugly head in October 2021
and as a member of the treasury
committee throughout this entire period
I've been like Cassandra in highlighting
some of the inflationary risks that
we've faced
far from being transitory as the
Independent Bank of England hoped
inflation has become quite deeply
embedded in the UK economy in wage
inflation and in expectations and that's
why I welcome the news today that the
office for Budget responsibility is
expecting that by the end of this year
inflation will be back down to 2.9
percent again because inflation is the
worst tax that we have on our economy it
is a tax pay particularly by the very
poorest who spend the highest proportion
of their incomes on food and energy and
so the chancellor must not hear the
siren voices
urging him to increase or to abandon the
inflation Target that he gives to the
Independent Bank of England the top
priority for our economy this year must
be to at least half inflation
it's to be welcomed that in his budget
today the chancellor has tried to focus
on measures that help to achieve that
inflation Target
the extension of the fuel Duty freeze
and the cap on household energy costs
will all help to keep inflation lower by
almost one percent uh but lower than it
would have been
and these may not feel like giveaways
but they do cost money against the
do-nothing counterfactual option so it's
good to see that they're being
implemented because of better public
finances and that these tax cuts can be
seen as consistent with the government's
second priority of reducing debt
in our recent treasury committee report
we called on the chancellor to think
again about the fiction that lies behind
fuel Duty forecasts
every year they get embedded in the
fiscal Outlook and every year
chancellors realize that it's not an
ideal time to raise fuel Duty I welcome
the fact that the fuel Duty cut has been
extended for another year and that once
again the fiction has not been followed
through into reality but I do think we
need to think long and hard about why
attacks that is inflationary that harms
growth and is heading the way of the
dodo as we all move to electric cars is
still in the forecast numbers
the third Economic Policy of growing the
economy in a non-inflationary way will
involve all of us working more
productively and the stride review named
after my illustrious predecessor has
rightly focused on this key key question
and I think there were many measures
that we can all see will be very helpful
that were announced in today's uh budget
because with over 1 million job
vacancies in our economy we are still as
a country working fewer hours than we
were before the pandemic and unlocking
that human and economic current
potential is key to strong productive
non-inflationary growth so the steps
that have been announced today on child
care and on pensions will help to ease
the labor shortages that are pushing up
wage demands and they will help counter
those inflationary pressures and so the
treasury committee looks forward to
exploring all of these issues in detail
with both our expert Witnesses I'm with
the chancellor in himself
well that was Jeremy Hunt's budget and
the reaction to it as well the first
budget in over a year three chancellors
since the last one was delivered and the
economic figures saying that they will
narrowly avoid recession this year the
forecast bad but maybe not as bad as
previous but the obr of course still
predicting the biggest ever fallen
living standards in 2022 and 2023 since
records began
you're watching Sky News live from
Westminster it is two o'clock as the
chancellor presents his vision for the
country's financial future well this
afternoon we are going to be assessing
the budget announcements with Beth Rigby
and our economics and data editor aired
Conway well Jeremy Hunt has unveiled his
budget for growth as the fiscal Watchdog
predicts inflation will fall to 2.9
percent by the end of the year
international monetary fund
says our approach means the UK economy
is on the right track
today's budget changes nothing again we
see a failure to grip the long-term
challenges no determination to create
growth which unlocks the potential of
the many working people being made to
pay for Tory choices and Tory mistakes
well the chancellor announces 30 hours a
week of free for every child in England
age between nine months and five years
on energy an end of the prepayment
penalty for the poorest and average
bills will stay at 2 500 pounds for
three more months
corporation tax is going to rise but
businesses will be able to deduct
expenses from taxable profits
and fuel Duty will remain Frozen at five
pence a liter which will save motorists
100 pounds next year
town with the highest inflation in the
country including what they think of the
lifetime pension allowance being a drops
that's uh in order to entice older
people back into work
but no new pay deals as hundreds of
thousands of teachers Junior doctors
tube workers and civil servants go on
strike
budget as Chancellor Jeremy Hunt said
the UK is proving the doubt is wrong as
he vowed the country is set to avoid a
technical recession this year will take
him to his feet in the Commons he
painted a picture of falling inflation
with announcements on Child Care fuel
Duty pensions and more there's a lot to
analyze and we're going to be looking
through all of the details you can see
the book spread on the desk in front of
us with Skies political editor Beth
Rigby and skies economics and data
editor Ed Conway alongside us to
decipher what the measures will mean for
you before we do that we can just take
you through the key announcements the
chancellor began his budget by
announcing that the UK is expected to
avoid a technical recession this year
and that's because of forecasts that say
inflation is set to fall from 10.7 to
just 2.9 percent by the end of 2023. the
energy price guarantee will now continue
until June with household bills
remaining at 2 500 pounds and the
chancellor has promised 30 hours of free
child care a week to working parents in
England with children aged between nine
months and five years
which Emery hunt also announced what he
called full expensing now that is a 9
billion pound scheme which means every
pound a company invests in it equipment
plant or Machinery can be deducted in
full and immediately from taxable
profits and in an effort to try and
boost growth the government will also
invest 80 million pounds over five years
in 12 new UK investment zones
as expected Corporation attacks is going
to be increased from 19 to 25 percent
we took difficult decisions to deliver
stability and sound money
since mid-october 10-year guilt rates
have fallen debt servicing costs are
down mortgage rates are lower and
inflation has peaked
tree fund says our approach means the UK
economy is on the right track
but we remain Vigilant and will not
hesitate to take whatever steps are
necessary for economic stability
today the office for Budget
responsibility forecasts that because of
changing International factors and the
measures I take the UK will not now
enter a technical recession this year
[Applause]
they forecast
they
[Applause]
they forecast we will meet the prime
minister's priorities to halve inflation
reduce debt and get the economy growing
the chance that they're making the most
of those APR forecasts that the economy
will narrowly avoid a recession this
year he also announced some business
investment support
I can announce we will introduce a new
policy of full capital expensing for the
next three years with an intention to
make it permanent as soon as we can
responsibly do so that means that every
single pound a company invests in it
equipment plant or Machinery can be
deducted in full and immediately from
taxable profits
it is a corporation tax cut worth an
average of nine billion pounds a year
for every year that it's in place and
its impact on the economy will be huge
the obr says it will increase in
business investment by three percent for
every year it's in place
it was a pretty unusual budget here that
most of the measures if not all had been
leaked or trails in advance at one of
A's of course was if you like the big
rabbit on child care because a
Chancellor did confirm extra financial
help for working parents who may be
struggling to pay for childcare
so for any parents who are moving into
work or want to increase their hours we
will pay the child care costs up front
and we will increase the maximum they
can claim to 951 pounds for one child
and 1 630 pounds for two children an
increase of almost 50 percent
I turn now to parents of school-aged
children who often face barriers to
working because of the limited
availability of wraparound care
one-third of primary schools do not
offer Child Care at both ends of the
school day even though for many people a
job requires it to be available before
and after school
to address this we'll fund schools and
local authorities to increase the supply
of wraparound care so all school-age
parents can drop their children off
between 8 AM and 6 p.m and our ambition
is that all schools will start to offer
a full wraparound offer either on their
own or in partnership with other schools
by September 2026
including the announcement that he
wanted to boost the 33 hours to everyone
age from nine months onwards too it'd
also been speculations that the
chancellor would increase their lifetime
allowance for pension savings to 1.8
million pounds but actually he decided
to abolish the limit altogether
we will increase the number of people
who get the best possible Financial
Health and career guidance ahead of
retirement by enhancing the dwp's
excellent mid-life mot strategy they
will also increase by fivefold the
number of 50 plus Universal credits who
receive mid-life mots from 8 000 to 40
000 a year
second with my right honorable friends
the education secretary who has a deep
personal commitment to this area will
introduce a new kind of apprenticeship
targeted at the over 50s who want to
return to work I have listened to the
concerns of many senior NHS clinicians
who say unpredictable pension tax
charges are making them leave the NHS
just when they are needed the most so
today I will increase the pension's
annual tax-free allowance from by 50
percent from forty thousand to sixty
thousand some have also asked me to
increase the lifetime allowance from its
one million pound limit
but I've decided not to do that instead
I will go further and abolish the
lifetime allowance
foreign
for a bit of reaction and Beth the
giveaways tended to be all around trying
to get more people back into work we
heard him there talking about the
pensions allowance but that's going to
really benefit the wealthiest right it
is I mean look so if you sort of in the
round uh a close Ally of the Prime
Minister said to me in the run-ups this
budget is not going to be a big bang
budget yeah it's Steady As She Goes
stability you know Steady Hand on the
tiller and what you saw in this budget
were no surprises I mean there wasn't a
rabbit and that does make me think now
that the child care policy was the
rabbit that leaked out of the hat jumped
out of the Hat uh thanks to the guardian
uh uh last night but no big rabbit but
the you know when I'm looking through
the scorecard this is basically where
the government costs the policies of tax
and spend what you see are basically two
big targeted policies here one is the
capital investment for companies nine
billion pounds a year of tax relief
effectively to encourage them to invest
growth budget and the second thing as
you were saying is child care that's the
policy worth 5.2 billion by 2027 to
eight what's it trying to do get parents
in to work what are they doing in the
round of it well they're building the
base for the next budget which will be
the pre-election fireworks if you like
if this one isn't the big band the sort
of pre-election fireworks show stocking
budget in which they then make a very
retail offer to the public but I think
if you put it in the round of people's
lives at the moment the obr just came
out saying that living standards are
expected to fall over six percent over
the next two years it's still the
largest two-year fall since the 1950s
marginally better from November but
that's reality of people's lives and and
as you said I think one of the big
rounds that might come from this budget
is that changes on the lifetime
allowances because basically people that
can afford to put over million quid into
their pensions they're a tiny proportion
of the population I think it's just
about seven thousand pensions uh go
above that level or are eligible for
that now they've abolished that lifetime
allowance they've also increased the
amount of tax-free money you can put
into your pension annually from forty
thousand to six a thousand it affects
kind of one percent of the population
but when you look at the scorecard it
basically by 27 to 28 is worth 1.1
billion pounds a year and I think the
way that Jeremy Hunt in the chamber
tried to frame that was this was about
NHS doctors and keeping them in the NHS
the way this might be received is at a
time when people are really struggling
you find a billion quid down the sofa uh
to to put into the wealthiest in society
so it's a tax break for the wealthy you
remember what happened last time in the
mini Mega budget when Liz trust tried to
give a tax break for people earning over
150 000 pounds a year trying to abolish
that 45 Pence rate it was only a two
billion pound policy but it did get
revised yeah I'm interested to know a
bit of the big picture economic
situation as well because we heard
Jeremy Hunt there to Big chairs from his
benches talking about the fact that
we're going to avoid a recession how
Rosy or otherwise are the figures I mean
it was really interesting wasn't it just
kind of actually the politics because
this was the first budget that we've
seen where the government wasn't kind of
embattled or you know creating a kind of
semi-final crisis uh in a while so that
was interesting let me just kind of talk
you through some of the numbers we're
just kind of getting them through at the
moment so so this is like our first take
based on some of the figures that we've
just heard about uh obviously from the
chancellor but also we get the updated
economic forecast for the office budget
responsibility that's really important
because that's giving us a sense of how
the economy is doing right now and the
big picture here is well it's a
relatively positive compared uh with
last time around I say compared with
last time around and also compared with
expectations but there are a few little
nuances that we'll get to in a second
These Bars just show you what was
expected last time and this is gross
domestic product it's the rate at which
the economy is growing the rate at which
we're all getting better off and
anything above the line obviously is
positive anything below the line is
negative look that one minus 1.4 that
was the recession that was forecast last
time around let's see how those numbers
change with the latest forecasts look
the red bars here that's the latest
forecasts okay this is the key thing to
look at to start off with because
obviously it was that question of
whether there was going to be a
recession well now the chancellor says
there isn't a technical recession what
does that mean in practice well a
technical recession is two successive
quarters where the economy is shrinking
in this case well look the economy is
basically down by 0.2 percent uh it's
not great by the scheme of things but
compared with last time around it's
certainly better better next year as
well but here's also something that's
interesting in the following years so
beyond the next election uh the forecast
is actually a little bit worse weaker
growth in those periods there how does
that impact public finances this is
really important because that determines
how much the chancellor potentially he
has to spend versus his forecast and
versus his rules this is showing you
public sets and net borrowing that's as
a percent of GDP these were the numbers
that we jotted down during the actual
speech itself and as you can see again a
bit less borrowing each of these years
so he's borrowing a little bit less why
is that in large part it's because the
economy is doing better and when the
economy does better that means more in
the way of tax revenues coming in which
means that he doesn't necessarily uh
suffer as a result of that he actually
brings in cash and doesn't have to
borrow as much as a result but now let's
get on to the actual policies that were
announced today now this is very big
picture ultimate big pitch there's
something called the scorecard which
kind of tots up all of the different
policies and gives a sense of whether
that's money coming out of the exchequer
that's in negative terms or coming into
the executive tax Rises and this is
giveaways it is largely giveaways but
here's again something striking and
we're totting things up here so within
that chunk there you've got the full
expensing expenses a big deal there for
many businesses around the country
that's going to cost kind of getting
towards 10 billion pounds a year by
2024-25 but you've also got other things
as well you've got Child Care you've got
those pensions uh plans as well the
changes to the pension plans well
they're mostly often the uh off towards
the future full expensing the big thing
in the short run but also note the shape
of These Bars again for the next few
years you've got big giveaways coming up
to 20 25 26 and then they diminish and
that's largely because that expensing is
a temporary thing it's a really big deal
but it's currently a temporary thing and
it's not necessarily going to be in the
future and of course this is after the
election so you've got big question
marks of what's about what's going to
happen after the election or any of
those things going to be renewed in the
next Manifesto but we'll bring you more
detail on how that you know the makeup
of those bars in a second just one other
thing to knows I do have hundreds of
other charts but I'm going to try and
keep it relatively short this time
around real household disposable income
you know this this is perhaps the
ultimate way of getting a sense of that
kind of pound in your pocket impact of
what been going through recently
anything above the bar shows we're
getting better off after you adjust for
inflation after you adjust for income
after you just for all of those
different things and this is last time
around look look at this right hand side
those two bars are the lowest that they
have ever been okay last time around
okay the red bars there now look at the
red bars again and we're going to bring
on these latest updated numbers so
improved numbers look at the red bars
the fall is a little bit less isn't it
just over here I'll go back just so you
can see last time pretty bad this time
still pretty bad but not necessarily
quite as bad and actually that's still
the worst two years in modern record so
going back you can see it here there
have never been another two years going
back to the 1950s where we've had as big
a squeeze on our personal disposable
incomes as we are going through in the
next couple of years so still very tough
for many households around the country
but that's the interesting thing about
this budget was these numbers are now
finally starting to get better rather
than getting worse of course questions
remain as to whether that's politically
enough for the conservative party and as
I say you saw the numbers there in the
charts there when it came to the
scorecard when it came to growth when it
comes to public finances you know big
questions about how much of the pain is
going to be felt after the next election
and therefore raising the question about
what comes in a Manifesto fascinating
lots more charts from ad to come you
might notice somebody else sitting
around at our table magically appearing
now that is James Cartledge who is the
exchequer Secretary of the Treasury
thank you very much for being on the
program I just want to pick up directly
from what Ed was just saying yes some of
the figures have improved but the obr is
still focus by casting the two worst the
worst Fallen living standards on record
still I mean things are pretty big stuff
well as you know the key factor there is
the surge in inflation
um this started in 2022 we had the
invasion of Ukraine and as you know
energy bills went through the went
through the sky
um and that had a mass that's had a
massive impact on people's disposable
income
um the overming impact has been from
rising energy costs um in the last year
as a country we've had to find about an
extra 150 billion as a country to pay
for Rising energy costs as good with
another NHS but I think the roots I
think the first really good news is that
over this year the obr is producing
inflation to more than half and actually
that is the key to getting the economy
growing because until inflation Falls
you know you don't get confidence among
consumers business investing and so on
so I think that's really important but
in addition to that because of the
budget today we put in place those key
measures to to get businesses investing
and growing again you paint a picture
that is still quite gloomy still
challenges as I think that you would
accept as well with that in mind how is
it acceptable that one of the biggest
giveaways in the budget is to some of
the very wealthiest people who can
afford pensions of more than one million
pounds when you say what some of the
wealthiest people as I think you are
saying yourselves and as the chancellor
said in his speech we're talking about
consultants in our hospitals
we want to talk about but that's it's
not targeted it includes Hospital
workers it includes consultants in
hospitals it does include senior
managers in our companies these are the
people who we need in our economy if
it's to grow
um but if you if you take the example of
senior clinicians in the NHS and I do
think that's the most important one the
point is that is a benefit to the whole
country because all of us want to know
that if we have to go to hospital or if
we have you know a relative who is
waiting for care that they have
consultants in place who can you know
perform those operations instead of
leaving the NHS because of a tax change
so I think it's really positive you
mentioned there the pressure on public
services still something that many
people will be very very acutely aware
of and I have to say just look looking
at what the chancellor was addressing
there was nothing on public sector pay
there was nothing on public sector
spending given the state of the NHS
schools back loss in court is that the
right priority well it's the budget is
primarily about tax tax measures but
there were some significant spending
decisions obviously an incredibly
important one included in your so-called
giveaways 11 billion extra for defense
over over the next five years that
includes replenishing our Munitions
because we've given so much to Ukraine
to help them defend their freedom
um so it include some very important
spending decisions it also includes
spending on child care most of that is
would be classes spending rather than
tax cuts and I think again a really
important Intervention which will help
more people get into work and ease those
heavy costs at the time of you know
challenging inflationary pressures
on the pension point
and when we saw
household incomes are really squeezed
you've just given a giveaway to the
richest 10 000 people who can have these
pension ports of it's 835 million pounds
a year by 2020 seven to eight can you
see how that looks to the public I mean
I don't agree for the reasons I said
about the NHS but so just forgive me I
think you mean the highest earners
honestly in terms of overall wealth of
property Etc and those people have high
earners they work incredibly hard you're
talking about as I said NHS Consultants
you're talking about senior managers in
our big employers we need those people I
mean just to give you uh the local style
so I represent the constituency South
Suffolk I've had a number of people
coming to my surgeries who are in that
very position who are thinking about
leaving the workforce because of this
very problem and you know those people
now have a massive incentive to stay in
employment we need that for our economy
to grow and deliver the revenues which
is in all our interests to fund schools
hospitals Etc we need these people
working and that's why I think it's a
really positive measure and it will you
know be a benefit to Public Services out
of the whole country so you're not
worried about any sort of backlash on
that measure you did you think about it
when you were discussing what you would
do in terms of the budget well I think
if you look at the big picture first of
all this is the first year where you can
earn a thousand pounds a month without
paying any income tax on National
Insurance so we've put in place huge
help for those on Lower incomes you know
as you as you will be aware at this
moment we are still providing very
generous support with energy bills
including 900 pounds of those on
benefits with increased benefits in line
with inflation you know and so I think
we have taken steps to support those on
the lowest incomes we've taken some
difficult decisions on tax but supported
those on the lowest incomes this
specific decision is very clearly about
growth it's about getting the people in
place who can run our businesses run our
Hospital Awards we need those people in
our economy working rather than leaving
the labor force I think that the biggest
policy decision of all I think was full
expensing so it's improving investment
incentives businesses a lot of
businesses will be delighted to have
seen that they've been calling it for it
for a long time
but here's the question why only do that
for three years it's kind of odd you
know you want stability as a business
you want to know that you're going to be
able to invest in the long run and you
know the promise from the government is
always stability but this seems like you
know adding a little extra bit of
instability great that you've done it
but why the expert it's a very it's a
very fair question Chancellor I think
did answer this he said when the public
finances allow his desire to make this
permanent
um you know we three years is
significant and and your right
businesses wanted to see this they know
that they can fully expense investment
in all those key things that let us grow
at a stronger rate but I just make one
important point on those brilliant
charts you were showing about growth if
you look at what the obr said a key
component the biggest they've had before
in a photo they've had so far in a
forecast is on what's called supply side
reform now I know it's a technical
phrase it basically means that growth is
coming not from you know just
stimulating more spending Etc by the
public it's coming from stimulating
strengthening the economy in the long
term which is what investment by
business does but and it's in it's
nearly there but the issue is that by
just making it temporary potentially
you're just encouraging businesses to
bring forward investment it's not about
actual supply side Improvement it's
about some would say cynically you know
pumping up the economy ahead of 2025 and
we all know what's happening on the
total contrary to being cynical this is
because we also have a duty to balance
the books and there's this very positive
narrative in fact you showed another of
your charts where debt is now falling
well the UK's National mortgages the
overall so the deficit is the overdraft
if you like debt as you know is the
country's mortgage balances it were that
is now going to fall I think that's
really positive and what it shows is
look the public finances have been have
taken a pummeling from a pandemic
followed by a war but actually now debt
is falling inflation is going to more
than half this year and the economy is
going to be growing again and so I think
it's a really good opportunity to have a
strong pro-growth budget which supports
business and helps people into work kind
of squeeze at one question in
um how irritated were you in the
treasury that it feels like the big
rabbit and your hat got leaked out it
felt like there was nothing new in the
budget at all
if I can be completely Frank there was
something new in the budget which is in
Simon excheck is actually responsible
for alcohol Duty that wasn't the fortune
that we are as you know increasing the
difference
it's a big deal for hospitalities on the
biggest employees in this country I tell
you it's a big deal for them that we're
still freezing uh the duty on a pint of
beer in a pub and we're backing pubs
which is a Great British institution be
right who knows where it came from the
fact is wherever it came from it's a
fantastic news story about child care it
means that this country is going to
start growing again we're going to get
more people working working longer hours
um having more uh prospects better
opportunities I think that's a really
positive story to tell okay thank you
very much indeed thank you for coming on
the program
just want to show you a few pictures
from today because while the chancellor
was delivering his budget inside
Westminster the streets outside were
filled with tens of thousands of
striking workers who were marching
through Central London more than 400 000
workers across a range of sectors are
currently on strike in disputes overpay
it's thought to be the biggest day of
industrial action since the current wave
of unrest began last year and I'm sure
many of you are going to be impacted by
it today we can go live to the March and
talk to Skies Ashner what's going on
it is no coincidence that as the
chancellor was speaking there the
Streets of London were full of people
tens of thousands of people who have now
made their way to
wage remind me where they're currently
speaking to the thousands of people who
are here teachers Junior doctors and
among them are this group of teachers
here from Tower Hamlet so I'd like to
introduce you to among the people
standing out on the walls is Helen a
primary school teacher talked to me
about the last couple of years has been
like what difference have you noticed in
your profession
um over the last few years I've noticed
that resources have been slashed and
teachers are leaving the profession
because they can't afford to make ends
meet even though the scrb which is an
independent review body have recommended
pay Rises to teachers for the last 10
years on and off none of them have been
given so in real terms that's been a pay
cut for the last 10 years and people are
really really struggling to make ends
meet London is probably fair to say is
better off than other boroughs around
the country so if we're struggling then
everyone else is absolutely on their
knees so today we're here to say that
every child in every home is absolutely
entitled to an equal education by people
who are respected for the jobs they do
Helen thank you very much and your
science has fully fund our schools a
message
yeah we would like the funding to go to
schools to make the pay Rises for staff
thank you so much Helen I appreciate
your time Helen here joined by her
colleagues here from Tower Hamlet as I
mentioned there are thousands of people
of lining uh Trafalgar Square and it's
very deep people strength of feeling you
can really feel it Sophie every now and
again you'll hear that Rush from the
crowds and that really big swathe of
support but a real sea of solidarity
here not just from teachers but for
junior doctors for train drivers here in
London and the signal is from the
government that this could have been
avoided Jillian Keegan wrote to these
teachers yesterday saying this could
have been avoided but if negotiations
don't happen there is likely to be an
escalation and more strike days just
like this do the same thank you very
much Ashner Ashner there reporting from
the biggest day of strike action thank
you
now I'm delighted to say we're joined by
the director of The Institute for fiscal
studies Paul Johnson for his reaction to
the Chancellor's uh budget thanks very
much for being on the program we'll talk
Lots about the numbers I'm sure Ed will
have a bit to say about that as well and
but I was very struck by one of your
tweets uh today uh where you say note
what the chancellor didn't mention
nothing on public sector pay no
mitigation of big income tax Rises
coming in this April no more money for
public services post 2024 still some
pain on the way yeah it's I mean you've
just shown the um the pictures of
teachers striking and uh the biggest
challenge facing the government and the
arguably the country over the next year
is this public sector problems with
nurses teachers doctors and a whole
group of others who are been getting
really big pay cuts last year and this
year government said they've only got
three and a half percent to give in the
coming year when inflation will average
more than that teachers experienced
teachers maybe 15 down on where they
were in 2010 but no mention of any
additional money me to help sort those
strikes out and no additional money post
2024 penciled in for public services
generally now public servers have
actually got quite a lot of money over
this Parliament it is true that
austerity is way behind us in that sense
but the next Parliament if those numbers
are kept to will look really tough we
just heard from James Carter she said
look this is about tax really it's not
that's something not for a budget is
that fair well not really because the
chancellor said he's sticking to his
fiscal targets
um he's only just by his breath meaning
well it's not a particularly sensible
fiscal time actually which is to get
debt falling in a particular year in the
future and he's only doing that because
he's making things up he's kind of
pretending that fuel duties will go
through the roof next year well they're
not going to he's sort of pretending
that I hope he's pretending that this um
corporate tax relief will be temporary I
mean he said he wants it to be permanent
it should be uh permanently I think he's
pretending uh that public spending will
be really really tight over the next few
few years so I don't think it's fair to
say that you know if you're putting
something so much stall by fiscal
responsibility you have to take
seriously uh what the chancellor says
about what he's intending on spending is
that right by the way what the minister
was saying that if if they had kept it
permanent that it would have broken
their rules the like an extra 9 billion
would probably would have done yes right
but as you say the rules are their own
destruction and indeed and I I don't
think I mean look I mean
we I mean I take rules of serious fiscal
rules probably more seriously than the
99.9 of the population but I don't think
we'd be throwing our hands up in horror
If instead of meeting them by 5 billion
they were missing them by 5 billion uh
because of uh a change they were a
permanent change on the corporation tax
thing and the problem with doing that
corporation tax change as they've done
first this should have been announced at
the same time as the corporation tax
rate was increased announced two years
ago it's not sensible policy making to
change it two weeks before the fiscal
year begins and second having made the
change it should be a permanent change
because actually structurally it's a
sensible thing to do if it's permanent
it's not such a sensible thing to do
just temporarily and Paul it seems like
it was a very targeted budget if you
like there were no big bangs in it no
massive surprises do you see it as a
Chancellor pursuing a study as she goes
approach now for a pre-election Splurge
next year how did you see it stacking up
politically you like well I mean there
were two big things in it the corporate
tax thing we talked about the child care
thing no doubt you you've covered that
actually a doubling in the amount of
public spending on child care and and
really I think moving to the end of a 20
25 year gradual change to the shape of
the welfare state it's quite a big thing
it's hard to see where there's space for
a Splurge next year given that uh you
know as I said you're barely meeting his
own fiscal rule as it is
um and growth while a little bit better
than expected isn't looking fantastic so
is he really going to have lots of money
to give away pre-election next year hard
to see I'm sure he'll find something I'm
sure he'll find some way of doing it but
I think I think this was quite a it was
a technical budget I think it was
genuinely making some changes which will
help the childcare corporation tax I'm
not so sure about the pensions tax
changes
um but it was and actually changes
disability benefits these are technical
but important and broadly speaking I
think sensible changes just to jump in
what why are you not so sure about the
pension and tax contributions well I
mean several reasons I mean one
Chancellor talked about it as being a
response to problems with doctors in the
NHS well if that was the target you
should have changed the NHS pension
scheme it didn't you don't need to
change the entire tax system to do it
secondly it will of course also allow
people to save more in their pension so
while some people may stay and work a
little bit longer because they can save
more some people might actually retire a
little bit earlier because they have
saved more because they've been able to
and actually
um the people who uh who might really be
affected by this he's kept a very sharp
taper in which means if you're on above
about 200 000 pounds a year then you
lose everything that he gave very very
quickly so it's it's going to benefit a
very particular group of people on on
high earnings but not the super high
earners and could even have the opposite
effects for some others well it could
have the opposite effect for exactly
that reason so so growth was one of the
big things and kind of underlying a lot
of the Improvement in the numbers the
the fiscal numbers the economy looks a
bit better than it did last time around
and so that that matters but there was a
dispatch maybe we can show that show the
chart there is kind of a disparatory
between what the obr thinks it's going
to happen to growth and what uh the bank
of England for instance thinks
um let's see if we can bring this chart
up here because it kind of shows it
um and it includes basic looking uh at
what the growth profile was before
um the pandemic so it was kind of a line
basically going up you can see that
there and then where it was afterwards
but the interesting thing is so that's
the latest numbers and they're obviously
kind of they're better than they looked
last time around better than November
but then you bring the bank of England
numbers on and they're pretty they're
pretty depressing by comparison so are
we at one of these moments Paul where
actually a lot just depends on whether
the obr's got its sums right and it
could well be that everything looks you
know a bit a fair amount more Grim I
mean which of these numbers I know
you're kind of a fiscal forecast but
which of these numbers are you more kind
of convinced by when you look at them
now well the obr is closer to what most
other forecasters are saying the bank of
England is really quite pessimistic I
mean the chancellor must be thanking his
lucky stars he's got the obr giving him
his forecast
when the bank is is really pessimistic
about the capacity of the economy to
grow
um over this period
um and the obr is is more reasonable
actually what they're talking about is
an average of two percent growth over
the subsequent few years which isn't too
bad at all I mean all I say is I just
hope the obr are right because if the
bank's wrong right then we really are in
trouble but it's it's a very strange
thing isn't it we've got monetary policy
being based on one set of forecasts and
fiscal policy being based on the
entirely different set of forecasts but
it's just a bit better I mean so no no
recession that's that's something that
you know that's one of the big stories
out of today I know it's an arbitrary
thing but nonetheless it suggests the
economy is better than it was but just
still pretty grim and the next few
months aren't necessarily going to be
especially the feel good Factor isn't
necessarily going to be who knows the
households to feel good factors not here
at all and I mean what they what we what
they worry about is what their incomes
what household incomes are doing and as
the you know the obr says we might not
be going into a recession but incomes
are still sharply down last year and
this year so not down by the full seven
percent they thought in November but
still down by five percent or so still
the sharpest fall in household incomes
in in certainly in living memory and
that's partly because of course of uh
inflation and earnings not going up with
prices but it's also significantly
because there's this great big tax rise
coming in uh next month which is the you
know fact that income tax allowances and
thresholds are not going up in line with
inflation that'll leave the average
basic rate taxpayer about 500 pounds
worse off the average higher rate
taxpayer about a thousand pounds worse
off that's actually a quite a big
contributory factor to this living
standard squeeze so it's actually it is
it's partly created by the government
despite what the minister was saying a
moment ago yeah it's interesting as well
who is like to ask this question because
it's something the government will start
you an interview it's always wonder what
the sort of actual the advice that
someone like you would be
Jeremy Hunt says this is all about
proving the doubt is wrong it's all
about you know showing that the
government policy is starting to bear
fruit when it comes to the economy how
much of this gradual Improvement is due
to the government or how much of it is
due to external factors that they have
nothing to do with well
um it depends on what your Baseline is I
mean clearly um things are doing better
than the team have the sort of mini
budget measures not been Unwound over
this year
um though this is really all about the
energy prices coming down and the
economy doing a little bit better for
other reasons though if you do look at
the um the obr numbers they do think
that a little bit of the growth at the
end and you never get more than a little
bit from what you're doing one budget is
down to this budget getting more uh
people into work in particular so I
don't think we should sort of sniff at
the fact that there's been there's quite
a lot of I think quite sensible policies
in here which over the long run will
bear some fruit
um is scoring some of that as improving
the size of the economy into the medium
term and it's really worth stressing
that getting these things right getting
corporation tax right getting child care
right getting the disability benefit
system right getting the pension taxes
right each one of them adds up into a
system which if it's just a little bit
more right does allow the economy to
grow a bit more in the future but the
issue is Paul isn't it that this is a
prime minister who has 18 months
effectively before he calls a general
election and if he can't get the economy
right and get people feeling like their
lives are getting better under this
particular Administration he's at risk
clearly of losing an election do you
think he can somehow turn it around or
really the the sort of quite anemic
growth figures the constraints on public
finances just too big a tide for him to
turn I think a lot of it will depend on
how it feels in a year to 18 months time
as I said I think this year through to
the early summer is going gonna look
quite difficult I think the economy will
begin to grow according to these
forecasts the end middle of this year
end of the year real incomes should
start to be moving in the right
direction in a year's time and you know
there will be an opportunity to you know
Chuck a little bit more money at some
people in the Autumn statement in the
budget next year so it depends to some
extent whether people think well we're
now on the right path we're at least
moving in the right direction even if
from a sort of rather low point or
whether they're thinking well or still
actually worse off than we were three or
four years ago so we don't feel very
good about that but I mean the truth is
that you know come next summer summer
2024 how something else probably will
still be below where they were pre um
pre-pandemic and people aren't going to
be feeling very happy about that but
they may just about be moving in the
right direction by then thanks very much
always really useful to have you here
with your analysis on these days so we
appreciate it thank you
well let's get the view now from our
household Finance expert Greg Marsh
shall we um Greg's been looking at how
the budget measures actually impact
normal families
indeed so much for the big picture what
does all this mean for households well
some of it was not a surprise as
expected the energy price guarantee will
not be increasing it was going to have
gone up to 3 000 pounds it is from the
state 2500 and as most analysts now
predict it's going to fall energy price
is going to fall towards the end of the
year households are probably going to
see energy bills come down a bit that's
good news uh similarly
um we've also potentially got good news
from the fuel tax freeze so had those
fuel tax prices gone up fuel Duty would
have meant a significant increase for
some households especially those who
drive more fuel taxes will not be going
up that's a continuation of the existing
freeze
also good news for those households who
depend on Universal Credit as well as
disability allowance Universal Credit
increasing roughly in line with
inflation given how high inflation is
those increases in pound terms could be
quite significant for households who
depend on Universal Credit likewise
disability support or personal
Independence payments and the winter
fuel payments so all of those three
Rising as expected and as hoped in line
with inflation as a result of today's
announcement now what does this mean for
real households well we've been
crunching the numbers and the team at
NAS has been looking at some of the
households we've been spending time with
Linda remember the retired nurse who we
met earlier on in the day she is on
pension and disability support her
husband works she doesn't
her household has benefited from that
freeze in the energy price cap her
household will also benefit over the
next 12 months quite significantly from
the inflationary increase in the
personal Independence payments that's a
disability support payments and the
freezing fuel Duty also good news for
Linda's household
less good news for Linda's household
because her husband works is this
negative balance as a result of those
frozen income tax thresholds this Effect
called fiscal drag it sounds very
obscure it's a kind of stealth tax let's
come back to that in a moment but taken
as a whole Linda's household we guess is
about 350 pounds a year better off as a
result of the Chancellor's announcements
today let's understand that physical
drag effect in more detail well
for an average UK income earning
household what we can see is although
the rates of tax increases is relatively
modest over time those effects add up to
quite significant sums of money for
higher income earners here we go look
for a typical UK household earning
little less uh there is nevertheless an
effect as a result of the freezing and
tax thresholds but because tax
thresholds are Frozen as incomes rise
and earnings increase about seven
percent this year for higher rate income
taxpayers the effect in pound terms can
be quite significant more than 500
pounds a year and for households earning
much larger amounts a hundred thousand
or more even more significant sums
earlier on the day we met Mike who is a
more comfortable uh a householder an I.T
consultant owns his own home Mike's
household again benefits by our analysis
quite significantly from those energy
price cap freezes It's a larger home so
the benefit is larger Mike and his
household also benefit from the freezing
fuel tax but
look at the effects of fiscal drag that
freezing in the income tax thresholds
for a household like Mike so what Mike
is going to see is a lot of squeeze in
his pocket as a result has his income
rises even only modestly and probably
less than the rate of inflation income
tax are frozen which thresholds are
frozen which means that as an overall
effect Mike's households probably worse
off as a result of today's budget so
Linda's household better off Mike's
household worse off be very interesting
to know what Linda and Mike make of
today's announcement and I'm hoping we
can go live to Sam in Burnley who's
talking to Linda and Mike in person
yes thank you very much Greg as you were
saying we are here in Burnley in
Lancashire some 20 miles north of sorry
20 miles north of Manchester I'd like to
be able to tell you that people here
have been digesting all of those
announcements from the chancellor of
what it means for their pockets but to
be honest where we are today people have
just been coming in to keep warm and to
get a hot meal but there has been a lot
in it that could be potentially relevant
for them one thing that did stand out to
me they're listening to it we've got a
lot of mentions of cities towns regions
there was nothing specific for Burnley
and don't forget we came here because
Burnley has the highest inflation rate
in all of Great Britain last measured at
11.9 that's more than two percent higher
than it is in Cambridge which is the
lowest inflation rate so plenty plenty
for people to be thinking about here but
people generally that I've been talking
to just feel disaffected from what's
been going on in Investments to feel
like their needs have not been reflected
well Greg has been crunching the numbers
there and as it applies to both Linda
and Mike and I'm just going to have a
catch up with them and to see what they
made of the budget and whether they
agree indeed with their Greg's
assessment and Linda to you first and
Greg was saying there that your
household will actually be better off
but that wasn't your read a bit was it
when you were listening to it because
you're going to lose the the energy bill
support and that's the thing that was
really affecting your budget most energy
bills
I mean another the cat stop the cat from
going up which is good but then they're
taking it out in the other end with the
support
and it just support grants so I can't
see how I'm going to be better off at
all I have to say your mood has been
quite quite zombies
how you're going to pay it and Mike and
Greg was saying that your household
unfortunately at worse off and that's
more to do with those income tax
thresholds yeah I'm not really surprised
about that um as you say um I came in
looking at the budget to think how it
might help Ordinary People in Burnley
rather than like me slightly better off
and there was very little mention of it
one phrase I was listening out for and
didn't okay I was leveling up I've been
up since yeah
yeah
the
um
funds might be useful for the region for
The Wider region because Blackburn I did
notice is in the the list some of the
red wall areas but Burnley seemed to
miss out on that you're in the I.T
business a lot of mention and provision
in there for Britain as as a technology
Hub will any of that do you think
Kickstart growth in your sector I I can
only hope so I mean the corporation tax
uh height to 25 is still kick in as far
as I can tell we expected that didn't we
yes um it was it was um pre-announced I
suppose that it would be coming in that
capital expenditure offset might be
useful for the businesses that I'm in uh
where where we have a lot of expenditure
on Capital Equipment computers
um but only three years yes so that
doesn't help with business investment
certainty does it not going forward no
there seems to be a lot of money that's
been brought in uh ahead of the next
election let's say let's put it that way
okay all right
um again I was I was looking at uh I
think the childcare incentives was going
to be useful for organ working people in
Burnley the breakfast and after schools
Club extensions don't start until 2026
as far as I can tell which is not really
I want to bring Linda back in on that
because she is involved in child care in
her family but so the macro picture for
you is that fiscal drag means that your
income will be lower I'll be alone than
it is before but potentially a boost for
the economy in the sector that you work
in hopefully you've got to you've got to
have some faith in that and Linda the
big announcements from the chancellor
around child care don't really touch the
sides for you because you're in unpaid
carer anyway for your grandson will they
help your son and your daughter-in-law
um
I really like
um and I mean
like I do a lot of the child care to
enable my son and daughter to go to work
and go to you now and study and get a
better job it only covers for 30 hours
which means I look after him two days a
week which is the situation for a lot of
families
and like they're saying they want the
um I'm retired NHS retirement well just
to go back to work which I can't see
happening okay so that's not really
going to help you but what you just
mentioned there is also a key plank of
Jeremy Hunt's budget which is he wants
people particularly NHS workers to go
back to work it's not going to affect
your disability payments are you going
to go back are you incentivized by that
no why not so well I would say it for a
reason because I've got several health
issues okay I'd absolutely love to go
back to work and I added to actually try
to go back to work okay
um and especially with all the other
pressures that the NHS is under and with
the Striking and so you know it might
have had good intentions but it's not
going to get Linda back into the
workforce so we're still going to be
digesting with our panel here exactly at
what it means for them as we go through
the day and we look more closely at the
detail we also of course want to hear
your thoughts on the budget what did you
think of the chancellors announcements
is it going to help you with the cost of
living crisis or was there an issue that
you think he missed out certainly Linda
thinks that there are there are more
than one issue that was left out for her
call us now on 0208
167-2200 to be part of a special phone
in program to have your say and you can
also ask our experts any questions at
the you might have about your situation
you can watch the budget you will say
that's at 7 pm this evening right here
on Sky News back over to you Sophie
thanks very much Sam lots more from Sam
in Burley Burnley as the afternoon wears
on and it really does feel doesn't it
that one of the biggest policies in the
budget today if not the biggest whether
in terms of impacting people's lives or
in terms of the impacting the economy
was the child care enhancement so we're
now joined by Neil lights who is the
chief executive at the early years
Alliance thanks so much for being with
us what did you make of the announcement
then I think on the surface it looked
quite attractive particularly to parents
but the reality is I have to say the
investment is just a fraction of what's
needed government's own uh statistics
show that for the three and four year
old offer which gets a couple of hundred
million it's actually 1.5 billion in
terms of shortfall so expanding A system
that is already very vulnerable is I
have to say not a great place to be but
the devil's in the detail you're
basically saying then that they're not
putting enough money in to fund these
places so the actual nurseries
themselves the child minders have to
make up that money themselves which puts
them in risk and they do that frankly
dare I say from those parents that don't
qualify for these free entitlements so
historically it's been the one-year-olds
and some of the two-year-olds Etc now if
even if Government adequately funds one
and two-year-olds what happens to the
funding for the three and four-year-olds
that's what's been sending this sector
into a crisis that's why we've lost
record numbers in the last 12 months
we've lost something like five and a
half thousand providers from the sector
in the last 12 months alone it's
interesting because you know I was
talking to Beth about this before um my
WhatsApp groups because of you know the
age I am have just been lighting up
about this policy everyone that I know
seems to be you know either really happy
about it or really gutted because
they've got a child who's three and they
just missed out on it
um but people I feel it would be really
shocked to find out how much people are
actually paying on child care if you've
got two kids
could be sixty seventy thousand pounds
right where is that money going well the
reality is we just don't invest I mean
the sad thing is we have some of the
highest child care and education costs
for young children in the world in fact
one of the oec tables that we top is the
percentage of a woman's salary woman's
salary that's spent on early years care
and education but if you look at the
amount of investment that we've put in
that's at the bottom end of the sector
and this is quite important but back in
December of 2018 when we were tired of
hearing dare I say from government we
invest enough money into these systems
we said well if you think you pay enough
money into these systems shows your
figures it took us two and a half years
later battle after battle for the
information commissioner's office to
rule and say show the figures and you
can you I'm sure you can assume why that
was the case well I'll tell you why it
was the case their words not mine to
adequately fund these entitlements would
require an additional two billion pounds
so an offer of 200 to 204 million you
can see it it's 10 percent of what
government said was a shortfall they
predicted that they would have to pay a
rate for three and four-year-olds per
hour by 2021 of seven pound Forty Nine
they paid four pound eighty nine so
that's why we have a sector on its knees
and that's why really frankly
they should have done this a long time
ago it's interesting that it seems to
have come to the fore when frankly
parents are on their knees providers are
on their knees
it's a political position rather than
frankly looking at what was right for
our country
um quality of child care matters an
awful lot as well right um and do you
think that there is a risk that the
quality of the child care is going to be
squeezed if there is are these funding
pressures we've been talking about the
ratios as well
I have to say one of the most appalling
things in all of this was the chancellor
saying that he was going to change the
adult child ratios
talked about Consulting talked about
engaging
who with parents don't want it
providers don't want to this is an
economic decision to give more children
to an educator
to try and balance the books we have
Educators leaving this sector in droves
we have a recruitment and retention
crisis that we've never witnessed before
because they're under pressure they care
for children they educate children and
what do we do after a pandemic when
children's needs frankly are greatest
what do we do we say give them more
children to look after we don't just
look after them we educate them so I
think it is an appalling position and I
hope parents remember that so it's just
not it's not just about economics and
children aren't Commodities we're
talking about the lives of children
really important stuff thank you very
much indeed for being on the program
today thank you
well it's been a I guess the sort of
Steady As She Goes at her budget a few
uh rabbits certainly on Child Care on
pension allowances and also of course on
expensing for companies as well but
perhaps not the kind of Big Bangs that
some might have been anticipating
perhaps as Beth was saying saving that
for an election yeah let's bring in Beth
and Edge how we fought a bit more uh
reaction add a very more chance we'd
like to kind of squeeze in for us so
you've been talking a lot about interest
rates haven't you yeah no interest rates
is a really interesting one because
obviously this is not something that the
chancellor uh kind of can really
influence directly and remember last
time around last uh what was it called
the last one whatever the the the
awesome statement I think it was in the
end uh and then the mini budget they
interest rates were the big kind of
Specter at the feast there because that
was they were going up as a result of
what the government was doing have a
look at this actually let me let me kind
of show you the chart here because
while we've been sitting here actually
things have been changing quite a lot in
kind of financial markets and when you
look at interest rates uh and the impact
they're having it's having on them it's
kind of a big deal that the back story
here is it's a bit different to last
time around so you remember let's just
kind of go back a little bit last August
okay this is where markets expected
interest rates and we're talking just
about the bank of England interest rate
to go not that high then we'll you know
won't be able to forget that you had the
mini budget everyone got very worried
that pushed up the expectations these
are just expectations looking out into
the future for interest rates up to kind
of six and a half percent actually kind
of towards 6.75 that's the backstory and
of course that was due to what was
happening in the UK a lot of concern
about uh the mini budget and what it was
going to do then it kind of dropped down
and as of last week the expectation
actually interest rates are already at
four percent and the expectation was
you're gonna have another three small
increases up to 4.75 percent
but we all know what's happened since
last week we've had Financial turmoil in
the US and then in the UK as well due to
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank and
another few banks in the U.S right now
as we speak people getting very worried
about Credit Suisse another bank far
bigger than Silicon Valley Bank if that
had big problems then we would all know
about it uh in a big way that's in
Switzerland right now it's kind of all
over the place and as a result of that
look at this red line and I'll just show
you what's happened now so where are we
now
look at that line so that in the space
of a few days it's gone down from people
expecting good interest rates in this
country to get up to 4.75 now they're
peaking called it's the latest numbers
we've seen just it was about about kind
of you know a few hours ago uh about an
hour ago 4.1 percent that's a massive
difference and it kind of implies that
maybe the bank of England which was
expected to raise interest rates as soon
as next week they might not do that at
all and actually they might be cutting
interest rates towards the end of the
year look at the right hand side it's
kind of coming down interest rates could
be down below four percent at the end of
the year if those expectations uh turn
out to be right now they are just
expectations but this kind of stuff
matters just as much some would say even
more than some of the stuff we've been
hearing about from the chancellor
because this feeds into many households
bills I mean you will know if you have a
mortgage just how much particularly if
you've had to refix it just how much of
a difference this makes well that is the
lowest that line has been for a very
long time I should say it's not
necessarily for good reasons it's partly
because people are so worried about
what's happening in the financial system
but even so that's a big deal it wasn't
covered obviously by the chancellor but
you know talking about the background to
this to this budget this stuff really
matters and and you know we heard just a
moment ago from the minister we saw the
numbers on what the impact for cost of
living is going to be you know that that
um shot I showed you a moment ago
showing the squeeze on household
disposable income being the worst that
it's been ever basically well it's still
as bad as it was Paul Johnson telling us
that's partly down to taxes so it is
down to the government it's down to
inflation yes but it's also down to
taxes as well and those tax that squeeze
is going to come so a little bit of
relief at least the interest rates might
not go quite so high how about the
politics Beth because we look at this
through an economic lens but also a
political lens as well is there anything
that you can see becoming a story yeah
there's a there's a couple of things I
mean it was interesting what Paul was
saying about it being a technical budget
because a sensible budget and at the top
of the presentation the Jeremy Hunt
message was we're proving the doubt is
wrong we have a plan we're sticking to
the plan what's the message and that's
all about sound management of the
economy after the lids trust debacle 0.1
so the conservative party the
conservative government trying to
convince the public that they can be
trusted the thing I think about all of
this though is that things could blow up
a bit a couple of things the fiscal drag
but also the pension a big bung to the
wealthiest earners at the cost of other
people potentially I think you're right
there Beth lots more analysis from Beth
coming up Anna too shortly
it's three o'clock there's this guy News
live from Westminster on the day the
chancellor presented his vision for the
country's financial future well all
afternoon we're going to be assessing
the budget announcements with our Deputy
political editor Sam coat standing in
for our political to Beth Rigby and also
our economics and data editor Ed Conway
as well well Jeremy Hunt has unveiled
what he described as his budget for
growth as the fiscal Watchdog predicted
inflation will fall to 2.9 by the end of
the year
the international monetary fund says our
approach means the UK economy is on the
right track
today's budget changes nothing again we
see a failure to grip for long-term
challenges no determination to create
growth which unlocks the potential of
the many working people being made to
pay for Tory choices and Tory mistakes
[Music]
the chancellor announces 30 hours a week
of free child care for every child in
England aged between nine months and
five years
on energy and end the prepayment penalty
for the poorest and average bills will
stay at 2 500 pounds for three more
months
corporation tax will arise but
businesses will be able to deduct
expenses from taxable profits
fuel Duty will remain Frozen at five
pence a liter saving motorists 100
pounds next year
finding out how those measures have gone
down here in Burnley it is the town with
the highest inflation rate in the
country including what they think of the
lifetime pension allowance being dropped
to entice older people back to work but
no new pay deals as hundreds of
thousands of teachers Junior doctors
tube workers and civil servants all go
on strike
foreign
good afternoon live from Westminster in
his first budget as Chancellor Jeremy
Hunt said the UK is proving the doubt is
wrong as he vowed the country is set to
avoid a technical recession this year
we'll take him to his feet in the
Commons he painted a picture of falling
inflation with announcements on Child
Care fuel Duty pensions and more
well there is a lot as always with
budgets to analyze and we're going to be
looking through all of the details you
can see them tapping away uh on either
side of me you were joined by Sky's
Deputy political editor Sam coats and
Sky's economics and data editor Ed
Conway to try and decipher what the
measures will mean for you but first we
can just take you through some of those
key announcements that were made today
well the chancellor began his budget by
announcing that the UK is expected to
avoid a technical recession this year
now that's because of forecasts that say
inflation is set to fall from 10.7 down
to 2.9 by the end of 2023. the energy
price guarantee will now continue until
June with household bills remaining at 2
500 pounds and the chancellor has
promised 30 hours of free child care a
week to working parents in England with
children aged between nine months and
five years
Jeremy Hunt also announced what he
called full expensing now that's a nine
billion pound scheme which means every
pound a company invests in it equipment
and Machinery can be deducted from
taxable profits in an effort to boost
growth the government will also invest
80 million pounds over five years in 12
new UK investment zones and this is a
big one the lifetime allowance which is
a total amount that workers can
accumulate in their pension savings
before paying extra tax well that has
been entirely abolished
in addition the pensions annual tax-free
lands Will Rise by 50 percent
in the Autumn we took difficult
decisions to deliver stability and sound
money
since mid-october 10-year guilt rates
have fallen debt servicing costs are
down mortgage rates are lower and
inflation has peaked the international
monetary fund
says our approach means the UK economy
is on the right track
but we remain Vigilant and will not
hesitate to take whatever steps are
necessary for economic stability
today the office for Budget
responsibility forecasts that because of
changing International factors and the
measures I take the UK will not now
enter a technical recession this year
[Applause]
they forecast
they forecast we will meet the prime
minister's priorities to halve inflation
reduce debt and get the economy growing
well the chancellor also announced some
business investment support when he
stood up in the Commons today
I can announce we will introduce a new
policy of full capital expensing for the
next three years with an intention to
make it permanent as soon as we can
responsibly do so that means that every
single pound a company invests in it
equipment plant or Machinery can be
deducted in full and immediately from
taxable profits
it is a corporation tax cut worth an
average of nine billion pounds a year
for every year that it's in place
so nine billion pounds to try and help
offset some of that corporation tax rise
and there was help as well uh leaked
before in the guardian for families who
have children under the age of three the
chancellor confirmed extra Financial
Health as well for working parents who
may be struggling to pay for child care
so for any parents who are moving into
work or want to increase their hours we
will pay the child care costs up front
and we will increase the maximum they
can claim to 951 pounds for one child
and 1 630 pounds for two children an
increase of almost 50 percent
I turn now to parents of school-aged
children who often face barriers to
working because of the limited
availability of wrap-around care
one-third of primary schools do not
offer Child Care at both ends of the
school day even though for many people a
job requires it to be available before
and after school
to address this we'll fund schools and
local authorities to increase the supply
of wraparound care so all school-age
parents can drop their children off
between 8 AM and 6 p.m and our ambition
is that all schools will start to offer
a full wraparound offer either on their
own or in partnership with other schools
by September 2026
well we'll talk you through the main
points let's bring in Sam and Ed now for
their analysis and reaction Sam let's
start with you you're freshly with us
this hour what is your big takeaway
what's your big thought
well it was only six months ago Sophie
that we were sitting in this studio
looking at the potential collapse of the
British economy as the markets judged
that the government of the day then run
by Liz truss was going to borrow too
much and might not be able to pay back
its obligations and so we had a new
Chancellor Jeremy Hunt brought in to try
and get everything back under control
and here we are today six months on and
actually you've got that same individual
Jeremy Hunt spending quite a lot of
money in fact sending so much money that
he within a whisker of breaking his own
rules on how much he's going to spend in
fact once you you look at some of the
ways that we'll probably end up spending
more reducing fuel Duty in future he'll
probably break his rules in future so
he's spent a lot of money the uh the
kind of hair shirt tone of just six
months ago has gone out of the window so
let's look at the kind of couple of
biggest things in this budget and assess
how important there are that they are
now clearly a lot of conservatives a lot
of businesses worried about corporation
tax has gone up as you've been saying
there is now this set of allowances
effectively tax breaks to soften the
blow of corporation tax going up but
will that Bruce growth what's
interesting about the detail of the
financial Watchdog the office for Budget
responsibility is they say that that
measure really might just bring forward
growth meaning rather than Britain uh
growing more overalls there's a small
question mark over that that even though
I think broadly speaking it will be
welcomed by business another big part of
this budget is trying to get more people
back into work there's a huge great
Suite of measures so that's the reforms
to disability allowance and uh uh
basically making people who are
reluctant to work or can't work more
face more sanctions and then the big
part of that is the child care uh
announcement help for parents of one and
two-year-olds up to 30 hours a week
funded uh child care but when you take
all that package together and go back to
that office of a budget responsibility
uh report they they've looked at all of
that and gone well after all those
things have been done we are only going
to have an additional 110
000 people in work now there's seven
million people who are economically uh
uh inactive yet the uh the consequence
of the changes announced today seem to
be really quite so we spent a lot of
money the question is does it cause a
lot of difference on the ground it's
interesting just 110 000 of what seven
million people who are at not in work
really interesting at staff Sam let's
bring in Ed shall we because
I'm trying to help make a big song and
dance didn't hear about the fact that
we're going to be technically avoiding a
recession that the figures have improved
they've proved the doubt is wrong and
his words what do the numbers show if
you look under the Bonnet well yeah I'll
show you in just a sec that the the um
the chance I mean the recession what's a
recession the technical definition is
it's two quarters of the economy
shrinking we're not going to have that
but as I'll show you it's not exactly
like we should be necessarily
celebrating either the the overall
picture better than it was last time
around better than it was at the time of
the the mini budget but but just have a
look this gives you a sense of it okay
what we're looking at here this is the
level of the economy okay so the the
higher this is the bigger the economy is
the bigger the kind of big pie of money
that we're generating uh that could be
that split amongst all of us okay and
you can see it going up this was
pre-pandemic it was expected to go up up
up up up then of course we all know what
happened the pandemic happened and then
it kind of we have we have kind of
growth that is getting up towards those
pre-pandemic levels but at a kind of
removed from where it would have been
otherwise so we haven't kind of make
good some of that difference but here's
the critical thing that was last time
around so those are the November's
numbers that red line that you can see
there what did today's numbers show have
a look slightly different okay so this
line suggesting we've got slightly more
of that growth coming earlier and the
line gets closer to where it was back in
March 2020 to where it was expected to
be so that is good news and it does mean
maybe we've just about if you look at
the area where the chart where the line
is falling we might just about have
avoided a recession there but it's still
essentially kind of flat or dipping a
little bit at this point
um but a couple of things to bear in
mind first of all other people have a
different view okay this is the Bank of
England what their forecast suggests and
they say essentially rather than going
up like that like the obr is just saying
now we're going to be basically
flatlining for quite a long time that's
kind of depressing isn't it and when you
have a look at total household
disposable income so a different way of
looking at you know the sense of how the
economy is doing this this is the kind
of pound in your pocket stuff so these
These Bars basically show you over the
course of the last few decades going
back all the way to the 1950s this is
the 50s here anything above the line
shows that we are all getting better off
after you adjust for inflation taxes all
of those kinds of things anything below
the line it's the other way around and
last time around again we're saying last
times figures and I say last time that
means November we were talking about two
really Grim miserable years there the
Year we're in at the moment and the next
one those red bars going down a lot the
worst that we've seen in terms of our
household disposable income the feel
good Factor
um essentially ever or at least as far
as these numbers go back let's have a
look at how they've changed so keep an
eye on this these red bars and see how
they change now when we bring on today's
figures did you see that look they
rather than being like that they are
like that so there's still two pretty
Grim years in fact when you look at it
and just kind of draw a line going all
the way back it's still the worst two
years that we've had on record going all
the way back to the 1950s possibly even
before that but it is a little bit less
bad than it was previously and when you
look at this budget there are yes a lot
of measures in there that are designed
to try to boost growth um but the
question of course is whether they can
actually do it this is just showing you
it's called the scorecard that overall
amount of money that is kind of going
into the economy from the exchequer in
each of these years and a couple of
things to note here okay there are three
years where these bars are very big lots
of money going out actually about half
of each of these bars
is that full expensing policy if you're
a business you're basically able to
offset more of the money you're
investing against your tax bill in the
future it's definitely a big deal it's
definitely expensive but look at how in
2026-27 which of course is after the
next election These Bars get smaller
that's because it's only a temporary
policy and part of the problem behind
this being a temporary policy is it
doesn't necessarily mean that businesses
are investing in the long run they might
just be bringing forward some of their
spending and that's kind of what the obr
the office of responsibility says is
actually happening so a lot of different
measures here the one thing that wasn't
mentioned in all of the budget is what's
happening with interest rates and an
awful lot is happening with interest
rates right now behind the scenes
because there's a lot of concern about
what's happening in financial markets
it's worth just noticing this because
when it comes to your you know cost of
living crisis interest rates is a big
part of it and last August they were
expected to go up not very much frankly
then you had the mini budget the
expectation was they were going to go to
six and a half percent as of last week
they're expected to go to 4.75 in the
coming months they're up at four percent
at the moment so still a little bit
higher with effects for for many
households however of course we've had
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank
you've got concerns now about banks in
Switzerland as a result of all that
concern just look at this in the last
few days alone
that's down to expectations of peaking
of 4.1 it might well be that the bank of
England has essentially already hit the
peak so that is a massive massive thing
which could be very consequential for
many households not really you know
strictly speaking part of the budget
um but when we're talking about the cost
of living crisis that stuff that's at
least it should be said
um when we're talking about interest
rates today we're not talking about you
know a financial crisis or a
semi-financial crisis that was created
in this country is problems in
Switzerland it's problems in you know
the us that are kind of dribbling across
and causing that implication really
interesting uh staff what do you how do
you think this is going to go down with
conservative about benches I always
think there's kind of three groups of
people who we look at their reaction
look at the market reaction we look at
the voters reaction there's been quite a
lot of pressure from Adventures too
hasn't there yeah I think that um the
the problem is as Ed was outlining just
there the outlook for the next two years
for for voters is unusterably griven the
worst on Modern records and I'm not sure
that the measures today go a long way
towards helping most people in the
country there are small slices uh that
they get gonna get some uh benefit that
Chancellor is funneling money in but
it's not going to be felt I don't think
by the kind of people he's targeting so
yes there are calls for immediate tax
cuts yes that will probably come this
Autumn or maybe next April but the
government and Jeremy Hunt has not left
himself very much money to play with
he's spent a lot today it's not quite
clear that that would deliver a
political dividend that type of spending
on companies and long-term reform
delivers the kind of political dividend
that's going to help the Tories in a
matter of months really interesting well
one of the areas that the chancellor did
decide to spend some money on was in
encouraging people back into the
workplace and this is all part of the
pension reform and the news that the
lifetime allowance which is the total
amount that workers can accumulate in
their pension savings before paying
extra tax that has been abolished now
the idea is this encourages people to
stay in the workplace longer but earlier
I spoke to Paul Johnson who's the
director of The Institute for fiscal
studies he told me that he did have some
concerns about the proposed changes
I think this was quite a it was a
technical budget I think it was
genuinely making some changes which will
help the childcare corporation tax I'm
not so sure about the pensions tax
changes
um but it was and actually changes
disability benefits these are technical
but important and broadly speaking I
think sensible changes just to jump in
what why are you not so sure about the
pension and tax contributions well I
mean several reasons I mean one chance I
talked about it as being a response to
problems with doctors in the NHS well if
that was the target you should have
changed the NHS pension scheme it didn't
you don't need to change the entire tax
system to do it secondly it will of
course also allow people to save more in
their pension so while some people may
stay and work a little bit longer
because they can save more some people
might actually retire a little bit
earlier because they have saved more
because they've been able to
let's bring in our business presenter
Ian King who joins us now live from the
city Ian what do you make of the pension
changes
well I think to be honest it's one of
the few decent uh pension policies that
we've seen over the last decade Adam and
the lifetime allowance was introduced by
Gordon Brown in 2006 it was then hacked
away at by George Osborne Over many many
years it's increased the complexity of
retirement planning for many thousands
of people and contributed to this crisis
in the NHS that Paul Johnson referred to
now there is a case for saying perhaps
they should have just honed in on
reforms to doctors pensions but the fact
is you don't even need a lifetime
allowance when the annual amount that
you can save into your pension is
already capped although Jeremy Hunt
increased that annual allowance this
year anyway but logically speaking
there's no need for a lifetime allowance
if you've got an annual allowance in
place and the fact that the lifetime
allowance even existed really does point
up the fact that it was essentially a
stealth tax aimed at prizing more money
out of wealthier taxpayers
fascinating stuff in I'm Keen to find
out from you as well how the markets
have reacted to the budget we all
remember of course what happened with
the famous mini Mega budget with Liz
trusts and quasi-core saying all eyes on
the markets then what's been happening
this time around
well I mean the you can forget the UK
budget in terms of being a market-moving
event everything uh that's going on
today is all about the banking section
we are seeing Equity markets falling out
of bed right across Europe the banking
sector is taking an absolute thumping
and this is really uh the latest uh
twist in The Saga of the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank there are concerns
now that other European lenders may be
uh having some of the difficulties at
Silicon Valley Bank did and it's
investors have alighted in particular on
Credit Suisse which is the second
largest bank in Switzerland it's been a
very very accident prone bank it's been
tied up in one scandal after another
um it's for example it had big exposure
to Green Seal Capital when that went
under just about every uh thing that's
gone wrong over recent years in the
financial markets Credit Suisse has been
exposed to it now yesterday it said that
uh it had uncovered some problems with
its financial reporting for 2021 and
2022 meanwhile today its biggest single
shareholders starting National Bank has
said that if if the bet if credit Suites
needed to raise more Equity uh it would
not be able to put in any more money due
to regulation Credit Suisse shares have
fallen by 25 at one point they're off
some 13 now we are seeing banking stocks
right across Europe being absolutely
smacked uh for example Commerce Bank uh
you Germany's second largest lender off
by 10 right now Banco sabado which is
the TSB span Spain's uh parent company
of TSB all of these lenders are being
hit here in the UK Barclays is currently
off by seven and three quarter percent
all of the main lenders down by between
five and seven percent it's an absolute
route in banking stocks but I stress
this is absolutely nothing to do with
the budget it is however the big Market
story of the day really interesting an
important backdrop as well to the
measures announced today thank you very
much inking
now funding to nurseries providing free
child care is rising to 288 million
pounds and the child care costs of
parents moving into work or increasing
their hours on Universal Credit will be
paid up front rather than arrears that's
increased by around 50 percent
well with us now is the founder of
pregnant then Scrooge Jolie Braley thank
you very much for being with us I've got
to talk about your name first of all
pregnant then Scrooge just talk talk us
through the thinking behind that first
well I mean it is what it says on the
tin you know we really believe that many
women experience all sorts of types of
discrimination and barriers to being
able to work from the point that they
get pregnant and all of the evidence
shows that I had my own experience of
pregnancy discrimination I informed my
employer I was pregnant and the next day
they sacked Me by voicemail and my
employer was a children's charity so and
this happens to 54 000 women a year and
then there are other systemic barriers
that women encounter when trying to earn
a living after having children so we do
get pregnant and then screwed and of
course Child Care is a big part of that
look it impacts men as well as women as
I'm sure the two fathers on either side
of me will say as well but of course it
does really impact women an awful lot as
well right and the cost of child care is
kind of eye-watering 60 70 000 pounds
we've got two kids by the time they
reach school age
um do you think what's happened in the
budget is going to help things we are
really pleased to see this significant
investment in the child care sector we
had conversations with ministers About
Childcare three or four years ago and
they'd look at you like you were
speaking Klingon so to now see this as
such a major part of the spring budget
is just so pleasing we're so happy and
it will make an enormous difference to
parents who were really struggling to
afford those eye-watering fees what we
are still concerned about is the
workforce strategy and plan around this
because we know that workers are leaving
the Chaka sector in droves and without
the workforce of course those places are
impossible to deliver so we want to see
a strategy around Workforce progression
and pay and we also need to know that
this is going to be sustainable for
providers because we've lost so many
providers waiting lists are out of
control so
um we're really pleased to see it we
just want to make sure it absolutely is
sustainable and it's going to work go on
the waiting list you often hear people
not often but do you do sometimes hear
people who put their games down while
they're actually pregnant before even
giving birth to try and get on the
waiting list for some um of the
companies and there's a bit concerned
about funding as well that you're
alluding to there if there is a bit of a
shortfall in funding then do you think
that could put some more providers at
risk I mean they're absolutely well and
we know that the shortfall in funding
for the current three and four-year-old
entitlement is about four pounds per
child per hour and this is what's caused
many of the problems because providers
have to cross subsidize so they pass
those costs down the chain to younger
children means workers are paid
appallingly badly for this really
valuable job that they do that can get
paid more working in ASDA or McDonald's
and so that's why we've seen this sector
crumble because of this underfunding so
we have to get this right this time
there's no point in rolling out three
hours if we don't actually ensure that
the providers can deliver them do you
think there is a problem about just not
valuing the early years in the same way
that you know we put money into
universities and to education when
people are a bit older but those early
years are absolutely critical though
yeah absolutely and we know that it's a
proportion of GDP we spend way more on
children in those older years than we do
when children in the younger years yet
we know that the first five years of a
child's life are the most foundational
to their future they have a huge impact
on their well-being on their cognitive
and language skills so it sort of
doesn't make sense so the countries do
it the other way around and there's a
proportion of GDP it's very small
compared to other countries those early
years but there is also this uh sort of
narrative around care we expect women to
do it for free we think you know you've
had children you deal with it and that
means that the people that do this as a
profession also are undervalued and they
also tend to be women so there is a
whole piece of work to do around valuing
these brilliant brilliant women who are
doing this care and paying them properly
to do that job and it's I think and
you'll probably be more process than me
but if they look at the kind of growth
forecast this is actually the charcoal
policy is thought to be one of the
biggest drivers for growth in the budget
yeah that's right so it's you know so
part of the reason that is stop costing
kind of as much as as it you know as a
lot of people expected is they've
they've scored it to to look at the
economic impact and I suppose that kind
of feeds into the fact that that's
potentially more mothers in particular
who are able to to get back to work who
previously would have had to uh to stay
at home in order to to do child care
that aren't going to have to be able to
do that so there's an economic kind of
side to this as well yeah we know Canada
for example invested 30 billion dollars
in their child care sector to create a
system that costs no more than ten
dollars a day which two parents in
England dollars a day ten dollars a day
um I mean it's just I mean mind blow
um and they did that because they
crunched the numbers they tested it in
Quebec and for every dollar they
invested they got between 1.80 and 2.50
back into the wider economy Australia
did it they found for every dollar they
invested they got two dollars back so we
absolutely know that this is a mechanism
for growth but what we forget in this is
the child and it's also a really
incredible opportunity for a government
to invest in children in those early
years so that they really do better in
the education system and you're not
paying more further down the line so we
do need to remember the child in all of
this as well as women being able to go
back to work especially post pandemic
after after so many children have lost
years of their education as a result of
lockdowns oh that's it we know that from
report after report the children sadly
are falling behind because of the
pandemic so it's really critical that
the first five years we get those right
really interesting to talk thank you
very much for being on the program thank
you
I'm all analysis from Sam and Ed coming
up but just want to show you these
images because while the chancellor was
delivering his budget inside Westminster
the streets outside were filled with
tens of thousands of striking workers
who marched through Central London now
ministers have resisted the demands for
public sector pay Rises to keep up with
inflation and as a result more than 400
000 workers across a range of sectors
are on strikes in disputes over pay it's
thought to be the biggest day of
industrial action since the current wave
of unrest began last year no surprise as
it was targeted on the day the budget
teachers in England University lecturers
civil servants and London Underground
drivers are all walking out and Junior
doctors as well are into the final day
of a 72-hour strike affecting hospitals
across England now Jeremy Hunt in the
budget saying that he is not going to be
embedding any inflation encouraging at
pay Rises into the system that's been
his line throughout but course those
strikes continuing and you can see the
number of people taken to the streets
today
or we can get a bit more reaction to the
budget now from the shadow economic
secretary tulip Sadiq thanks very much
for being on the program today no
recession more money for child care some
things to enjoy from the budget well I
think the devil is in the details so I
just heard you speaking to Jolie before
about child care and I was someone who
has two small children I would have
definitely benefited from what's been
announced today but I want to see how
it's funded for a start it is something
we've been calling for from the labor
party for a long time you've probably
seen that the budget has labors and
fingerprints all over it in terms of
things you must really think it's a
great budget and well well we would
think of it if we knew how it was going
to be funded for for a start but also I
did want to see some announcements which
I was a bit disappointed about about
breakfast clubs for example which is one
of the things that constantly comes up
when I'm visiting nurseries they did say
about wrap around care for schools
though didn't they they did they say
about breakfast clubs at 8 A.M to 6 p.m
I think by 2024 I believe well if let's
see how that works out and how it's
funded but the one thing I was very
worried about I don't know if Jolie
mentioned it because I didn't watch the
whole thing was about the child care
ratio so one of the things I hear
constantly when I'm speaking to people
and I was in Shadow education before is
the fact that before and you I think you
had four children and now he's saying
that maybe it would be five per person I
don't know if you've ever tried to look
after five children with my two I
struggle anyway but there was a
consultation done last year on ratio and
children's ratios in nurseries there was
no response to that the government
didn't even respond to consultation and
now they're saying five children they're
not saying it's compulsory just to be
clear but they're saying it's advisable
and I think that's very worrying and how
about the wider kind of economic picture
as well
um the figures do seem to be improving
slightly
well it's felt to me like there was a
series of announcements and but there
was no long-term sort of growth plan and
that's what I'm worried about I looked
at the figures in the oecd and we ranked
25 out of 38 countries in terms of
growth we're the only country in the G7
that hasn't gone back to its pre-covered
levels in terms of growth so I really
wanted to see some sort of sustained
plan for growth that I didn't really
feel we saw that we saw the announcement
about pensions obviously I just saw Paul
Johnson from the ifs saying that it will
only benefit a very small minority of
people and we think it could be a very
costly mistake if it doesn't work out so
people who are in the one percent of the
country in terms of earning will benefit
from that policy we haven't seen the
figures yet but if you have a two
million pound pension you'll be paying
275 000 pounds less now obviously I want
people to get into the workforce
obviously I want to strengthen the
numbers in the NHS but it could be a
very costly mistake if it doesn't it's a
gamble if it doesn't pay off so we've
asked the the treasury for numbers on
this to support the fact that people
will go back into work so let's see I
mean it's always difficult to have this
sort of immediate reaction to a budget
that's only been delivered but that's a
bit of a red flag there the policy on
the lifetime pension allowance we are
the only reason we're worried to be
honest is because it sounds like it's
going to be a multi-million pound policy
and it may not pay off in exactly the
same way that the government wants and
it feels like it's not just a labor
party but the ifs are saying that as
well saying it would only benefit a very
small minority of people now it may
affect like like we think one percent of
the population who are very rich that's
not going to help our economy really so
like we said we've asked for the figures
let's see what they say if they say this
is amazing and this many people are
going to be retained with us somehow I
don't feel so optimistic about it just
judging from the numbers at First Sight
just on that I think the government
think that it's going to cost about 850
million pounds a year to fund the
scrapping of the lifetime tax allow and
will benefit tens of thousands uh about
10 000 people on that basis do you think
you'll support or oppose it are they
sure about those figures because when we
um press them for it they definitely
weren't so sure so is that what they've
said is the figures in the red book I'll
have to look at the details but um
sometimes they do give these figures and
they don't play out exactly how do they
think it's going to affect tens of
thousands though because 10 000 people
about ten thousand dollars it's still an
enormous amount of money for 10 000
people I think at this stage
can you see labor voting against
anything that you heard today well one
of the things we are quite concerned
about is field Duty because I don't know
if you have more information than me
obviously we were calling for it to be
frozen for three months but we were
going to pay for it we said by bringing
in a proper windfall tax and I'm sure
you know all of this but just for the
benefit of anyone else listening we
wanted to backdate it we wanted to tax
oil and gas rates at the same rates as
Norway and other countries we also said
we were going to close a loophole which
was the fossil fuel investment loophole
to and that would raise 13 million
pounds that was going to form part of
the basis of how we pay for freezing
fuel Duty for three months how the
governments that they're going to pay it
because they were just going to be
transferred to working people who have
to pay the burden because I don't know
if you guys know but we were quite
worried about that who's going to pay
for this freezing it seems what's
interesting actually though is
um that's field duty is kind of one of
our green taxes it's probably the
biggest green tax that we have in this
country you know we talk about Green
taxes talk about trying to get to Net
Zero trying trying to have a kind of
joined up strategy
there were kind of inconsistency in
being kind of saying that you want to to
reach Net Zero you want to do it
potentially faster than the conservative
party and yet you're supporting this
plan to cut the biggest green tax you
know maybe you'll make up some of it
from windfall taxes but all the same it
does it does seem a little inconsistent
doesn't it well when you're in a
situation where the country is really
struggling and people are relying on
their cars because they have to go to
work and also because of the number of
people who we have who are disabled or
sick and can't use public transport then
I think we've had to we have to get the
country moving and that's why we were
supporting it even certainly the
environment well you know we've had we
have a very clear plan about our climate
change investment plan about getting
green Industries working about making
sure that we if we have to borrow to
invest 28 million pounds billion pounds
which you know about
um well I hope you know about I'm
assuming everyone reads our Manifesto
and our policies all the time but if
it's in a situation where we get the
economy growing for the time being and
people can use their cars yeah we are
supporting it but that wasn't really my
point I don't I mean it doesn't sound
like anyone does know how are they going
to fund this have you asked anyone from
the government I don't know well I've
seen this just in the general I think I
think it's too boring I mean yeah and
it's they're borrowing a bit less unless
you say six billion pounds is it's quite
a big chunk I mean I I have to say I
generally don't know why when they did
bring in the windfall tax they didn't
bring in the proper winfall tax because
they could have and they could have
raised 13 million pounds from it and
they have taken lots of our ideas and if
it gets the country growing we're happy
with that but just bring it in properly
because they're saying they have too
much money they don't know what to do
with it the oil and gas companies why
wouldn't we use that there's a very
minor change they could make in terms of
back dating it would raise a lot more
money so I hope they're listening okay
thank you very much indeed great to have
you on the program at tulip Sadiq uh
there
um we are about to lose uh Ed so let's
have a bit of a final thought uh shall
we on we've been
it's going right through since 11 in the
morning and so and your brain's probably
a little bit scrambled any chance do
you've had another chance we have a
chance no no I've done I've done okay
all right
um I mean I think so so you know the big
picture here the economy is doing a
little bit better than than was
previously expected but is that going to
matter for for most people I mean you
know most people see that their lives
are getting far more expensive they're
getting squeezed from all of these
different directions squeezed by prices
squeezed by interest rates squeezed by
the fact that taxes are going up as well
and some of those taxes have yet to kick
in you know we've heard from Paul
Johnson we've seen on the analysis that
a chunk of the chart I was showing you
earlier about real household disposable
income and how that's kind of going down
for lots of households you know chunk of
that is taxes it is taxes so I think the
real question and this goes you know
Strays somewhat into into kind of Sam's
territory is
how does does this kind of repair any of
the kind of scarring that was done to
the Tori's reputation for for economic
credibility by what's happened over the
past six months can nothing erase that
the economy is certainly getting better
is it going to get better quick enough
that people will notice it and have a
feel good thanks it almost certainly not
is it more stable to some extent yes and
yet some of these measures much as they
are welcomed by for instance business
whether it's full expensing no it has
that could be a massive thing for
business but it's done on a kind of
temporary basis and so these are
technical concerns but do they
necessarily add up to a budget we're
just going to boost growth
not necessarily convincing at the moment
so yeah sorry that was a little bit that
is that is actually it's been a long day
but um thank you very much for all your
analysis and all the chances it never
Seasons to amaze me how speedily you
managed to get them up
um Ed there it felt like a pose a bit of
a question didn't he whoops I'm just
throwing my pen around
um about uh whether or not the budget is
going to do enough to make people feel
better off effectively what do you think
the political reaction to that is well
it always comes down to as it always
does in this bit of the election cycle
to that conversation about tax cuts and
there's nothing really on tax cuts for
voters all the measures in the budget
today benefit voters indirectly and as
Ed was just saying it takes a little bit
of time before uh growth boosting
measures those um uh tax allowance
changes that help business save some of
their corporation tax actually create
new jobs and benefit people uh possibly
not in time for an election now the
problem that Jeremy Hunters created for
himself is he hasn't left much wiggle
room he spent a lot of money today 21
billion pounds next year and the year
after that doesn't leave him a lot of
space to try and cut taxes in a big way
in the kind of way that many story about
benchers think is necessary so what are
you going to do to make people feel
better off before polling day that
question is unresolved and there was
nothing in the budget that started to
answer it uh fascinating thank you very
much indeed Sam for talking us through
some of the political uh reaction to
that budget and your allies list as well
so is there a good news for household
finances let's try and bring in Greg
Marsh shall we because we're talking
about how people are going to feel it in
their pocket Greg what's your take
yeah well as that said there's a big
picture and there's the little picture
what does this mean for households so
we've been looking today at the analysis
of the budget on ordinary households
well there was some good news this
morning confirmed at lunchtime the
energy price guarantee is being held
where it was at three uh 2500 pounds it
was going to increase to 3 000 which
would have been a bad nasty surprise for
households it's coming down and coming
down further as Energy prices fall later
this year
potentially some more good news in fuel
Duty freeze so again have fuel Duty gone
up we would have seen the cost of
filling a tank of a petrol at the pumps
rise significantly we're stuck with
futility where it was good news for
drivers
also uh however less good news for
income earners particularly those on
higher incomes now one way to think
about this problem is look at what's
happened to the rate at which we pay
income tax over the last few years it's
increased a little bit it's hard to see
it if we look at it like this so let's
look at it in a slightly different way
let's look at what's happened to the
rate of tax at a pending on your income
level
those on immediate income in the UK as a
result of tax thresholds being frozen
where they are today no change to tax
thresholds but incomes rising and
average income increasing about seven
percent this year means that the average
family is paying more tax but higher
income taxpayers higher earners only
between 50 and 100 000 the effects of
that so-called fiscal drag it's a kind
of stealth tax it means that those
income earners are paying significantly
more and even higher income earners 100
000 or more paying an awful lot more tax
as a result of those tax thresholds not
moving in line with earnings increases
what does this mean for actual
households well we've met Mike over the
course of the day and we've been
spending some time with Mike Mike is an
I.T consultant he's comfortably off he
owns his own home as a result of running
the analysis on Mike's income and Mike's
household we can see that Mike's energy
bills will be better than they were
because that price cap guaranteeing
larger house a bit more even than some
households similarly the freezing fuel
Duty good news for Mike
however the effect of those frozen tax
thresholds for a household like Mike's
is very significant potentially more
than offsetting the giveaways in the
Chancellor's budget today our analysis
is that on a net basis Mike's household
probably about a hundred pounds a year
worse off as a result of today's budget
let's look at a very different household
Leanne is a self-employed fitness
instructor and Leanne has a young
daughter four years old so unfortunately
too old to benefit from any of the child
care giveaways in today's announcement
but Leanne and her husband in their
household are beneficiaries of that
freeze in the energy cap good news for
them there similarly the increase in
child benefit and inflationary increase
in child benefit about 114 pounds a year
of good use for this household because
Leanne's husband drives a lot for his
job runs a removal business even better
news on the fuel tax freeze so a very
significant increase however those
income earning households like Leanne
and her husband like Mike's are seeing
that offset effect of those frozen
income tax thresholds so again overall
Leanne's household better off as a
result of today's budget so it's not a
disaster at all but it's a mixed picture
a household like Leanne's slightly
better off a household like Mike's
slightly worse off now hopefully we can
go live to Sam in Burnley who's got
Leanne and Mike with her and so we can
get their reaction live Sam over to you
thank you very much Greg welcome back to
Burnley here in Lancashire we've been at
this drop-in center Church on the street
um all day long it has now closed as you
can see it's emptied out behind me it
was absolutely full of throngs of people
coming in here earlier to get a hot meal
even to take away some clothes on a cold
day like this but as I was saying uh
life goes on for them they have gone
home many of them weren't even that
interested in what Jeremy Hunt had to
say today in delivering his budget but
of course many of those announcements
will affect them one way or another we
didn't actually hear Burnley mentioned
there were a lot of towns and cities
mentioned the reason we came here of
course is because Burnley is the place
in all of Great Britain with the highest
inflation rate well we're joined Now by
two of those people who have stayed on
to carry on analyzing the budget what it
means for them here today we've had Mike
we've been speaking to Mike all days and
I.T consultant and we also have Leanne
Bruce she's a fitness instructor hello
there to you Leanne we haven't actually
had you on television yet although your
finances have been all over Sky News I
hope that's all right
um Greg Marsh was there explaining that
actually uh there's some marginal
benefit for you with this budget but
overall it doesn't do much for you I
know you've your fitness instructor
you've got a little girl
um but the child care benefits which are
the big thing about this budget don't
affect you she's four yeah we've just
missed out she just started school so
unfortunately we're just uh 12 months
too late for that one but it is
beneficial and it's something that I
think has been definitely a long time
coming it's going to really help working
parents get back into get back into work
with that with that extra support so
yeah I was reading that you went
part-time didn't you because the cost of
child care was just too expensive so if
this had happened then would that have
made a big difference to your decision
to work full-time and possibly not
full-time because even then you know the
rates are just extortion that you're
talking sort of 50 pound a day and which
you know if you need full-time child
care that's going to mount up across
across a month but I could only afford
to put her in Nursery you know for one
full day and two half days really so
uh women have to make a lot of decisions
when they decide about whether they work
particularly also if you're you're
self-employed and I think your your
husband's also is self-employed you're
both out on the road a lot so your fuel
expenses were really high yeah um what
was in the budget for you do you think
in terms of freezing of the fuel duty is
that going to make a difference I mean
it's not going to make things any worse
but let's face it it's they do a good
job about singing and dancing in
Parliament you know making it sound like
they're doing all this wonderful things
to help people and it's not helping it's
not helping at all you know everyone is
still much much worse off than than we
were my husband does a removal business
Damian Bruce removals and you know he's
paying 20 40 pounds a week more
in fuel costs than what it was
previously so it's not going to get much
worse but I can't say that it's better
because it's just it's just not really
all right we've got a nice little plug
in there for his business we'll let that
one go give them the circumstances I
might coming back to you um when we
started talking to you you were telling
us that actually your pension was a
victim of the Liz truss mini budget yes
um because of what happened in the money
markets and of course as you get closer
to retirement age like you are if you
don't mind me saying um but your pension
starts being lifestyle so moved more
into the money markets which is why you
lost that money when you look at the
measures that put forward by Jeremy Hunt
today who is trying to correct that
impression that the budget isn't just
for the wealthy what do you think
um well what I'd say is I don't have a
million pounds in the sermons part for
my pension so yeah I'm referring to that
lifetime allowance which is now scrapped
yes and I don't think there would be
people in Burnley who do have that kind
of a pension pot let alone the ability
to supplement it tax-free from what I've
been reading in the report
that movie is a large tax giveaway to
the very rich because they can add to
their pension part tax-free and um
the rest of us just don't get a slice of
that pie which is a real shame and as
you say I lost about about a third of my
pension pot
um over 49 days last year
okay all right so if he has tried to
correct it it has it certainly hasn't
worked and there's been a big boom for
the very highest earners yeah and
interesting to get perspectives from me
both you both have very uh different
ways of making a living both very
different lives and and how it's
affected both of you really appreciate
you talking to us here on Sky News so we
also want to hear uh from you do please
send us your thoughts on the budget what
did you think of the chancellors
announcements uh are any of them going
to help you with the cost of living
crisis or was there an issue that he
missed out on we've been hearing uh
quite a few uh there that he might have
missed out on you can ring us on 0208
167-2200 to be part of a special phone
in program to have your say and you can
ask our experts any questions you might
have about your situation you can watch
that it's called the budget you will say
it's at 7 p.m this evening right here on
Sky News
[Applause]
well we are still here with all the
analysis you need of the budget and the
guys who've done all of their analysis
already is the office for Budget
responsibility they predicted that the
UK will not enter technical recession
this year now the chancellor has
announced that he expects inflation to
fall to 2.9 by December it was at 10.7
in the final quarter of 2022.
when we're joined now by the chair of
the office for Budget responsibility
Richard Hughes thanks for having us on
being on the program today
um good to be able to have a say on a
big fiscal event this time around them
oh yes we were involved in this fiscal
event from from the beginning and
actually we had a date announced very
early back in back in December so we're
able to plan our work
um in a way which was very predictable
and the budget came off uh more or less
in mind with those plans
um now I just came to a talk in Broad
terms initially Jeremy Hunt said that
this was going to be a budget for growth
has he succeeded in that
all right so the economic Outlook in
general is brighter than we'd forecast
back in November uh you know both gas
prices have come down interest rates
have come down we expect inflation to be
slightly lower over the medium term that
means that we expect the the fall than
GDP over the course of this year to be
lower than we forecast back in November
it falls by just half a percent rather
than the two percent that we're
expecting back in back in November and
then over the medium term the level of
output is also slightly higher it's
higher by about half a percent of GDP uh
in five years time and about 0.2 percent
of that Improvement
um can be attributed to the policies
that the chancellor announcing his
budget in particular those around trying
to boost the labor force
that's interesting so around 0.2 percent
uh are due to this budget the rest I
guess the the vast majority due to
external factors like for example the
falling price of oil and gas
yes that's right Energy prices when they
come down they reduce the cost they
reduce the cost of doing business in the
UK and they undo some of that shock that
we faced from having higher energy
prices after the Russian invasion of
Ukraine although it's still important to
emphasize that even in the medium term
Energy prices are still higher um twice
as high as they were before the Russian
invasion of Ukraine we were used to in
the UK paying about 50 people firm for
gas even at the end of our forecast
we're still paying more than a pound per
therm for gas so we're still dealing
with in the in the longer run a much
higher cost of energy and that still
acts as a drag on our growth and a drag
on our productivity in our forecast you
mentioned there the measures that are
going to help growth being around trying
to tackle economic inactivity so for
example changes to the pension allowance
and also of course child care how do you
see those two things improving or not
so we think in five years time all that
package of measures taken together you
know both the pensions measures as well
as the child care measures as well as
the changes around benefits and support
for people who are inactive for reasons
like having a long-term health condition
we think taken together those measures
at around 110 000 people to the
workforce in five years Time by far the
biggest impact comes from the child care
measures we think that that increases
the workforce by about 60 000 because it
allows more young young parents to come
into the workforce who are otherwise
prevented from doing so by the higher
cost of child care it also means that
the young parents who are already in the
workforce
um but but paying for their own child
care by getting help from the government
that allows them to increase their hours
so you get another effect on on GDP also
from the fact that you've got more
people working longer hours who are
already in the workforce but paying for
child care at the moment with young
children so you're saying 60 000 people
entering the workforce you anticipate
because the child care changes have you
broken down the other elements at all to
get to the 110 figure
so for the rest it's all it's all sort
of in the tens of thousands for the
lifetime allowance we think there's
around 15 000 more people coming back
into the workforce and then the rest of
that hundred and ten thousand comes from
the other measures that are acting on
benefit claimants and also getting more
support from the Department for work and
pensions and the Department of Health
but by far the biggest element of the
hundred and ten thousand is a sixty
thousand extra from Child Care
and I just want to talk a bit about the
economic predictions as well because
Jeremy Hunt made quite a big deal of the
fact that we are avoiding a technical
recession this year but at the same time
growth is still pretty poor and you're
also forecasting uh the biggest ever
fall in living standards since freckles
began in 2022 and 2023 how would you sum
up the economic picture
so it's brighter than it was in November
but it's still being held back by these
by these structural challenges of the UK
economy faces we lost 500 000 people
from the workforce we think that by the
end of our forecast you know we've still
got about 380 000 people still missing
from the workforce compared to our
pre-pandemic forecasts so we're still
dealing with the fact that we lost a lot
of people from the pandemic and we only
get us we only get a proportion of those
back by the end of the forecast period
we've also had seven years of stagnant
real investment um here in the UK the
budget measures that the chance
renounced today have a temporary impact
on investment over the next three years
we think they boost it by around three
percent a year but then investment falls
back an hour forecast after that because
these measures expire in 2026 and
actually the overall level of
Investments are now forecast if you
start in 2022 and you finish in 2027
it's pretty much unchanged compared to
what we're forecasting back in November
because what the what the temporary
investment incentives do is just bring
forward investment from the future and
make it happen now to get the tax
benefit but because the measures is
temporary and it expires in three years
time investment then falls back to lower
than where it was in our forecast before
I'm just going to bring in some coats
our Deputy political Avatar uh hello
there
um one of the Striking things about
today's budget is that Jeremy Hunt
actually spent quite a lot of money he
took us to within a whisker of the
fiscal rules the self-imposed rules
about how much he can spend how much he
can borrow if you were a Chancellor
looking for the ability to maybe cut
taxes in a way that might people might
find more attractive before an election
has he left himself any wiggle room at
all to do that is he going to be able to
cut taxes or has he actually spent so
much at this point that he's not really
going to have the room to do so
so you're right that the margin of the
chances left against his fiscal rules is
around 0.2 percent of GDP and that is a
vanishingly small amount of Headroom
against a fiscal Target in five years
time and even by historical terms the
average chances left himself a margin of
of something more like two some one to
two percent of GDP against his fiscal
targets and so it's it's very much a
White Knuckle ride between now and and
the fifth year of our forecast but one
thing to remember about the nature of
the Chancellor's fiscal rule is that
it's actually a rolling fiscal rule so
it always targets the fifth year of the
fifth year ahead and as we move into and
we do our next forecast in November the
forecast is going to roll on a further
year that gets them another year to hit
his Target so it's a sort of Manana rule
which you can always put off by another
year because you're always trying to
reach it in five years time it never
actually falls due in the current year
um because it's a Target about what
happens in the forecast not enough not a
Target about what happens today
gotta love those fiscal rules and
gurpreet Norman our business
correspondent with a question now
um your forecasts are more optimistic
than they were back in November but
they're even more optimistic than the
bank of England's why can you explain
that discrepancy between your forecasts
and the bank of England's forecasts and
then just secondly we know your
forecasts are based on assumptions about
where interest rates might be we've seen
following the collapse of Silicon Valley
Bank that the outlook for interest rates
has shifted what does that mean for your
forecasts
that's right our forecast different from
the bank in a number of respects one is
that we're both forecasting in a very
volatile economy and so that means that
depending on when you're forecasting you
have different assumptions about energy
prices and different assumptions about
interest rates both of which have been
jumping around a lot in recent weeks and
so because we were forecasting later
than the bank interest rates had come
down a bit Energy prices had also come
down a bit that meant that we had a you
know we had less less of a drag on
growth in our forecast than the bank had
when they put theirs together we also
reflect the impact of the policy
measures that were announced today in
our forecast so the Boost to investment
in the near term the Boost to employment
in the medium term as well as the latest
news we've had about migration that also
boosts uh growth relative to what the
bank had assumed in their forecasts we
also have a slightly more optimistic
view of our long-run productivity
potential than the bank does we don't
think it's going to stay at its very low
post financial crisis level but make
some kind of recovery but not back to
its pre-financial crisis level so in
that sense that's one of the reasons why
we're more optimistic than the bank's
been in our forecasts
okay thank you very much indeed that was
Richard Hughes there the chair at the
office for Budget responsibility thank
you for being on the program
we'll have lots more analysis from Sam
and gurpreet as the afternoon uh
continues but that was the budget for
growth and that was how it was built by
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt still pretty
poor economic figures but they're less
bad than they were previously so a small
win perhaps for the chancellor and the
measures that were there were all about
trying to get people back into the
workplace with an eye-catching policy
announcement particularly on Child Care
lots more coming up on the budget we'll
have more analysis and reaction in the
next hour
[Music]
thank you
hello it is four o'clock this is gone
News live from Westminster on the day
the chancellor presented his vision for
the country's financial future we're all
afternoon we're going to be assessing
the budget announcements with our Deputy
political editor Sam coats and our
business correspondent gurpreet narwin
well Jeremy Hunt unveils his budget for
growth as the fiscal Watchdog predicts
inflation will fall to 2.9 by the end of
the year
the international monetary fund
says our approach means the UK economy
is on the right track
today's budget changes nothing again we
see a failure to grip the long-term
challenges no determination to create
growth which unlocks the potential of
the many working people being made to
pay for Tory choices and Tory mistakes
well the chancellor announces 30 hours a
week of free child care for every child
in England aged between nine months and
five years
on energy and end the prepayment penalty
for the poorest and average bills will
stay at 2 500 pounds for three more
months
corporation tax will rise but businesses
will be able to deduct expenses from
taxable profits
and field Duty will remain Frozen at
five pencil leader that will save
motorists a hundred pounds next year
and we've been finding out how those
measures have gone down here in Burnley
the town with the highest inflation in
the country
including what they think of the
lifetime pensions allowance being
dropped to entice older people back to
work
but no new pay deals as hundreds of
thousands of teachers Junior doctors
tube workers and civil servants go on
strike
good afternoon live from Westminster
well in his first budget as Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt said the UK is proving the
doubters wrong as he vowed the country
is set to avoid a technical recession
this year taking to his feet in the
Commons he painted a picture of falling
inflation with announcements on Child
Care fuel Duty pensions and more
well there's lots to analyze we're going
to be looking through all the details
joined by Sky's Deputy political editor
Sam Coates and also Skye's business
correspondent garfunknowen alongside us
to decipher exactly what the measures
will mean for the economy but also for
you as well but first let's just try and
take you through some of the key
announcements today
well the chancellor began his budget by
announcing that the UK is expected to
avoid a technical recession this year
and that's because forecasts say
inflation is set to fall from 10.7 to
2.9 percent by the end of 2023. the
energy price guarantee will now continue
until June with household bills
remaining at 2 500 pounds for the
average home the chancellor has also
promised 30 hours of free child care a
week to working parents in England with
children aged between nine months and
five years
Jeremy Hunt also announced what he
called full expensing now that's a nine
billion pound scheme which means every
pound a company invests in it equipment
and Machinery can be deducted from
taxable profits in an effort to boost
growth the government will invest 80
million pounds over five years in 12 new
UK investment zones and the lifetime
allowance which is the total amount that
workers can accumulate in their pension
savings before paying extra tax while
that has been abolished completely and
in the pensions annual tax-free
allowance that will also Rise by 50
percent
took difficult decisions to deliver
stability and sound money
since mid-october 10-year guilt rates
have fallen debt servicing costs are
down mortgage rates are lower and
inflation has peaked the international
monetary fund
says our approach means the UK economy
is on the right track
but we remain Vigilant and will not
hesitate to take whatever steps are
necessary for economic stability
today the
responsibility forecasts that because of
changing International factors and the
measures I take the UK will not now
enter a technical recession this year
[Applause]
they forecast
they
[Applause]
they of course we will meet the prime
minister's priorities to have inflation
reduce debt and get the economy growing
well the chancellor also announced
business investment support as well when
he stood up in the Commons a little
earlier
I can announce we will introduce a new
policy of full capital expensing for the
next three years with an intention to
make it permanent as soon as we can
responsibly do so that means that every
single pound a company invests in it
equipment plant or Machinery can be
deducted in full and immediately from
taxable profits
it is a corporation tax cut worth an
average of nine billion pounds a year
for every year that it's in place
so that was Jeremy Hunt's nine billion
pounds attempt to try and lessen some of
the impacts of that corporation tax hike
and there was also some news for working
parents as well because the chancellor
confirmed extra financial help for
parents who might be struggling to pay
for childcare
so for any parents who are moving into
work or want to increase their hours we
will pay the child care costs up front
and we will increase the maximum they
can claim to 951 pounds for one child
and 1 630 pounds for two children an
increase of almost 50 percent
I turn now to parents of school-aged
children who often face barriers to
working because of the limited
availability of wraparound care
one-third of primary schools do not
offer Child Care at both ends of the
school day even though for many people a
job requires it to be available before
and after school
to address this we'll fund schools and
local authorities to increase the supply
of wraparound care so all school-age
parents can drop their children off
between 8 AM and 6 p.m and our ambition
is that all schools will start to offer
a full wrap-around offer either on their
own or in partnership with other schools
by September 2026
and then Chancellor also of course
announced the extension of the 30 hours
of free child care to all children from
nine months now the labor leader
kirstama criticized the new budget for
not showing signs of what he described
as real ambition
Madam Deputy speaker these are the
organizing principles of conservative
economics judge them by their choices
the running down of our Public Services
paid for by working people the disaster
of the Tory mortgage premium paid for by
working people
still miss for a proper windfall tax
paid for by working people
that's what makes the Chancellor's boast
about lower inflation so ridiculous the
idea that it's a tax cut British people
can see through that they see their tax
burden at its highest level for 70 years
and they know it's not the government
that's lowering inflation it's working
people earning less enjoying less it's
their sacrifice that is helping to bring
inflation down and they deserve better
than another Cheap Trick from the
government of gimmicks making them pay
whilst trying to claim the credit
and even with the price guarantee the
average Energy bill has doubled in 18
months because of their recklessness the
average mortgage payment is up 2 000
pounds a year a massive hit to living
standards however they cook the books
and yet still no real ambition on
Industrial strategy no real ambition on
the clean energy that will give us
cheaper bills no real ambition on house
building the same old Tory choices
sticking plaster politics no growth for
the many working people pay
well that was kirstama's reaction to the
budget we can bring in Sam and gerprick
now to get their reaction to the budget
and Sam first of all what's your main
takeaway
well here we are six months after really
the economy was at a Brink and we're
back to another spending budget Jeremy
Hunt adding about 21 billion pounds to
the economy for each the next couple of
years
um so decent sums but what's interesting
is how he and Rishi sunak have chosen to
spend the money that they have not
things that you might do if you had an
election in mind uh there weren't big
tax cuts he didn't
um tackle the public sector strikes uh
which are causing misery today for lots
of parents lots of commuters but instead
primarily this was a budget uh that
centered around trying to boost growth
uh and as they've been talking about for
several days the idea of today was to
try and get more people back into the
workforce with a suite of measures that
basically targeting different people
from pensioners the gender pension rules
uh they have changed the disability
rules and the medium term uh that they
hope we're going to be more people back
into work and uh and then notably the
the changes around child care now that
will be a big and substantial move for
parents of one and two-year-olds now
it's coming in over time it doesn't all
come in at once it's going to be a
couple of years before all the changes
are available to working parents but
that is a big deal but what's
interesting is when you look at the fine
print the office for Budget
responsibility uh say that actually even
though there are perhaps seven million
people who could be filling vacancies in
the economy this is only going to mean
another hundred and ten thousand people
are back in the workforce uh in five
years time so a big change but not
necessarily a big effect and some
political dangers I think with the fact
that pensions changes will basically
only benefit the very richest so I this
is a budget where I am I'm interested
how it lands and whether it makes an
impact with the voters uh or whether
some of the measures actually backfire
yeah it's interesting the I think the
obr told us and they just a moment ago
that 15 000 people they expect to come
back to the work force because the
pension changes which is quite a small
amount of people I guess when you think
about the
um the amount of money they might be
saving
um let's get some ration from you shall
we because Jeremy Hunt you know who
stood up to Great Applause saying we're
going to avoid a technical recession he
said that Rishi sunak is on track to me
all three of his economic pledges what
do you make of the numbers
yeah see the budget is based on a set of
forecasts that are put out by the office
for Budget responsibility and Jeremy
Hunt made a very big deal about the fact
that we're going to avoid a technical
recession but a technical recession is
just that it's technical it's two
quarters of negative growth two quarters
consecutively in which the economy
shrinks we might have avoided that but
over the course of the year the economy
is still going to shrink by 0.2 percent
that's a small upgrade on November but
most people watching at home will
probably be able to recognize that when
it comes to their living standards
living standards over the two years
that's this year and next year they will
shrink by almost six percent again a
small Improvement but still the biggest
decline in living standards over a
two-year period since records began in
the 50s can I ask a stupid question when
we talk about a decline in living
standards what do we mean we mean how
much money people have to spend how much
disposable income they have at the end
of the month and most people will know
that a lot of that has been eroded by
inflation
um people's mortgages have been going up
their rents have been going up the cost
of living has been rising but also taxes
the tax burden is that a post uh
post-war high and that's showing no
signs of coming down we know that fiscal
drag is very much in force the
government hasn't lowered those tax
thresholds that it's been able to put in
um for a while now
um so most people I think responding to
this will may say that we've avoided a
technical recession but it doesn't
really feel like that you feel like it
that's not the point um Sam interesting
talk about taxes there with um Gopi and
because this has been of course
something that lots of conserved about
benches have been getting pretty worked
off about I think Simon Clark and pretty
Patel both this morning saying that they
want the conservative party to be doing
something when it comes to the tax
burden how much disquiet is there
well I I don't think that the
conservatives have a really a consistent
view within themselves on how to manage
the economy one moment they're looking
to be uh bringing down debt the next day
wanting to spend lots on leveling up
next thing they wanted to cut taxes uh
they they have for years now been at
odds and say there are different wings
of the conservative party that want
different things and you're right
there's a Wing uh that wants tax cuts
now and Rishi sunak has sort of ever
since he tried to run for the leadership
last summer made clear that that isn't
his approach he's gonna wait until the
right time and he can afford it and then
you can get some tax cuts what's
interesting is that there's so little of
this budget that looks like you have any
kind of election which could be barely a
year away in mind all of the measures
the main measures will either take time
to come in or designed to boost growth
and it takes a while before that
actually makes people better off so I
wouldn't be surprised if there wasn't a
great deal of public reaction to this
budget it just doesn't hit individuals
directly quickly and in that case why
should they care maybe saving that form
for an election budget you can see that
happening and one other thing I wanted
to talk to you about as well it's
interesting talking to Ian King earlier
who was talking about the markets and he
said look ignore the markets in reaction
to the budget that's got nothing to do
with the budget this is all about what's
happening with the banking sector
um and our concern should we be as a
country which obviously you know has a
lot of banking is a big part of our
economy how content should we be about
what's happened to Silicon Valley Bank
and others yeah I think interest rates
are quite interesting because for two
reasons firstly the bank of sorry the
office for Budget responsibility it
bases its forecasts
um on assumptions about where interest
rates are going to be when it made these
four cars it didn't take into fact into
account the fact that market
expectations where interest rates are
going to be have come down considerably
since the clap collapse of Silicon
Valley Bank and so what does this mean
for the obr's forecast we already know
that they're not in line with the bank
of England's
um but this could drastically shift
um what their forecasts are and then
also ordinary people I mean if if uh
interest rates are going to Peak at a
lower level then the obr is expecting
that might have serious consequences for
the cost of living it might be our
mortgages come down who knows yeah which
again if you're talking about retail
policies and that's something that could
help quite a lot of people and thank you
very much indeed we'll have more from
both of you in a moment but there was no
movement on public sector pay as Sam was
saying and is there any good news for
household finances should we bring in
Greg Marshall to try and find out
so what does the budget mean for
ordinary households well during the
course of today no sooner the chances of
finished speaking then we started to run
some numbers and we've been looking at
three households in particular we've
been looking at Linda a retired nurse
we've been looking at Mike a comfortably
off I.T consultant and we've been
looking at Leanne a fitness instructor
and also a mother of a child so we've
tried to understand for each of these
households what today's announcements
mean let's start with Linda Linda is on
pension and disability support although
her husband still works as a result
she's seen as well as that benefit from
the freeze in the energy price guarantee
that's the 3 000 pounds that's staying
at 2500 that's good news she's also seen
an inflationary increase in her personal
Independence payments that's the
disability announced and the benefit of
the fuel Duty freeze that was announced
today
however some of that is offset by this
negative sum this this balance which is
a result of income taxes being frozen
that's called fiscal drag and it's a
stealth tax we'll talk about that more
in a minute but taken as a whole Linda
is a winner from today's budget we think
her households up about 350 pounds over
the next 12 months let's understand that
fiscal drag idea in a bit more detail
now a household like Linda's a
comfortably earning but not earning a
lot only sees a modest effect because of
those tax thresholds Frozen but
households on higher incomes 50 000 and
up they are seeing a very significant
effect as a result of their earnings
Rising but income tax thresholds staying
the same as a result every year they're
paying more tax essentially they're
getting dragged into those higher rate
tax bans and those numbers can really
add up let's take Mike as an example of
this so Mike's household as a result of
this budget also benefits a larger house
from that energy price cap and it
benefits from the freezing fuel duties
but look what happens to Mike's
household situation over the next 12
months an enormous cost associated with
those rise with those frozen income
thresholds as his salary increases and
so the consequence of putting those
pieces together is on a overall basis we
analyze mica's slightly worse off as a
result of this budget
finally let's look at Leanne a fitness
instructor she lives with her husband
also self-employed and their daughter a
four-year-old too young unfortunately to
benefit from all the child care
giveaways that the chancellor announced
earlier on energy price guarantee good
news child benefit increase very good
news for this household fuel duty-free
is excellent given how much this
household needs to drive but also losers
as a result of that fiscal drag effect
that stealth tax creeping in so overall
a household which is a little better off
as a result of the budget so there we
have it Leanne Mike Linda three very
different households three very
different pictures some winners and some
losers from today's announcement
Sam I think you're live with us in
Burley and maybe even have some of those
people with you so we can get their live
reaction
I do indeed thank you very much Greg
welcome back to Burnley in Lancashire
we've been here all day at this drop-in
center where people have been coming in
to get a hot meal even take a hot shower
uh in those shower rooms just over there
they've all gone home now it is closed
they've gone home to get on with their
lives most of them weren't terribly
interested in watching Jeremy Hunt
feeling that 200 miles away in
Westminster nobody cares much about
their lives and their day-to-day
struggles we are of course in Burnley
because it has the highest inflation
rate in the whole of Great Britain and
Greg was just spelling out some of the
situation there of people that I've been
talking to while I've been here today we
still have two of them with us we still
have Mike and Leanne Leanne coming to
you first you're relatively young person
you have a young daughter
you live in Burnley with this
ridiculously high my inflation rate when
you're looking at the budget you're
looking at your own life situation what
do you feel about the future for a young
family like yours staying in Burnley
it's just um really testing times you
know especially coming from my point of
view as you know someone who's
self-employed you know I feel like we're
always the ones sort of Left Behind
you're trying to you know do well for
yourself and you're just backpedaling
all the time and I think the government
really needs to step up and help the
working person because they're just left
behind and costs are increasing all the
time across the board everything's going
up and up and up and they make it sound
like you know by keeping it at a level
a level rate that and not increasing it
anymore that they're doing as a favor
but actually they're not people are
struggling in mental health everything
like that is on the rise suicide a lot
of Outreach work as well don't you I do
yeah you're talking to a lot of young
people is there enough support for what
people are going through no the
support's just not there at all and it's
people of all ages you know I deal with
people from Toddlers right through to
adults you know and I'm seeing it across
the board and children are suffering
following covert and everything else and
then now with the cost of living crisis
people are just really really struggling
and the support's not there at all and
it needs to be we were hearing from Mike
there that just marginally you benefit
there's not much in it no
um
it needs to be more than that doesn't it
for you you're self-employed your
husband's self-employed
talk us through the challenges and what
it feels like to think well this
budget's supposed to be for people like
me but there's only really a marginal
difference yeah and that's it you know
it it needs to be more support because
if if things keep going up and up that
it's just going to get worse the
situations just going to be on a
downward spiral people cannot cope with
any more increases they just cannot you
know can't do it people are already at
breaking point and Beyond you know and
for people that are on borderline if
things get any worse then I'd like to
think was to come
might moving on to you you're relatively
unusual in Burnley you're in a
relatively prosperous situation albeit
this budget is not to your advantage
because of that so-called fiscal drag
um where does it leave you what does it
what does it make you think about how
the budget has really treated people
like Leanne and everyone else in Burnley
well I think that's where the problem
comes as I said to you early on I'm in a
reasonably comfortable position the
stabilization of the tax rates
um will cost me a little bit of money
but I am in a comfortable enough
position that I can ride over those
bombs I can attack my belt a little bit
uh for people like Leanne and people
aren't the people in here they don't
have any more belt to tighten so Jeremy
home it's not really a surprise that a
lot of people here haven't been paying
too much attention to the budget because
there's been nothing in it for them
um you're you're in business you're an
I.T consultant
um we're expecting corporation tax to go
up which it has in terms of the measures
in there for business what do you think
it's going to mean for kick-starting
growth in the economy because that's
what's desperately needed well we are an
I.T consultancy so the r d tax offset
should help out a little bit I think but
um it rankled a bit to see Jeremy hunts
down there and say we are lawing taxes
and the labor will rise raise them while
raising corporation tax to 25 that was
already appreciated but they could have
helped business by not raising by quite
so much I think
all right uh we'll really appreciate
your time that you've spent with us here
on Sky News throughout the day as I was
saying uh Mike and Leanna going to go
home it's just another day they'll be
thinking about work and child care
whatever else it is at tomorrow
um there's a real sense here in Burnley
that what goes on down in Westminster
more than 200 miles away is like it
might as well be on another planet as
far as people think that the chancellor
has them in mind with the measures that
he has put in place that's been very
much the sense I've picked up here all
day here in Burnley the town with the
highest inflation rate in Great Britain
now let's head back to you now Sophie in
Westminster thanks very much Sam so much
coverage from Sam from Burnley talking
to some of the people that Chancellor
needs to win round in his budget
well let's turn to pensions now and that
news that the lifetime allowance which
is the total amount that workers can
accumulate in their pension savings
before paying extra tax has been
abolished now the idea is that this is
going to help drive more people back
into the workplace who might attempt to
take earlier retirement but may now I
think that actually if they can get a
bit more on their pension by working
longer they might be tempted to stay on
well earlier I spoke to Paul Johnson
he's the director of The Institute for
fiscal studies he told me he does have
some concerns about the proposed changes
I think this was quite a it was a
technical budget I think it was
genuinely making some changes which will
help the childcare corporation tax I'm
not so sure about the pensions tax
changes
um but it was and actually changes
disability benefits these are technical
but important and broadly speaking I
think sensible changes just to jump in
what why are you not so sure about the
pension
um tax contributions well I mean several
reasons I mean one chance I talked about
it as being a response to problems with
doctors in the NHS well if that was the
target you should have changed the NHS
pension scheme it didn't you don't need
to change the entire tax system to do it
secondly it will of course also allow
people to save more in their pension so
while some people may stay and work a
little bit longer because they can save
more some people might actually retire a
little bit earlier because they have
saved more because they've been able to
let's bring in our business
who joins us now live from the city we
saw that Paul Johnson raising some
concerns about how the changes to the
pension allowance might work what's your
take
well I think this is actually probably
something that's going to be welcomed by
an awful lot of people it affects more
people than uh than is often uh
acknowledged the lifetime allowance of
course caps the amount of money that you
can save into your pension pot at 1.073
million pounds anything above that is
taxed at the punitive rate of 55 and as
you've been saying it has indeed been
blamed for the early retirement of an
awful lot of professionals not just
doctors but other professionals across
the economy probably higher paid workers
who who make a good deal of her
contribution to the tax system who are
probably more productive than the
average worker and who all things being
equal you would want to keep in the
Workforce Now what Paul Johnson said is
perfectly true they could have just
tweaked the doctor's uh system and it's
also true that by abolishing the
lifetime allowance you could allow some
people to reach their their savings
goals earlier than they would have done
otherwise but bear in mind that pension
pots you can pass them on inheritance
tax free as things stand and that is a
very very powerful incentive for for a
lot of people to carry on working who
want to pass something on to their
children or their descendants without
paying inheritance tax on it so that's
another little aspect of that and the
other thing I think about this Sophie is
that it is a you can see this as a tax
simplification method because with the
existence of the annual allowance which
caps after today the amount of money you
can save annually in your pension has
sixty thousand pounds a year you are
already inhibiting the ability of the
very well off to save into a pension
fund there's no need on that basis for a
lifetime allowance and as such it was
really only punishing punishing prudent
Savers and those who invested their
retirement saving sensibly so I think in
that sense it will be seen as a welcome
piece of tax simplification and it also
rights a wrong that's been done to a lot
of probably natural conservative voters
over the last decade it was Gordon Brown
that introduced the lifetime allowance
back in 2006 but it's really hurt since
uh George Osborne began cutting it quite
aggressively in 2010 onwards
it very much indeed Ian King there are
giving us his take on those changes to
the pensions allowances
now I just want to show you these images
because while the chancellor was
delivering his budget inside Westminster
the streets outside were filled with
tens of thousands of striking workers
who marched through Central London
ministers have resisted demands for
public sector pay Rises to keep up with
inflation more than 400 000 workers
across a range of sectors are on strike
and disputes overpay and it's thought to
be the biggest day of industrial action
since the current wave of unrest began
last year well let's go live now to the
march in central London and Sky's Ashley
harinag is there well there was very
little uh in the budget wasn't there
that is going to impact those strikes
and people are very disappointed by that
it has to be said so if you know there
was mention of child care which of
course would help those workers but also
of Pensions and of other things too
things like fuel Duty for example a cut
to that and I think lots of people were
disappointed though that their concerns
when it came to the dispute and the
strike action that's that's come of that
was not mentioned do you have teachers
here today we are junior doctors uh we
had University lecturers and Tube
drivers here in London and I have to say
it was an extraordinary turnout I think
the chancellor could would rather have
delivered his Budget on a day where we
didn't have such a turnout here snaking
through the streets of the capital and
culminating here in Trafalgar Square
where only about an hour ago this was
very very different it was absolutely
packed there were so many so many people
here from from Across the Nation people
from Leeds we spoke to people from
Sheffield from Rochdale and and majority
were teachers actually we spoke to lots
of them about why they decide decided to
make the journey here into the capital
by no coincidence of course on the same
day that the chancellor was delivering
his budget and here's what some of them
told me
[Music]
well I believe that we can't bring you
those uh people that we spoke to earlier
on but some of the things they they
noted particularly those teachers were
the fact that teaching assistants in
their classrooms though some of them
didn't have them anymore they said that
resources were they were really
struggling with a lack of those not only
things like rubbers and pencils but
actual physical stuff they also said
that many of them had a problem with
retaining those staff numbers and it's
not just a problem that's affecting
primary schools but secondary schools
too there was such a strength of feeling
where we saw so many of the Union
general secretaries taking to the stage
some have been saying this is what
solidarity feels like and there was a
real feeling of camaraderie here in
central London I mean from the
government's point of view they have
said they've come to the table on
numerous occasions and those
negotiations still need to be had but
from the Union's perspective they expect
there to be a significant escalation and
yes this was the biggest national day of
strike action yet but more of that they
say is to come Ashner thank you very
much indeed more to come at clearly the
message from the strikes today with the
latest person to join our budget
analysis at table is the director the
resolution Foundation talks about good
to have you here we've just been seeing
those pictures of the strikes and It
just strikes me that
we talked a lot about what was in the
budget one thing that didn't seem to be
in the budget very much was the public
sector and public services do you think
that that was surprising yeah I think
that's broadly right the Chancellor's
interested in some long-term reforms
that make a difference to growth be that
on investment by businesses or uh who's
going into work what he didn't focus on
is the Public Services generally that's
true in the short term in terms of
public sector pay the treasury wants to
leave that to be dealt with in the next
few months doesn't want to pretend
that's out there's more money on the
table now when they haven't resolved
those paid disputes and he didn't want
to make a difference to the longer term
problem which is really quite tight
probably implausibly tight public
spending plans for after the next
election those have all been left in
place and they'll be dealt with by
another budget or another Chancellor
implausibly tight what expand on that so
we are penciling in about a one percent
real growth in public spending in the
Years Beyond this spending review which
basically means this Parliament if you
want to also increase depending on
defense to 2.5 percent of GDP and you
want to protect the Health Service and
you'd like to protect schools to some
extent that would mean pretty huge cuts
to other departments those aren't going
to happen that's interesting um let's
talk about what
shall we uh Jeremy Hunt dubbed a budget
for growth do you think that's a fair
assessment well he said he when he says
budget for growth he means two
objectives getting business investment
up and getting economic inactivity down
which is a posh way of saying getting
more people into work and on the second
of those he had quite a lot to offer and
in particular on child care that will
make a big difference to a particularly
a small group of parents those with
young children that's a pretty big
change what's happening there so yes
unemployment and on investment no
because we've unwisely gone ahead with
yet another temporary change to the
corporate tax regime rather than putting
in place a long-term settlement and the
result of that is that we're bringing
forward some business investment so
we'll get some next year but we won't
see any permanent increase in business
investment and the long-term problem for
the British economy is that our
businesses do not invest at the rates we
see in France Germany and the us and
this isn't going to solve that in the
medium terms quite expensive they're
nine billion pounds I mean more than the
child care package right yeah but nine
billion but temporary and the reason
it's temporary is because the chancellor
is trying to stick to his fiscal rule to
have debt Falling by the end of this
forecast period and he doesn't want to
raise any taxes because he's already
been clobbered over the head by
conservative MPS for that and if you
bring those two things together you end
up with a silly situation which you've
set announced another temporary
corporate tax regime when what
businesses want is a good corporate tax
regime but they also want one that stays
and is certain and we've just said to
them again we can't do that
Sam
um Tulsa if you were the chancellor and
you knew that there was an election a
year away you had decided not to do
anything that really helps people in
their pockets today but you're gonna
want to do tax cuts at some point before
the next election what's striking today
is that Jerry had ended up spending so
much money leaving himself so little
wiggle room he really does you were just
saying care about those fiscal rules
hasn't he found his own hands today and
left himself very little to play with in
the run-up the election or to be fair to
Jeremy Hunt there is some help for
households today he's avoided the big a
spike in energy bills coming into place
in April and if you fill up your car
then fuel Duty isn't going up in April
so he's stopped it getting worse
um and that people notice things that
happen and people may not feel that it
makes them feel like good news because
everyone's incomes are going down again
next year in fact it's the biggest fall
of incomes over two years on record but
he's doing something and that's why he's
spending quite a lot of money in terms
of the money the obr gave him today in
terms of improved forecast he's spending
about two-thirds of that but you're
right he's not spending it at the back
end and that's because he's got himself
a fiscal rule that is binding he's got
the lowest Headroom on record against
that rule so not much space if he sticks
with that rule for tax cuts next year
all I would say is that Headroom can
change a lot with a number of different
assumptions changing and he's got
probably two more goes for that Headroom
to exist and he doesn't need that much
Headroom if he's immediately before an
election because he can then run right
up to the wire in terms of that fiscal
rule if he is not doing The Prudent
thing and giving himself a big amount of
Headroom but the big lesson from history
is that chancellors should be leaving
themselves more Headroom against their
fiscal rules so they don't end up doing
short-term things just to make sure they
stick to those rules but that's not what
he did in the Autumn and that's why
we've ended up with a silly corporate
tax package today and it's not what he's
done today a lovely thing to say that
wouldn't it how significant is this on
economic inactivity because there are
about half a million more people
inactive now than there were before the
pandemic the obl says that these
policies will get 110 000 people into
work is that significant enough so this
is a bit of a cop-out but there's two
answers to that one is I think insofar
as budgets go this is quite a big
package of measures to all bring
together at once folks on older workers
on parents and on those who are sick and
bring those all together so I think it's
a big material package that will have
some difference
the other answer is that the actual
scale of the increase 110 000 the office
and budget responsibility say that's
about 0.3 percent of the workforce it's
actually smaller as an increase than the
change in the obr's migration assumption
is in terms of the number of workers and
as you pointed out it's smaller than the
increase in inactivity we've seen since
the pandemic so I think taking in the
macroeconomic perspective no like with
most budgets it doesn't make much
difference in the in the roundings in
terms of a set of policy measures I
think the chances are set out quite a
lot actually
okay thank you very much indeed always
good to get your analysis to Austin Bell
there from the resolution Foundation
well let's have a bit of a recap shall
we if you're just joining us we can look
through some of the announcements that
were made the energy price guarantee
will now continue until June with
household bills remaining at 2 500
pounds the chancellor has promised 30
hours of free childcare a week to
working parents in England with children
aged between nine months and five years
and Jeremy Hunt also announced what he
called Full expensive now that's a nine
billion pound scheme which means every
pound a company invests in it equipment
and Machinery can be deducted from
taxable profits
he adopted the budget to try and boost
growth and the government will invest 80
million pounds over five years in 12 new
UK Investments
zones the lifetime allowance which is
the total amount that workers can
accumulate in their pension savings
before paying extra tax that's been
abolished
for joining us now to discuss this in a
bit more detail is the Deputy leader of
the liberal Democrats Daisy Cooper
actually that is definitely not Daisy
Cooper apologies uh Sarah Olney is here
for the liberal Democrats also as Stuart
Jose who is the S P's economy at
spokesperson good to have you uh both on
let's start with you since we made the
uh on the guesting uh what's your
reaction to the budget well I mean I
think so many households are going to be
really disappointed with that
everybody's really feeling the squeeze
right now because fuel builds are going
up food bills are going up everyone's
paying more tax because the uh the
government have Frozen the the
thresholds everyone's paying more on
their mortgage of course because
interest rates spiked after the mini
budget so there are so many expenses
that are piling onto households right
now and I think what would have been uh
what people were looking for was some
immediate relief what we were calling
for was to see not just the energy price
guarantee held at 2 500 for it to go
down to 2000. that would have put it
back to where it was uh last year and I
think that would have made an immediate
difference right now to people's ability
just to afford the Basics and that's
going to be really important what's your
main takeaway I think there were two
things he spoke a lot perfectly
understandably about visiting
productivity boosting growth growing the
economy but then he didn't really do an
awful lot in that regard and if you look
at the productivity growth numbers over
the forecast period they don't even hit
1.5 the below the two percent historic
average for the entire forecast period
they haven't proved a bit though right
well no one or two of the years are
actually lower than the forecast only
four months ago just anyway that's
really an Iraqi stuff but it's not quite
what it seemed and I think Sarah's
actually right
because he had that little bit more
Headroom although very little a little
bit more Headroom he should have brought
down the energy price cap to two
thousand pounds he should have
maintained the 400 pound energy support
package as well which was Universal that
would have helped he could have actually
used those measures to tackle and
squeeze and Bear Down on inflation but
he chose not to and if he's hanging his
hat on and flashing falling off to 2.9
percent while ignoring grocery inflation
at 17
telecoms inflation at 15 he might be in
for a heck of a shock next spring or
next autumn
you must welcome Sarah only though some
of the childcare measures we've had some
um support from the labor side on this
well absolutely the 2019 liberal
Democrat Manifesto we had a really
generous child care package and it's
great to see that the chancellor seems
to have adopted most of it but I think
there's there's some questions
outstanding uh I think we've got some
questions certainly about the ratio and
comparing it to Scotland obviously but
in Scotland they have uh you know higher
requirements for skills and and uh and
so on so I don't think it's a direct
comparison but also big questions about
if you're going to boost the demand for
child care which is what this will do
what are you doing to increase the
supply and I would have loved to have
heard some more there about training
child care workers bringing people in
you know boosting pay for child care
workers it's so important that we have
quality child care and I'm speaking very
much from experience here as one of
those people who you know over the last
decade just had to spend a lot of money
on child care so I'm you know I'm really
well aware of the issues that working
parents are facing but you've got to be
able to guarantee good quality Child
Care otherwise I don't know that people
are necessarily going to be attempted to
take it out I'm teaching to bring in
both and Sam and gerprit but before I do
can I just ask you if I know about
another story um away from the budget
because there's been an open letter on
behalf of two of the three candidates in
the s p leadership
um competition and they want to know the
number of s p members in the electorate
saying that the HQ are keeping the
details secret that there's concerns
about the way that the process is being
run what on Earth is going on here well
what now there's a good one is all three
candidates as I've said we publish the
membership numbers and I'm perfectly
relaxed about that perfectly relaxed
about that I would say one thing this is
an internal SNP election and if anyone
on the table can give me the precise
membership of the labor party the tour
Department in other dance I'll give them
a Fiverr parties tend not to publish
these things but I've got no problem if
those numbers are published it feels
like there is shall we say some
old contest is exposing some of the
factionalism within the SNP and do you
think that is a fair it does certainly
seem to say you know we had for example
you know one of the candidates on Sunday
saying that there was a conflict of
interest with Nicholas sturgeon's
husband being involved in the contest
husband isn't involved in the contest
he's the chief executive of the party
the election has been carried about an
independent third-party private company
quite right quite proper we've used them
many times other organizations use them
there's a lot of trumpian conspiracy
nonsense been spoken two with the three
candidates
the membership will be published the
votes are being cast as we speak they'll
be added up by an independent company
and a leader will be announced on the
27th thereafter all of this nonsense
will never be discussed again
[Laughter]
uh
both of you uh
um talking to the labor party it wasn't
clear to me that actually they're going
to oppose vote against anything in
today's budget if it's pushed if it
pushed the vote there are controversial
things in today's budget I think the
abolition of the pensions uh cap uh
could turn out because it benefits the
wealthy a small number of people could
turn out to be quite divisive as if
stands do you think that the smps do you
think the liberal Democrats will oppose
anything that you've seen today yes I
mean one of it was obvious when he was
talking about economic inactivity he had
to do something to bring more people
back into the labor market
self-evidently the case some of the
measures are expensive but they might
not bring huge numbers back but of
course the sting in the tail because
Tories always do this is they intend to
be more punitive to Universal uh credit
claimants I think that's something the
SMP absolutely would oppose 100 percent
it's difficult to know what kind of uh
votes we're going to get we won't be
votes on individual measures but um you
can always push one so well imagine that
you could pick one that you want to
oppose I mean I tend to agree with
Stuart I I you know he didn't allow
elaborate too much on what he meant
about that but that's that's something I
do find really concerning we already see
so much hardship across all of our
constituencies and so much of it arises
from the sanctions regime in in benefits
and it does always feel like for those
on Lower incomes it's sanctions to get
you back into work whereas those on
higher incomes it's you know it's they
get the carrot so
um I can't I'm not going to sit here and
say absolutely definitively yes we're
going to vote against this but that
would certainly be something there is
another measures of course he announced
this
money for uh small nuclear modular
reactors not a single one of these has a
design which has yet been approved how
much money is he prepared to commit to
an untested technology in the nuclear
field again I wouldn't be at all
surprised if we look extremely carefully
at that and say we might be better
deploying that money for real green
Renewables
I'm just a question to both of you on
the energy price guarantee do you really
think that's the most sensible way to be
supporting households I mean it's a
completely untargeted policy and it has
the potential to actually increase
inflation because you're putting money
into people's pockets rich and poor and
you're giving the money to go out and
spend in the real economy which has the
negative effect of boosting inflation
it's something that economists have
warned about so would you not do you not
think that maybe a more targeted
approach would be better to supporting
households so I think in the context of
all these other squeezes on people's
income uh I think you know a bit of
extra support to uh for people's fuel
bills when they are at historically high
levels I could say 500 pounds higher
than they were last year
um I think you're right it would be
better if it were targeted but what they
found when they were implementing the
scheme is there is no good way of
targeting we don't have a sort of a list
of everybody's income and we can't say
who's really struggling with their fuel
bills and who's not so that's why it's
always been a kind of a universal scheme
just simply there's no other way of
doing it and what I'm talking about is
getting money into people's pockets
right now not in 2025 when their free
child care comes in this is something we
need right now we need this summer
because people are really struggling
right now we think inflation overall
will come down by the end of the year
and so we'll be facing a different
situation you know in 12 months time but
right now this is the thing that could
really help the thing that I would quite
like to talk to you both about is
something that wasn't actually in the
budget but something was going on
outside which is those huge action day
of strikes and we are of course seeing
strikes continuing across the country I
know that lots of people watching are
going to have kids at home that may be
watching the TV while juggling two kids
who because their schools are sharp
because of strikes we've had transport
workers at striking today as well
nothing on the budget on that what
should be done to try and solve this
well these strikes are only happening
because of the financial pressures you
know if someone's on even a reasonable
wage but they're being hit by 10 12 13
14 inflation and you know the
information for those on most modest
incomes being even higher then it's
perfectly understandable these disputes
are happening so what I said in the
response today and I I stand by this the
government should even if they didn't
announce the numbers today made a
commitment for the Autumn that the
things in their control public sector
pay their pensions benefits they should
be looking to raise those in line with
inflation to make sure people do not
fall further behind that would take away
a lot of the pain a lot of the heat but
on some of those disputes there's a
secondary political issue UK government
ministers have got to get around the
table and actually negotiate
so well I agree with Stuart's second
point there I mean I don't know what the
government strategy is for resolving
these disputes but we have had so much
disruption in the public sector I'm one
of those parents who's still from the
home today
um and you know how many operations have
we lost how much bigger has the queue
got in the NHS because of all the days
lost to strikes by nurses doc doctors
ambulance workers but what's the
government strategy you know there's
been too much this macho posturing for
too long it took the months to get
around the table with the nurses the
only way they're going to resolve it is
by negotiation and that should have been
the strategy from day one okay thank you
very much indeed both of you coming on
and sharing uh your thoughts some
reaction there from both the s p and the
liberal Democrats
well in the meantime let's go back to
Sam shall we who is standing by in
Burnley talking to the people who really
matter in all this the people who are
voters
yes thank you very much Sophie we've
been here all day as you say in Burnley
in Lancashire it is the town in Great
Britain with the highest inflation rate
in all of uh in in all of Great Britain
as I was saying those measures were
announced more than 200 miles away in
Westminster so we've been talking to
Folks up here to see whether any of them
are going to have a material impact on
day-to-day life for families and indeed
business owners are living here well I'm
joined now by the owner of Via Roma
Fashions at Fraser Kerry a Fraser good
to see you thanks so much for coming
over here
um do you get a sense that there is
anything in the budget itself or in the
government's thinking for small
businesses no again small medium
Enterprises are not being shown within
this budget there's nothing within it
that sort of made me feel confident I
was where we're moving towards as a
business is this energy price cup that
they're doing and they're carrying on
for another couple of months in
comparison to this time last year in
April is still 20 more expensive you
know so our consumers aren't feeling
like the pressure is off so we're you
know it it's just becoming
every single week it's getting more and
more difficult and we're seeing it as
today I've been working today we've had
a couple of people in and people just
don't have the disposable income at the
minute to be buying the luxuries yeah I
mean because you are a luxury clothing
yes it is we can kind of tell that by
looking at your get up today thank you
um Rosa but business has been slow it's
fair to say yes it has been slow and the
the budget announcement hasn't made that
any better and there's nothing within
that that makes me feel confident that
things are going to get better you know
um I just feel like for you as a
business for us as a business or or for
people in the general public you know
it's the rate of inflation is ridiculous
everything's expensive and you know I
just don't see an end to it you know I I
haven't seen anything within this budget
that makes me feel confident that we're
moving in the right direction oh you're
from Burnley no I'm originally from
London but I've got family from up here
so I've been here for about eight years
now and so what do you think about your
future in Burnley trying to run a
business uh well it's
it's tough it's tough It's one of the
lowest income areas in the country I
think so it's it was already tough and
now it's just getting worse and worse
and you know these big corporations are
swooping in and they're the ones making
the money but we are small Independents
just aren't being represented and I
didn't really get to listen to the
budget properly because I've been
working but from just the the the sort
of the uh the bullet points of it I
didn't hear anything for smes that made
me feel confident at all and it's just
going to get worse so or for leveling up
awful leveling up or just there's no
seen any sign of leveling there's no
incentive for Independence to to grow
there's no incentive for Independence to
sort of make some money to sort of
progress you know or scale their
businesses as such they're just there's
not the opportunity to do it okay well
really interesting uh talking to you and
getting your perspective we've been
talking to people
um across the Spectrum today in in
Burnley different incomes different
social situations and the message has
pretty much been the same but uh you
know the the messages being delivered
down in Westminster by the government
did not necessarily have the people or
indeed the businesses of Burnley in uh
in front of mind uh back to you Sophie
in Westminster
thanks so much Sam lots of coverage
there from Sam Washington in Burnley
well let's bring in Sam and gurpreet
shall we for a bit of a final thought
we've been on air since 11 we've had an
awful lot of analysis from everyone from
the obr to the ifs we've had
conservatives labor lib Dems SMP
Sam what's your reaction
that in the office for Budget
responsibility report which few normal
people actually read it says that
there's going to be a six percent drop
in living standards over the next couple
of years and that's the biggest since
the 1950s
and while we talk about the whole
plethora of measures from Child Care to
help for businesses that just stands out
as an absolutely hideous backdrop for
the sunac administration to go forward
and fight an election against there was
a bit of help a bit of help largely to
stop more bad things happening not
really that people will feel if anything
more people are going to be paying more
tax because of what's known as fiscal
drag and being people being caught up is
um uh because of inflation so I I'm not
sure that what the chancellor chose
today to do will particularly help the
conservatives of the next elections
that's a bold choice and that is the big
thing really isn't it for the
conservative party thank you very much
indeed Sam can I pray what are your
thoughts well when we're thinking about
the economy Jeremy Hunt celebrating the
fact that we're avoiding a technical
recession is probably quite a low bar to
judge ourselves against and the economy
is going to shrink this year the
forecast it isn't fantastic nothing to
celebrate uh too much but the government
does have a little bit of extra room to
borrow
but the fiscal Headroom at the end of
the forecast period
it's not March and it doesn't give them
much room for many pre-election
giveaways as Sam just mentioned but for
everyone sitting at home
declining living standards is the thing
that they're going to be feeling High
inflation it's eating into their
disposable incomes higher taxes eating
into their uh disposable incomes and all
of that makes for a pretty bleak
backdrop for the coming years thank you
very much both for all of your analysis
well that is it from this Sky News
special coverage of the spring budget
it's been an absolute pleasure to be
with you a budget the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt hopes will prove the doubters wrong
while Labor's care starmer branded it
cheap tricks from the government of
gimmicks we've been getting all the
reactions from Westminster and across
the UK let's take a look back at some of
the highlights of the day
since mid-october 10-year guilt rates
have fallen debt servicing costs are
down mortgage rates are lower and
inflation has peaked
International
tree fund
says our approach means the UK economy
is on the right track
but we remain Vigilant and will not
hesitate to take whatever steps are
necessary for economic stability
today the office for Budget
responsibility forecasts that because of
changing International factors and the
measures I take the UK will not now
enter a technical recession this year
they know it's not the government that's
lowering inflation it's working people
earning less enjoying less it's their
sacrifice that is helping to bring
inflation down and they deserve better
than another Cheap Trick from the
government of gimmicks making them pay
whilst trying to claim the credit
even with the price guarantee the
average Energy bill has doubled in 18
months
because of their recklessness the
average mortgage payment is up 2 000
pounds a year a massive hit to living
standards however they cook the books
you're going to lose the the energy bill
support and that's the thing that was
really affecting your budget most energy
bills six to seven pound a month which
I'm going to be losing which is a lot of
money
you know I'm in another the cat stop the
cat from going up which is good but then
they're taking it out in the other end
with the support
energy support grants so I can't see how
I'm going to be better off at all really
well they might be avoiding a technical
recession they may have improved
slightly when it comes to those economic
forecasts but still predicting the
biggest fall in living standards since
records began that is it from me Mark
Austin though is going to be guiding you
through all of the budget analysis
coming up
[Music]
foreign